Wenn du ein genialer Spieler bist, aber ein Riesenarschloch, dann kann ich darauf gern verzichten. Mit der Weltmasterschaft im eigenen Land ist es auch ein sehr, sehr ernsthaftes Ziel. Und der Rudi Völler, glaube ich, der macht in einer Art zu spielen und jetzt geht es erstmal wieder bei Null los, aber ich denke, das ist eigentlich überhaupt kein Problem, weil es wie überall im Leben ist, wenn ich über einen langen Zeitraum meine Leistung bringe, dann kommt er gar nicht vorbei an mir. Ich bin einfach irgendwie davongelaufen und dann wurde es halt zufällig Australien.
Absolut hervorragend von Thomas Broich. Thomas Broich ist heute hier im Rasenfunk im Tribüngespräch. Hallo Thomas. Sehr schön, dass du hier bist. Bist du eigentlich at thomas-broich22 auf Twitter?
Ähm, boah, das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht. Ich hab mir irgendwann mal einen Account zugelegt, aber da gibt's ein paar wohl unter meinem Namen und welche genau als ich bin. Das weiß ich gar nicht, weil ich hab noch nie getweetet und erfolge auch niemandem.
Okay, dann werden wir das auf jeden Fall nicht verlinken. Da sag ich schon häufig bei den Gästen dazu, deswegen wollte ich es jetzt hier abklopfen. Aber das ist ein komisches Gefühl, oder? Wenn es so Thomas-Broich-Klone gibt. Das ist mir nämlich auch aufgefallen bei der Recherche.
Ist schon irgendwie seltsam, vor allem, ich hab dann irgendwann mal versucht, zumindest irgendwie Twitter und Facebook mal darauf aufmerksam zu machen und vielleicht diese ganz offensichtlichen Faker dann irgendwie auch zu sperren. Und das ist unheimlich kompliziert.
Okay.
Also die wollten da so viel Beweismaterial quasi und es gibt ja auch diesen Verifizierungshaken nicht mehr und solche Sachen, dass ich tatsächlich irgendwie ein paar Mal Mails von denen bekommen habe, aber es reicht noch nicht aus und dann habe ich wieder aufgegeben und hoffe einfach, dass die Leute da kein Schindl oder treiben.
Ja, das, was ich gesehen habe, war eigentlich alles in Ordnung, was die Leute da gemacht haben und Twitter und Facebook, die haben da ihre eigene Policy. Wir wollen heute über deine Karriere sprechen und über alles, was du jetzt auch gerade so machst. Ich freue mich sehr, dass du dir die Zeit dafür nimmst und dass wir heute ein Tribünengespräch aufzeichnen können für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die neu zum Rasenfunk stoßen. Mein Name ist Max Sackop-Ost, ich bin der Ed Gehnetzer bei Twitter. Bevor wir loslegen, möchte ich danken Rehklett, Max Spania, Roland, Linus und Simon. Sie alle sind Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützer des Rasenfunks. Wir sind werbe- und sponsorenfrei, finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure finanzielle Unterstützung. Wie ihr das tun könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/unterstützen. Vielen Dank für alle, die das an der Stelle schon getan haben. Thomas, erzähl mir was von Australien. Was macht Australien so besonders?
Boah, lange Liste, würde ich sagen. Das, was für mich am coolsten war, dass die Leute das sind, was die Australier non-judgmental nennen. Also du kannst eigentlich tun und lassen, was du willst. Und Leute zeigen sich erst mal eher begeistert und interessiert. Also in Deutschland ist es eher so, dass wir so eine gesunde Skepsis in uns tragen und sich beruflich verändern oder die Stadt wechseln oder solche Geschichten. Das ist immer so ein bisschen auch Abenteuer. Auch so ein bisschen Risiko, hab ich das Gefühl. Für den Australier ist gefühlt alles einfach nur eine Riesenchance.
Ja, das stimmt. Ich war auch nämlich in Australien, aber das ist schon, mein Gott, das war 1999, glaube ich, wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere. Also schon ewig her. Und deswegen wollte ich mir jetzt noch mal von dir ein bisschen dieses Australien-Feeling zurückhören. Da hatte ich auch den Eindruck, damals haben alle gesagt, how do you like it here, also halt in ihrem australischen Englisch, das kriege ich jetzt nicht hin. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja alles toll. Und dann haben sie gesagt, ja geil, dann kommst du wieder, machst dir einen Laden auf und lebst halt einfach hier in Australien. Also das war quasi die zweite Antwort zu, wie geht es dir hier? In Deutschland wäre die zweite Antwort gewesen, hätte es wahrscheinlich gar nicht gegeben. Weil gut hätte schon gereicht.
Also ich habe da teilweise absurdeste Beispiele für Freunde der Musiker, der hat es mit der Musik dann irgendwie nur so halb hingekriegt, also war in einer Band und in einem Musikladen, wie das halt immer so ist, und hatte Familie mit drei Kindern und meinte dann mit 40 so, ja, er könnte jetzt mal mit einer Elektrikerlehre anfangen. Und dann hat er das so erzählt und alle fanden das irgendwie total geil. Also nachdem auch, ja cool, mach das und so. Und dann irgendwie nach einem Jahr war es dann wieder so, na Elektriker, das ist nicht sein Ding, er ist Musiker, durch und durch und so. Also er probiert es jetzt nochmal mit der Musik und war dann mit 40 plötzlich wieder mitten im Nachtleben und hat irgendwie von Donnerstag bis Sonntag irgendwie einem Gegner am anderen gespielt. Und die Leute haben einfach das dann wieder abgefeiert. So nach dem Motto, ja geil, go for it, also follow your bliss, so diese Sache, mach was dir wirklich am Herzen liegt. Und es war nie dieses Ding, was man in Deutschland ja voll häufig hat. So nach dem Motto, ja meinst du schon, dass das vernünftig ist? Und ja, du weißt, also im Hinblick auf die Rente und ja die Kinder und überhaupt dein Alter, irgendwie hatte ich das Gefühl und das ist ein sehr extremes Beispiel, aber dass irgendwie dieses anything goes da wirklich gelebt wird.
Und das kennt man ja auch so ein bisschen aus den USA, da war ich jetzt noch nicht selbst, aber da habe ich immer den Eindruck, es wird dann ein bisschen oberflächlicher gewertet. Fandest du, dass die Australier auch oberflächlich sind in dem Sinne? Oder ist das eine ehrliche Begeisterung?
Ich weiß, was der Deutsche damit meint und auch fühlt, weil das...
Das ist eine deutsch-deutsche Frage, ne?
Ja, eher schon. Also es ist natürlich auch ein bisschen so, aber ich finde es einfach geiler, wenn deine Grundreaktion erst mal ist, ja klar, probier das aus. Mannschaftskameraat von uns hat einen Kaffee aufgemacht. Wir alle wissen, dass irgendwie zehn Prozent aller Kaffees nur das erste Jahr überleben. Von diesen zehn Prozent überleben wieder nur zehn Prozent. Das zweite, also es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund, einen Kaffee aufzumachen. Alles okay, aber wenn du in der Situation bist, es ist doch tausendmal geiler, wenn die Leute um dich rum sagen, hey, go for it, mach's einfach. Und ob jetzt das eine oder das andere richtiger ist und näher dran an der Realität, spielt eigentlich erstmal keine Rolle. In erster Linie zählt doch das Gefühl, was du im Leben permanent in deiner Magen-Gegend rumträgst. Und da bin ich im Zweifel auf der vermeintlich oberflächlicheren Seite, die aber irgendwie einfach optimistischer ist.
Ja, da kann man nicht gegenargumentieren, das hört sich auch sehr gut an. Unterscheidet sich denn Brisbane, wo du dann deine Karriere hast ausklingen lassen, noch mal vom Rest Australiens? Australien ist ja sehr, sehr groß.
Doch, wir müssen ja schon mal tausend Kilometer zurücklegen, um überhaupt nach Sydney zu gelangen. Und das ist so die nächste größere Stadt. Melbourne ist dann noch mal anderthalb Stunden weiter beim Flieger. Und diese ganz großen Städte, also die Ballungszentren sind dann so 4-5 Millionen. Das ist schon ein bisschen hektischer. Also wenn wir sagen hektischer, dann reden wir über australisches Hektisch. Das ist immer noch überschaubar, aber das ist dann auch ein bisschen mehr also Fokus auf Karriere und auch ein bisschen schicker und hipper. Und Brisbane ist schon sehr, sehr laid back, wie die Australier sagen. Also allein dadurch, dass es recht tropisch ist, also die Luftfeuchtigkeit durch die Hitze, willst du da auch gar nicht so wirklich buckeln. Also da spielt sich viel im Freien ab, da wird auch viel gechillt und das Tempo in der Stadt ist einfach noch mal ein Ticken langsamer als in Sydney oder Melbourne.
Platz 38 von 231 Städten in der Rangliste der Lebensqualität 2018 habe ich gelesen, das hat sich tatsächlich ganz gut angehört und du hast ja dann auch deinen Wohnort da direkt in die Stadt rein verlegt, an den Stadtstrand, direkt vor deiner Tür.
Ja das war in den ersten zweieinhalb Jahren oder so. Ich wusste ja nicht, was mich da erwartet. Macht ja irgendwie Sinn da mitten rein zu gehen, wenn man neu ankommt. Kurze Wege und schön war es ja da auch so am Fluss mit Stadtstrand und überall Restaurants und Lokale um einen rum. Hab das dann aber nach einer gewissen Zeit dann auch wieder abgebrochen und hab mir dann tatsächlich dort unten, weil ich wirklich den Plan hatte, auch lange zu bleiben, also vielleicht auch ganz zu bleiben, hab mir dann ein Haus gekauft mit Pool, also immer noch zentral, aber so ein bisschen weiter raus und das war noch geiler. Also mein Haus war da so ein Palmen umsäumt und ich hatte so meinen kleinen privaten Pool und das war schon echt das Leben, wie man sich es er träumt. Also so vormittags trainieren, wir mussten immer extrem früh trainieren, waren dann aber entsprechend um die Mittagszeit. Ja, Luftfeuchtigkeit, also gerade im Sommer. Wir mussten eigentlich um sieben anfangen mit dem Training und dann bist du halt um neun, halb zehn fertig und dann hast du noch Video-Besprechung und Massage und wenn du Glück hast, bist du irgendwie um halb eins daheim. Und dann war natürlich der Nachmittag erstmal frei und dann haben da Palmen und Pool auf eingewartet. Also das war schon ein geiles Heilheit.
Das glaube ich. Und du hast ein Jahrhundert Hochwasser erlebt, war das auch einer der Gründe, da rauszuziehen aus dem Flussnähe?
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Also es war damals schon krass. Es waren auch irgendwie wirklich dunkle Bilder, also dunkel im Wurzeln. Es hatte so etwas total Gespenstisches.
30.000 Gebäude beschädigt, habe ich nachgelesen.
Ja und vor allem die Stadt, wie du sie kennst, eine Großstadt mit Hochhäusern, immer beleuchtet und so. Wenn dann auf einmal irgendwie nur noch 20 Prozent der Lichter brennen, das ist schon irgendwie gespenstisch.
Okay, aber war nicht der Grund, da unten rauszuziehen. Jetzt weißt du jetzt sehr viel über Australien. Wie viel wusstest du denn damals, als der Wechsel zustande kam? Das war im Jahr 2010.
Extrem weniger. Also ich muss sogar gestehen, als der Dario Vidozic, mein Mitspieler damals, in Nürnberg mir erzählt hat, ja, mein Papa, der ist bei Brisbane Roar Trainer. Also wenn es für dich in Deutschland hier wirklich gar nicht mehr weitergeht, also bevor du jetzt die Schuhe an den Agel hängst, probierst du da mal, da dachte ich damals noch, dass Brisbane Roar, also R-A-W, geschrieben wird. Also Roar, das hat sich mir einfach auch nicht erschlossen direkt mal. Und so phonetisch war das für mich irgendwie so, ja, muss Roar sein.
Und dann hast du es gegoogelt und Google hat gesagt, meinten sie Brisbane Roar wie der Roar eben das Geräusch?
Dann hab ich unser Maskottchen mal gesehen, so ein Teddybär-artiger Löwe. Also nicht unbedingt furchtanflößend. Und ja, das ist ja so ein bisschen komisch. Also mit den Vereinsnamen in Amerika und Australien, da beklecken sie sich glaube ich nicht mit Ruhm.
Ja, da werden wir später noch über so einige Gegner von euch sprechen. Sehr gut hat mir gefallen, zum Beispiel Perth Glory finde ich immer ganz gut, wenn man schon einfach den Ruhm in seinen Vereinsnamen reinschreibt, damit man ihn dann auch auf jeden Fall hat. Wie war denn das dann genau? Also Dario Vidozic, ihr habt damals beim 1. FC Nürnberg zusammengespielt, wir kommen zu der Zeit dann auch nochmal später zurück. Es war für dich keine glückliche Zeit, du wolltest dich verändern und du wolltest doch unbedingt weg aus Deutschland, im Intro haben wir gehört, möglichst weit weg.
Ja, also ich hatte damals das Gefühl, es geht hier einfach nicht weiter. Also ich hatte ja in Gladbach erst eine ganz gute Zeit, dann eine schlechtere, dachte irgendwie, komm, jetzt kriegst du das in Köln nochmal auf die Reihe. Da waren es auch viele Höhen und Tiefen und mehr Tiefen auch definitiv und hab dann am Ende ja auch nicht mehr gespielt. Und dann kam eben Nürnberg und dann mit meinem, ja, ich würde fast schon sagen, Kumpel Michael Ehrning, der mich aus der Gladbacher Zeit dann noch kannte, dachte ich, komm, jetzt ist nochmal deine eine Chance. Und dann hat das halt einfach schon wieder nicht geklappt. Und ich konnte einfach nicht mehr, ich war so unglücklich irgendwie mit der Gesamtsituation. Und dann wollte ich eigentlich, also ich hab ernsthaft mit dem Gedanken gespielt, einfach aufzuhören. Und umso mehr ist alles, was danach passiert ist. Also es fühlt sich so an wie ein krasses Geschenk. Also ich fand es auch so geil, dass mein Berater, Berater haben ja immer so einen zweifelhaften Ruf, der hat mich so bearbeitet, einfach nicht aufzuhören. Und dann kam eben die Sache mit Dario, dass sein Papa da irgendwie Co-Trainer war und der hat mir das auch so richtig schmackhaft gemacht.
Mit was hat er das dir schmackhaft gemacht?
Ja, dass er sagt, ey, du bist ein cooler Kicker und da unten wirst du Erfolg haben und das Leben da und du wolltest unbedingt mal ins Ausland und irgendwie Fußballer sein. Also klar, wenn es schlecht läuft, verpflucht man es, aber es gibt doch eigentlich auch nichts Geileres und so. Warum diese Sache dran geben, also das war nicht nur Darius Worte, sondern auch von meiner Mom oder von meinem Berater. So dieses Ding, du bist einmal in deinem Leben Fußballer. Es gibt auch keinen Weg zurück mehr. Also wenn du jetzt aufhörst, du kannst fünf Jahre später nicht sagen, ach weißt du was, ich spiele jetzt noch mal drei Jahre. Das ist einfach bei manchem vielleicht drin, aber unrealistisch. Also zieh es einfach durch und vor allem probier noch mal was Neues, was anderes und ich finde es halt irgendwie echt bemerkenswert, dass diese schönste Zeit meiner Karriere so wenig geplant war. Also ich wollte weder jemals nach Australien, wenn ich übers Ausland gesprochen habe, ging es für mich immer um Spanien, Frankreich, irgendwie das Südeuropäische, Romanische Ausland. Das war immer so sprachlich und kulturell so mein Sehnsuchtsort. Und Australien, das war eigentlich gar nicht so ein Ziel, was ich jemals hatte. Und irgendwie umso schöner da quasi, wo man es nie erwartet, so ein Glück zu finden.
Und du hast es schon angesprochen, erfolgreichste Zeit deiner Karriere, bist dreimal Meister geworden, zweimal Spieler der Saison, einmal MVP im Finale, Spieler des Jahrzehnts. Also alles abgeräumt, was man abräumen kann. Wir haben im Intro schon gehört, dass mancher Mannschaftskollege sagt, one of the greatest player that ever played in the A-League. Da hast du auch die Augenbrauen gehoben. Ich habe es genau gemerkt, als wir das Intro gespielt haben. Und Ainz Postocoglu, dein damaliger Trainer, der auch nochmal eine besondere Rolle spielen sollte, der ist damals aus Belgien zu dir gefahren nach Nürnberg mit seiner Frau, wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe, um mit dir einen Kaffee zu trinken. Wie war denn dieser Kaffee mit dem Trainer und hat das für dich eine Rolle gespielt, dass da jemand schon mal so viel auf sich nimmt, um dich überhaupt kennenzulernen?
Leider nein. Also ich würde sagen, ich würde gerne eine Geschichte erzählen nach dem Motto, dass der diese 10 Stunden, also fünf hin und zurück, da auf sich genommen hat. Aber ganz ehrlich, ich war damals eigentlich so desillusioniert, dass ich sowas gar nicht so richtig wertschätzen konnte. Und wenn dann ein Trainer da sitzt und dir erzählt, was er alles vorhat und irgendwie da eine große Vision aufbauen will in deinem Kopf oder so, ich dachte mir irgendwie so, boah, das hab ich doch alles schon zehnmal gehört und ich will es nicht mehr und ich kann es nicht mehr und so. Aber irgendwie hatte ich trotz allem ein gutes Gefühl bei Ange. Also ich hatte irgendwie so das Gefühl, dass das ein sehr ernster, aber verlässlicher Typ, also auch nur ein Bauchgefühler. Ich könnte jetzt auch nicht begründen, an was ich das festmache. Also nicht irgendwas Spezielles, was er gesagt hat. Aber ich hab mir irgendwie gedacht, mit dem Typen, das kann man mal probieren. Aber es war jetzt nicht so, dass ich irgendwie die Arme hochgerissen hab und gedacht hab, das ist es oder so.
Endlich jemand, der schön Fußball spielen lassen möchte. Das hattest du vorher, weil Köln, Gladbach und Nürnberg natürlich nie hören dürfen von einem Trainer. Wie ist es denn dann, auf einem neuen Kontinent anzukommen? Wer hilft einem da? Was macht man in den ersten Tagen? Wie fühlt man sich?
Erstmal so, es hat einem einer den Boot und den Füßen weggezogen. Ich fand das schon krass, so weit von zu Hause dann weg zu sein. Also irgendwie ist das schon echt eine Nummer. Und da mit dem Zeitunterschied auch. Also man lebt wirklich doppelt in einer Parallelwelt. Es ist die eine Sache, dass alle anderen erst mal sich 24 Stunden auf den Weg machen müssen, um bei einem zu sein. Aber dann auch die Tatsache, dass es einfach nie passt, zeitlich. Also wenn es bei mir abends ist, ist es halt dann erst früh am Morgen. Und man ist dann auch irgendwie vom Gefühl zu Hause, halt in ganz anderen Welten. Und was ansteht halt auch, die einen gehen zur Arbeit, die anderen wollen dann ein Feierabendbierchen trinken. Das war am Anfang schon echt seltsam. Auch über die ganzen Jahre seltsam. Aber am Anfang kam echt so ein Gefühl der Einsamkeit noch dazu. Und ich dachte mir dann oft so, boah, was mache ich eigentlich? Ich war am Anfang so krass gejetlaggt die ersten Tage. Total früh immer wach gewesen. Bin dann alleine mit dem Auto einfach durch Brisbane gefahren. Hab Gott sei Dank noch ziemlich geile Musik gehört. Das war dann ein geiles Erlebnis. Also ich kann gar nicht sagen, ob es so positiv oder negativ war, aber irgendwie intensiv. Und diese Anfangstage, die haben sich bei mir auch echt total eingebrannt. Also wenn ich die Musik von damals noch hör... Boah, ich weiß es leider vom Namen her nicht mehr. Also ich glaub, dass Mumford & Sons damals so ein bisschen dabei waren, aber es gibt so zwei, drei Lieder, da müssen drei Akkorde erklingen, dann bin ich irgendwie, mein ganzer Körper ist wieder in der Situation.
Und dann bist du gejet-lackt durch den Linksverkehr gefahren in Brisbane, das ging aber auch nur nachts, vielleicht ganz gut, dass du früh wach warst, oder?
Es war tatsächlich so, also es war Null Verkehr und ich konnte mir die Stadt dann mal so ein bisschen anschauen und es ist ja auch irgendwie trostlos, dann allein in so einem Hotelzimmer zu hängen und dann fand ich es irgendwie schön, also Städte, Großstädte bei Nachtsender, irgendwie auch schön. Ich fand es dann irgendwie total lustig, da habe ich dann schon begriffen, dass die Australier vor der Arbeit unheimlich gern Fahrrad fahren. Also es ist Wahnsinn, da sind dann sehr früh Herrscher an von Radsportlern unterwegs, die dann auch ganz früh die ganzen Cafés dicht machen, sodass es unter Umständen morgens echt lang dauern kann, bis man seinen Kaffee kriegt und es liegt an den Radfahrern. Das fand ich irgendwie witzig.
Australien, große Radsportnation, das vergisst man tatsächlich hier unten ganz gerne. Und wie ist dann das Ankommen? Also man wird ja vermutlich irgendwie vom Flughafen abgeholt, vom Verein, da wird dir alles gezeigt. Aber hat dir dann jemand geholfen, da Fuß zu fassen? Wer übernimmt sowas? Sind das Mitarbeiter, sind das Mannschaftskollegen?
Mitarbeiter. Also die Mannschaftskollegen waren auch cool. Die haben mich irgendwie bei einem sofort einfach mitgenommen. Das war auf jeden Fall positiv. Aber wir hatten da einen Brasilianer, der schon eine Weile in Australien gelebt hat und der hat sich um alles gekümmert. Also das war mega easy, mir alles besorgt, Auto, Bankaccount und Möbel. Und der wusste einfach überall, wo man hin muss.
Und bist du dann da in Australien gerne zu den ersten Trainings gegangen, um die alle kennenzulernen? Wie hat sich das verändert zu deiner Nürnberger Zeit? Oder wie lange hat es vielleicht gedauert, dass sich verändert?
Also ich bin am Anfang, also das ist genau dieses Ding, ich war nicht so schlagartig verändert. Eine ganz andere Situation, aber man stellt sein Verhalten ja nicht von einem Tag auf den anderen um. Also so dieses, dass ich dann in der Kabine auch Zeitung lese oder so. Ich habe das erstmal beibehalten, was ja jetzt nicht unbedingt so mega kommunikativ ist.
Wie wurde das aufgenommen?
Cool, also das fand ich irgendwie so das Schöne, dass ich habe das ja vorhin mal angedeutet, dass egal was ich gemacht habe, die Leute haben es irgendwie akzeptiert. Das war irgendwie kein Ding. Der ist halt so, der macht halt das und so. Es war auch so ein bisschen Selbstschutz, weil gerade am Anfang, ich musste auch nicht die ganze Zeit mit jedem reden. Das war irgendwie, also vom Englischen her, es hat einfach gedauert, bis man auch jeden immer gut verstanden hat, weil das sind so viele Schotten und Menschen mit Balkanhintergrund oder so. Und es war einfach immer ein anderer Accent und teilweise viel und jeder wollte mit dir reden und so. Ich habe mich dann teilweise auch hinter der Zeitung so ein bisschen versteckt und es war so meine Oase. Und habe aber dann schnell gemerkt, dass das irgendwie für die Leute alle okay ist. Und dann war es auch am Anfang so, die australische Liga ist extrem physisch. Also das Fitnesslevel ist brutal. Also nicht jetzt von der Schnelligkeit oder so, da brauchen wir nicht drüber reden, das ist im europäischen Schwitzensport schon höher. Aber die geben im Training immer Vollgas, eben sehr körperlich, also da knallt es permanent und das war am Anfang schon auch krass und das war eine Herausforderung. Es war nicht so, dass ich da hin bin und irgendwie im Training sofort im Klassen besser war als alle anderen. Aber das war irgendwie alles okay. Also ich hatte irgendwie das Gefühl, die lassen mich in Ruhe und die geben mir Zeit und da ist jetzt nicht so diese Mega-Erwartung oder ich hatte nicht das Gefühl jetzt schon wieder zu scheitern, obwohl alles am Anfang auch erst so gemächlich begonnen hat. Und das war für mich eigentlich die wichtigste Erfahrung, weil ich dadurch innerlich langsam aufgemacht habe. Ich war so verhärmt irgendwo und so vernarbt von der Zeit irgendwie, von diesen ganzen negativen Erfahrungen, dass ich erstmal wieder irgendwie so zutrauen ins Leben und in die Menschen um mich herumfinden musste und dafür war Brisbane die ideale Umgebung.
Jetzt gibt es ja einen Salary Cap in der A-League, aber es gibt den Marquis-Player, also einer ist im Bunten vom Salary Cap. Warst du das dann bei Brisbane, Roar, oder wer war das?
Nicht am Anfang. Also es dann dermaßen gut lief und ich meinen Vertrag verlängert habe, dann hatte ich die Möglichkeit, Marquis zu werden. Aber am Anfang, ich bin ganz normal dahin, war in diesem Salary Cap mit drin. Es war ja auch kein Move des Geldes wegen. Also es war wirklich reines Abenteuer und raus aus Deutschland.
Ja, ich habe mich das eben jetzt gerade gefragt, weil du gesagt hast, die Erwartungshaltung war gar nicht so groß und da habe ich eben darüber nachgedacht. Weil ich glaube, als Marquis-Player ist es nochmal ein bisschen anders, weil das wissen ja auch alle, das wird ja offen kommuniziert. Aber wenn man quasi innerhalb des Salary Caps drin ist, den ja die anderen Mannschaftskollegen auch teilen, mit Ausnahme dieses einen Marquis-Players, dann hat das ja auch nochmal eine Bedeutung. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass Geld alles ist, aber so ein Mannschaftsgefüge ist ja was, was sich bilden muss. Und das spielt sicherlich schon auch irgendwie eine Rolle, was die Erwartungshaltung dann angeht.
Das hat es auf jeden Fall leichter gemacht und das war dann tatsächlich so, als ich dann Marquis war und dann hatten wir auch mal ein schlechteres Jahr. Und dann kam sofort dieses Ding wieder, ist ja das Geld noch wert, der ist ja auch schon alt und dann kommen auch plötzlich wieder so Sachen, er wirkt lustlos und da habe ich mir gedacht, wie krass eigentlich.
Die Körpersprache.
Die Körpersprache, ja das ist wirklich so. Und da war ich irgendwie heilfroh, dass es das alles damals nicht gegeben war. Aber auch die Truppe, die wir an den Start gebracht haben, war eine totale Losertruppe. Also Angel ist damals durch Europa getourt und auch in Australien gewildert und hat sich eigentlich nur Leute rausgesucht, die einen Point to Proof hatten, also die noch irgendwas unter Beweis stellen mussten. Aber dann hat es halt erst mal zur Folge, dass du wirklich in einem Raum voller Verlierer sitzt und Angel hat das auch ziemlich deutlich gemacht. Also er meinte, guck dich mal an. Wo kommst du denn her? Und wirst du, dass die Leute dich so in Erinnerung behalten, soll das deine Karriere gewesen sein? Und ich glaube, da werden wir später auch noch ein bisschen drüber reden. Aber diese Art von Storytelling, Leute bei der Ehre packen und irgendwie so was Visionäres, was Angel einfach brutal beherrscht hat, das hat uns als Truppe so zusammengeschweißt und so viel Motivation gegeben, das war echt eine coole Reise.
Ja, du hast irgendwo in einem Interview mal gesagt, das hört sich jetzt komisch an, aber Angel Posticoclo war der Erste, der mir Fußball begreiflich gemacht hat. Und das, obwohl du ja schon 2001 in den professionellen Fußball in der Regionalliga gestartet bist, dann schnell 2. Liga und neun Jahre später dein erster richtiger Fußball-Trainer oder warst vielleicht du auch einfach nur empfänglicher?
Ich glaube definitiv beides. Also das mit mir damals auch nicht so viel anzufangen war, dass ich irgendwie ja eh schon alles wusste oder vielleicht die Ohren auch ganz bewusst zugemacht habe, brauche ich nicht drüber reden, also ich hatte in Deutschland auch gute Trainer und hätte von denen auch bestimmt viel, viel mehr lernen können, aber in Australien waren halt dann die Gegebenheiten plötzlich so, dass meine Ohren sperrangelweit offen waren und dann ein Trainer war, der meiner Meinung nach halt taktisch auch so unfassbar viel drauf hatte, dass ja, also ich würde es echt so beschreiben, Fußball für mich plötzlich Sinn gemacht hat. Ich habe eigentlich in Deutschland zehn Jahre Fußball gespielt und dachte irgendwie so, ja ob wir jetzt gewinnen oder verlieren, das weiß eigentlich keiner so recht, also das hängt dann zusammen mit Selbstvertrauen, stehe ich morgens auf und bin irgendwie leicht und spritzig, ist es irgendwie der Wille, der berühmt, berüchtigt oder die Aggressivität, eng am Mann dran sein.
Zeitkampfstatistik, ganz wichtig in Deutschland.
Ja oder auch so Sachen wie, okay, wer macht denn das erste Tor? Also Momentum ist ja auch immer wichtig und spielen wir auswärts oder zu Hause. Das waren für mich so die Faktoren, warum es jetzt laufen könnte oder halt auch nicht. Und in Brisbane war das ganz anders. Da war es auf einmal wirklich nur Taktik und System. Es war wirklich einfach so, wir spielen so aus dem und dem Grund und das war so reproduzierbar und so analysierbar. Also wenn wir es gut gemacht haben, lief es und wenn wir es nicht gut gemacht haben, wussten wir auch warum und dann spielt es plötzlich keine Rolle mehr, ob du auswärts oder zu Hause spielst oder ob du plötzlich mal eins und hinten bist. Und dann verlierst du einfach mal 36 mal hintereinander nicht. Und das war Wahnsinn und vor allem wenn wir sagen 36 mal hintereinander nicht verloren, in einer Liga mit Salary Cap, das heißt wir waren nicht der FC Bayern Australiens. Also man muss sich vorstellen, dass irgendwie alle Mannschaften härter sind. Es gibt aber die eine Härter, die 36 mal hintereinander nicht verliert. Also die müssen fußballerisch echt verdammt viel richtig gemacht haben.
Und damit ja auch Sportarten übergreifend ein Rekord aufgestellt hat in Australien. Da standet ihr auch glaube ich ganz gut im Fokus in der Zeit. Also Ayns Posticoclo, du hast gesagt, er, also hast du jetzt noch nicht hier gesagt, aber das habe ich mir alles angelesen und man kann ja viel über dich herausfinden. Der wollte so ein bisschen das Barcelona unter Pep Guardiola nachspielen lassen mit seinen Mitteln. Und das war so ein bisschen euer Ansatz. Also ein gutes Positionsspiel, hohe Ballbesitzzeiten, viele kurze, flache Pässe. Jetzt wollen das viele. Ich könnte mich auch hinstellen, könnte sagen hier mit meiner, ich hole mir eine Hobby-Truppe und wir wollen jetzt spielen wie Barcelona. Aber wie macht man denn so was? Und glaubt man dem Trainer denn überhaupt, wenn der sagt, wir spielen jetzt wie Barcelona? Die machen das gut.
Also erst mal denkt man sich, der ist total bescheuert. Also wir sind nicht Iniesta und Messi. Und wenn wir den Schlechtesten aus der Barcelona-Squad nehmen würden, dann wären wir noch nicht mal anernt, der. Also das klingt so anmaßend. Aber für ihn war das nicht so ein Ding, wir müssen jetzt nicht so gut sein wie Barcelona. Wir wollen einfach nur so spielen. Also das ist die Mannschaft, die mit Abstand den krassesten Fußball in Europa spielt, den meisten Erfolg hat. Und warum sollen wir nicht versuchen, irgendwie das zu kopieren, was die Besten machen? Also auch dieses Learning from the best, da geht es nicht nur um das System an sich, sondern auch um diesen Mindset. Also immer lernen wollen und sich immer am Gold-Standard irgendwie so orientieren. Das war einfach dieser Ansatz von Posto Koglo. Und das war eine geile Sache. Und wenn du jetzt fragst, dieses Wie, dieses Kurzpass, das ist ja vage. Also irgendwie zu sagen, naja, das wollen wir machen, kann man schon wollen, wird man nicht hinkriegen. Also es geht ja darum, wie sind die Rotationen auf dem Feld? Also dieser Klassiker, dass der Achter abkippt und dass der Außenverteidiger hochschiebt und dass der Flügelspieler dann so zwischen den einzelnen Ketten irgendwie so driftet und da in diesen Pockets, in diesen Taschen da irgendwie den Gegner permanent vor Entscheidungen stellt und wie man das timet und so. Das lässt sich doch beobachten. Also das war es, was Ainz gemacht hat. Also er hat einfach geguckt, wie spielt eigentlich Barcelona? Welcher Spieler ist wann in welcher Position? Wo steht der Stürmer? Steht der beim ersten Innenverteidiger, beim zweiten? Steht der abseits, steht der zwischen den beiden? Und das hat er noch und näher studiert und dann kopiert. Und das Geile an Ainz war dann auch, der ist dann von uns weggegangen zu Melbourne Victory und damals war Bayern das Maß aller Dinge. Das war als Heinckes mit dem Bayern das Dribble gewonnen hat und da ging es mit Robben und Ribéry über die Außen und das war gar nicht alles Ballbesitz, da war auch viel Konterfußball dabei. Dann hat er mit Melbourne Victory diesen Fußball kopiert und hatte ähnlichen Erfolg. Also das war so geil zu sehen, dass man eigentlich nur in Anführungszeichen genau hinschauen muss und verstehen muss und dekodieren können muss, was da eigentlich passiert.
Ja, faszinierender Trainer auf jeden Fall, von dem ich vorher noch gar nicht so viel wusste, aktuell trainierte in Japan. Wie schnell hast du dich denn dann an die Liga gewöhnt und wie schnell ging das dann, dass das auch gegriffen hat, was da Pastor Csoklo euch in die Mannschaft bringen wollte?
Hat ein bisschen gedauert. Also man hatte drei Monate Vorbereitung. Es fühlt sich manchmal an wie drei Jahre. Drei Monate Vorbereitung, das heißt, du hast echt extrem viel Zeit, dieses neue System einzuschibieren. Und dann hat es auch noch, ich glaube, so vier, fünf, ich glaube, am sechsten Spieltag haben wir noch mal verloren, nur drei oder so. Hatten noch ein bisschen gedauert. Da hatten wir unheimlich viel Ballbesitz, aber haben noch kaum Tore erzielt. Aber dann ging die Post ab und dann kam dieser Lauf von den 36 Spielen.
Genau. Sechster Spieltag, die letzte Niederlage und dann die gesamte Saison über keine Niederlage mehr. Das ging dann auch sehr erfolgreich weiter. Bevor wir aber über das erste Highlight am Saisonende sprechen, würde mich mal interessieren, das waren ja deine ersten Spiele in Australien. Auch deine ersten Spiele in diesem Modus, dass man dreimal gegen jede Mannschaft spielt. Am Ende habt ihr gegen die Mariners, glaube ich, sechsmal gespielt. Da kommen wir gleich noch zu. So ist eben Australien. Aber da hast du ja alles zum ersten Mal erlebt. Und du hast im Nachhinein mal gesagt, es erwarten dich die schönsten Auswärtsspiele der Welt. War das das erste, was du mitgenommen hast? Oder was war noch anders in der Liga?
Also sportlich war wirklich das Körperliche ganz anders. Und dann diese Mentalität, dass man nicht schweiben darf. Und mit Schwalbe meine ich noch nicht mal so, also eine total offensichtliche Andi-Möller-Schweibe, sondern wenn du nur quasi das Tackle antizipierst und dann schon irgendwie vielleicht, weil du einen Faul ziehen willst.
Dankbar annimmst, so wie man es hier sagt.
Genau. Oder manchmal sich auch nur selber schützen will. Weil wenn da so ein Verteidiger-Angerausch kommt, muss ich nicht unbedingt meinen Standband noch auf dem Boden haben. Also da bin ich dann lieber auch schon so leicht in der Luft, wenn du mich schon wegwärmst. Nur diese Sache. Und das haben die total verurteilt. Also die haben halt diese Rugby-Kultur und ich musste mich da am Anfang beschimpfen lassen. Das war Wahnsinn. Also ich muss dann auch echt meinen Spielstil ändern und auf diese Geschichte total verzichten. Und es ist lustig, dass es eigentlich jedem Ausländer in Australien gleich geht. Also egal, die Jungs aus Uruguay oder so von Aroly, der dann auch eine riesen Saison gespielt hat, die kommen erst mal an und müssen damit kämpfen, dass sie als Cheater, also als Betrüger beschimpft werden.
Das kommt aus der Rugby-Kultur, aber macht es dann nicht auch irgendwann den Fußball entspannter? Man würde sich das ja hier fast wünschen.
Ach, das ist total geil. Also das ist wirklich so, nicht liegen bleiben, nicht schweiben, einfach Mund abputzen und weiterspielen.
Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, dass es in Australien so ist, dass man oft mehrere Heim- oder Auswärtsspiele nacheinander hat. Also ihr habt zum Teil viermal nacheinander auswärts gespielt, dann zweimal zu Hause, einmal auswärts, wieder zu Hause. Liegt das an den großen Entfernungen? Kannst du mir das erklären?
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob das so stimmt. Also dass mal zwei auswärts hintereinander sind, kann ich mir vorstellen. Also in der Regel, zumindest in den letzten Jahren definitiv, war es schon eher so ein Rhythmus von Auswärts- und Heimspiel.
Okay, vielleicht lagen da dann auch Unterbrechungen drunter. Ich habe es zum Beispiel in der Saison, habt ihr vom 15. Spieltag bis zum 20. Spieltag nur auswärts gespielt und dann wieder zu Hause. Aber dann hat es auf jeden Fall kein System.
Es könnte daran gelegen haben, dass durch die Flut das Handkopf nicht gespielbar war.
Na klar, das war in der Zeit. Das kann wirklich daran gelegen haben. Okay, dann hat das kein System und du warst dann schnell in der Liga drin und hast ja auch dann sehr schnell in jedem Spiel mitgemacht. Also warst sofort Stammspieler und ihr habt es dann bis in die Final Series geschafft, wo ihr dann dreimal gegen die Central Coast Mariners gespielt habt. Warum auch immer man im Halbfinale und dann auch im Finale gegen die gleiche Mannschaft spielt. Macht es dann eigentlich noch Spaß, sich dann zum Finale auf dieselbe Mannschaft zum insgesamt sechsten Mal in der Saison vorzubereiten?
Ja, also es ist echt seltsam. Ich erkläre mal kurz den Modus. Es geht darum, also die ersten zwei haben eine Double Chance. Also wenn du im Halbfinale gegen, also spielt der erste gegen den zweiten, wenn du da rausfliegst, spielst du dann noch mal gegen den Gewinner der anderen Play-off-Teilnehmer. Also die spielen dann ihre kleine Gruppe aus, der dritte bis zum sechsten. Und dann kriegst du quasi noch mal eine Chance, um ins Finale einzuziehen. Also so war das dann. Also wir haben die Mariners damals geschlagen und dann kamen sie wieder und dann standen wir wieder vor demselben Problem. Es war insofern was anderes, weil in Australien die Zuschauerzeiten so brutal anziehen, je wichtiger die Spiele werden. Also wir hatten in der regulären Saison irgendwie immer sowas, keine Ahnung, zu besten Zeiten hatten wir mal einen Zuschausschnitt von 15.000, es kann aber auch mal 10.000 sein. Zum Grand Final kommen dann aber 50.000. Und dann ist es egal, ob du zum 6. Mal gegen eine Mannschaft spielst, wenn das ganze Stadion dann doch Trikots hat und Schals und vor allem alle kommen und es ist irgendwie von der Atmosphäre exakt wie in Europa, das ist dann schon eine geile Sache. Und dann stellt man sich nur die Frage, also wo zum Teufel sind die alle während der Saison?
Na ja wahrscheinlich laid back irgendwo am Stadtstrand.
Ach ja, den Teil der Frage muss ich ja noch beantworten. Die schönsten Auswärtsspiele der Welt. Auch was ich mich da bezogen hab, war die Geschichte, dass wir immer weit reisen mussten, aber dadurch auch immer drei Tage unterwegs waren. Die Hotels, die wir hatten und die Spielorte, das war halt sensationell, weil du warst halt in Melbourne und das Mannschaftshotel war dann in St. Kilda. Schön am Strand. Du warst am Coogee Beach in Sydney. Das ist der Strand neben Bondi Beach. Und der sieht im Prinzip gleich aus, die gleichen Cafés und der gleiche Vibe. Und wenn du da am Spieltag oder spätestens danach, also auslaufen war bei uns, immer schwimmen gehen, einfach ins Meer gehen und am Spieltag selber, wie oft ich einfach morgens noch am Strand saß und Kaffee getrunken hab und Big-Gammen gespielt hab mit einem Kumpel und dann auch noch schwimmen war. Also hast du halt in Wolfsburg ja nicht.
Das ist der richtige Kontrast dazu. Dann lass mal so zu dieser ersten Finalserie kommen. Das interessiert mich. Da habt ihr das Hinspiel bei den Central Coast Mariners, mit 2 zu 0 gewonnen und im Rückspiel steht's dann plötzlich 2 zu 0 für die anderen. Und du schießt das 1 zu 2. Das war dann dein drittes Tor, glaube ich, in der Saison. Ist das so auch einer der Momente, an den du dich jetzt noch erinnerst? Oder ist das der Klassiker, jemand schaut im Nachhinein auf all deine Spiele und pickt sich dann sowas raus?
Na, weiß ich noch sehr gut, weil ich das Tor nur schießen konnte, weil Cvečke Misimović uns damals im VfL-Trikot genau so ein Ding eingeschränkt hat, als wir mit Köln in Wolfsburg gastiert haben. Das war so ein Ding, wo du über außen durchbrichst und jeder rechnet quasi mit dem Rückpass oder dem scharfen Ball vorne rumgezogen. Und Cvečke hat sich damals überlegt, ich könnte eigentlich auch aufs kurze Eck chippen.
Ach, das war das Tor, was du da mit dem Außenriss dann ins kurze Eck gemacht hast? Oder war es Innenriss?
Genau, Außenriss, aber gleiche Idee.
Ja, aber da sieht man mal, wie gut man, du hast ja gesagt, man muss einfach nur genau gucken, was die anderen machen und dann das Erfolgreiche kopieren. Hast du ja dann bei dem Tor auch gemacht. So, ihr seid dann ins Finale eingezogen. Das erste Finale für dich, du hast schon gesagt, 50.000 Zuschauer, ihr habt zu Hause gespielt im St.Courts Stadium, also in Brisbane. Zur Vorbereitung aufs Grand Final hast du Hit the Road Jack einstudiert. War das dieses Final, das hast du mal in einer Kolumne bei 11Freunde geschrieben.
Ach so, wir haben am Vorabend einfach Musik gemacht. Ja, das stimmt. Also wir haben nicht bis spät in die Nacht, aber irgendwie so bis kurz vor Mitternacht, aber einfach mit der Band gejammt. Das war irgendwie eine ganz entspannte Vorbereitung.
Weil der Verein dich schon für die mögliche Siegesfeier eingeplant hatte, dass du da dann mitspielen solltest in der Band. Man wusste auch damals schon nicht vielleicht mit dem Begriff Mozart, da kommen wir noch dazu, warum du so genannt wurdest, aber man wusste schon, dass du der Musik sehr nahe stehst.
Ja schon, aber in Australien war das gar nicht mehr diese Klassiknummer oder diese Mozart-Assoziation, die auch ganz woanders herkam. Du kennst die Geschichte, ich glaube wir erzählen sie gleich. Damals habe ich einfach mit Gitarre so richtig angefangen. Ich habe Mitte 20 in Köln zum ersten Mal einen Klampf in die Hand genommen und fand das irgendwie geil und hatte immer schon diese Musikaffinität. Und in Australien spielt Musik, also gerade in Brisbane, eine extrem große Rolle. Es gibt extrem viel Live-Musik, also auch unter der Woche in fast jeder Bar wird tatsächlich Live-Musik gespielt. Fand ich cool, habe mich dann mit ein paar Leuten angefreundet und regelmäßig Musik gemacht.
Genau, vielleicht erzählen wir die Geschichte jetzt schon, weil ich nicht weiß, wann wir zu der Mozart-Nummer kommen. Da erinnern sich die Hörerinnen und Hörer nicht mehr dran. Es war, glaube ich, Stefan Reisinger, mit dem du bei Burghausen gespielt hast, der mit dir im Auto mitgefahren ist und dann lief Carl Orff. Und er hat danach den Journalisten erzählt, kann man auch in der Doku über dich sehen, dass da Mozart lief und dann haben sich alle Mozart genannt.
Ja, und das ist total hängen geblieben. Es ist ja krass, wie sehr sowas verfängt dann und was das für ein eigenes Leben annimmt. Ich habe zur damaligen Zeit, war eigentlich nicht nur klassische Musik gehört, aber lief halt in dem Moment. Und ich finde auch, also kam in der Burana, ist ja irgendwie auch so ein Stück, was man hören kann, wenn man jetzt nicht unbedingt, da muss man ja total der Classic Freak sein. Das ist aber eine Nummer, die mächtig daherkommt.
Hättest du einfach gesagt, das war aus einem, ja Star Wars ist es nicht, aber es kam ja in genügend Filmen vor, es war jetzt der Film-Soundtrack, dann hätte er wahrscheinlich nie was von Mozart fabuliert.
Das ist das Ding. Und das Krasse war ja dann, dass das dann mit dem Fußball irgendwie so verbunden wurde. Auf die Art spielt er oder der Dirigent oder so. Es entbehrt jeglicher Grundlage und ist aber so krass einfach hängen geblieben, dass es mein Spitzname wurde, dass Leute mein Spiel damit irgendwie assoziiert haben. Und es ist ja traurig, weil so ein Rositsky galt ja auch als Mozart, aber aus den richtigen Gründen. Der hat dann wirklich das Spiel dirigiert und war halt ein unfassbar talentierter Fußballer. Und bei mir war es einfach nur so eine verrutschte Sache, die mir echt keinen Gefallen getan hat.
Ja, noch Jahre später hieß es dann bei guten Spielen, Mozart fiedelte den Gegner weg. Ich glaube, das war, als ihr gegen Schalke gewonnen habt mit Köln im DFB-Pokal in der zweiten Runde. Die Schublade gab es aber ja dann in Australien wahrscheinlich nicht.
Null, das war auch so geil. Also wenn wir auf die Schublade eingehen, dann muss ich glaube ich schon noch eingestehen, dass ich mir selber mindestens genau so viel eingebrockt habe, wie von außen da mir irgendwie aufroktriert wurde. Also ich fand das damals halt sehr schmeichelhaft. Ich fand auch diesen Mozart-Vergleich erstmal ganz cool.
Ich glaube, Mozart ist nicht der Schlechteste, ja.
Es gibt Schlimmeres, und damals dachte ich halt auch noch, man ist irgendwie schon auch ein toller Typ, wenn man so ein bisschen Weltliteratur liest und so. Und dann kam halt eins zum anderen, und dann hatte ich da mein Image weg und bin mit meinen Flickensakus durch die Gegend gelaufen. Und da dachte ich mir irgendwie schon, so ein halber Intellektueller bist du ja eigentlich schon. Und dass einem so eine Nummer irgendwie um die Ohren fliegt, ist normal und auch gerecht. Aber schön war es halt, als ich nach Australien gekommen bin und schon irgendwie befürchtet habe, ja die Journalisten werden schon auch wissen, wer da kommt und so. Wussten die aber entweder nicht oder hat die nicht interessiert. Also ich konnte da völlig unvorbelastet wieder starten. Und das war ein richtiges Geschenk.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, du hast für Freunde später dann Kolumnen geschrieben, hast ja generell immer mal wieder auch das geschriebene Wort ausprobiert. Da waren sehr viele hochtrabende Worte mit dabei. Allen Talben, etwas wird feil geboten und so weiter und so fort. Und du bist ja auch rhetorisch sehr fit. Wie war denn das im Englischen und dann auch im Australisch-Englischen? Warst du da genauso schnell dann auf der Höhe, dass du tiefergehende Antworten geben konntest? Wie war das für dich?
Das ging eigentlich recht schnell und auch gut. Also ich war sehr happy, auch damit mich in einer anderen Sprache ausdrücken zu können. Also ich glaube, ich habe einfach eine Affinität, was Sprachen angeht. Und habe auch in Deutschland immer wieder Filme schon auf Englisch geguckt. Deswegen war das größte Problem eher das Hörverstehen, also mit den ganzen Accents und so. Und wenn du aber dann dort halt bombardiert wirst mit Zeitungen und Filmen und Kino und jeder spricht mit dir und so weiter. Ich habe dann logischerweise auch nur noch auf Englisch gelesen und das geht dann echt ziemlich schnell. Also ich würde sagen nach ein paar Jahren oder so war ich dann schon ganz fit eigentlich im Englischen.
Und wie schnell hast du dir australische Dialektwörter noch angeeignet, weil da flippen die Aussies ja aus, wenn man sie in ihrem eigenen Dialekt bespricht.
Ja, geht ja nicht anders. Also keiner sagt Afternoon, sondern sagen halt alle Abo. Also warum sollte man dann Afternoon sagen? Die sagen nicht Breakfast, sondern naja. Die lieben ihre Abkürzungen.
Also das ging schnell, dass du da mit drin warst. Ok, kommen wir zurück zum Sportlichen. Ihr steht im Finale, es geht in die Verlängerung beim Stand von 0-0 in der 96. Und in der 103. Minute schießen die Mariners zwei Tore. Das ist jetzt eine etwas langweilige Feedreporter-Frage. Aber was ging dir da durch den Kopf?
Na ja, also eigentlich ist es vorbei, oder? Also wenn man in der Verlängerung 2-0 hinten ist, die die ganzen 90 Minuten schon anrennt und irgendwie dieses Tor einfach nicht macht. Also es war ja diese klassische Rollenverteilung. Also wir hatten ja wieder diese 70% bei Besitz. Aber es war halt dann tatsächlich so, die haben es einfach verteidigt bekommen, haben dann noch zweimal gekontert und dann hast du irgendwie noch ein paar Minuten auf der Uhr. Da glaubt doch keiner mehr dran. Also das ist eher so ein Mut der Verzweiflung. Also du wärst halt bescheuert aufzugeben. Du setzt halt nochmal wirklich alles auf eine Karte. Du probierst nochmal alles. Und ich meine, die Saison läuft noch 10 Minuten. Also da hört jetzt auch keiner auf. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob man ernsthaft behaupten kann, wir hätten alle noch dran geglaubt.
Okay, da höre ich leise Zweifel raus. Es sollte ja dann aber anders kommen. Du hast beide Vorlagen gegeben zum 2 zu 2. Einmal aus dem Spiel heraus. Und das 2 zu 2 selbst war dann nach einem Eckball von dir. Und im Elfmeterschießen habt ihr dann tatsächlich den ersten Titel geholt. Beschreib mal, was da eben passiert ist. Von diesem 0 zu 2 bis dann zu der entscheidende Elfmeter. Und ihr habt das Ding eingetütet.
Ich glaube, das kann man gar nicht so sehr in Worte fassen. Wenn man es einfach nur beschreibt, klingt es halt nicht spektakulär.
Deswegen wollte ich es auch dich beschreiben lassen und wollte es nicht selber sagen.
Das 1 zu 2 war halt ein ganz normaler Angriff, wo unser Brasilianer eigentlich die meiste Arbeit macht. Der Finne stehen einfach ganz gut. Und dann kam halt diese allerletzte Ecke.
Passt war es schon auch nicht so schlecht. Aber ist in Ordnung, dass du da dein Licht nicht auf den Schäfe stellen möchtest, sondern darunter.
Der Enrique war einfach auch ein guter. Der auch drei Jahre später im Grand Final wieder das Tor für uns gemacht hat, das Siegtor. Also der war schon ein guter Zocker. Und dann kam halt diese Ecke. Und das war halt so ein Ding. Das war halt einfach echt eine gute Ecke zur richtigen Zeit. Also man schießt ja auch viele Ecken, die am ersten hängen bleiben oder irgendwie so einen halben Mondball oder sowas. Aber dieses Ding, das war echt geil. Also da war von der Flugbahn bis zur Power dahinter. Also irgendwie alles gepasst. Und wir hatten auch wirklich drei Leute da in unmittelbarer Umgebung, die eigentlich bereit waren, jede einzelne von denen reinzumachen. Also da kann man dann irgendwie vielleicht doch wieder reininterpretieren. Naja, also die waren halt so heiß, die wollten es unbedingt. Also in dem Moment hat halt nochmal vieles gepasst. War schon ein krasser Moment dann auch, weil also in dem Stadion in Sankt Corp wird auch Rugby gespielt. Also zwei verschiedene Codes und Länder-Spiele und sowas. Da geht es wirklich fett ab. Aber es wurde niemals davor und danach so ein Lärmpegel gemessen.
Ernsthaft? Krass.
Das ist eine ganz coole Geschichte, so eine kleine Anekdote. Also die haben dann diesen Soundbite tatsächlich später bei uns hinten auf dem Trikot dann auch verewigt. Also wenn man sich das Brisbane-Trikot anschaut, da ist so ein Graf drauf. Und das ist der Soundbite aus genau diesem Moment, das 2-2 aus dem Grand Final.
Ach, coole Geschichte. Und wie muss ich mir dann eine australische Meisterfeier vorstellen?
Ja, schon wild. Also die Australier, die sind, ich glaube, das darf man ja auch schon sagen, die sind trinkfest. Die trinken gern und auch viel. Ich glaube, dass einige von uns echt auch die ganze Woche einfach nur durchgefeiert haben. Ich glaube, dass ich ziemlich schnell im Flieger saß.
Richtung Heimat?
Ja, weil es macht für mich ja, oder macht da gar nicht so viel Sinn, irgendwie jetzt noch drei Wochen dran zu hängen oder so. Das war für mich einfach die Chance, mal wieder Freunde und Familie zu sehen. Und wenn ich mich recht entzinne, war sogar die Tommy Zizou-Premiere ziemlich bald danach.
Ja, genau, tatsächlich. Die war, glaube ich, sogar drei Wochen danach oder so. Und ihr habt, also Aljosha Pause, das ist die Doku, die es über dich gibt, Tom meets Zizou, wo Aljosha Pause dich über lange Zeit begleitet hat. Und der hat dann nämlich noch die Bilder vom Finale reingeschnitten, eine Woche vorher, habe ich gelesen. Stimmt, das war eine unmittelbare Erfolge.
Ich glaube, ich bin da ziemlich bald danach Richtung Heimat abgehauen.
Und wo würdest du jetzt im Nachgang, jetzt wo du ja auch so ein bisschen gesettelten Blick hast auf das Ganze, diese erste Meisterschaft einordnen? Also du bist aufgestiegen in die 2. Liga mit Wacker Burghausen, du bist aufgestiegen in die 1. Liga mit dem 1. FC Köln, du hast auch den Klassenerhalt geschafft mit Burghausen, mit Köln, auch mit Gladbach, verschiedene Vorzeichen usw. Wo steht da diese australische Meisterschaft?
Also irgendwie kommt es mir gar nicht so sehr auf die Erfolge an. Also ich bin mir dessen bewusst, was du gerade aufgezählt hast, und irgendwie finde ich es schön, ein paar Mal aufgestiegen zu sein und nicht abgestiegen zu sein, ist cool. Aber das, was für mich den großen Unterschied ausgemacht hat, war so die Art und Weise, wie wir gearbeitet haben und das erreicht haben, was in Brisbane passiert ist. Also es hat einfach mit mir als Person, als Persönlichkeit so viel gemacht, es hat irgendwie mein Leben einmal so komplett umgekrempelt. Und das war viel, viel wichtiger. Also dieses Erwachsenerwerden, dieses weniger dumm rebellisch sein, dieses sich auf nichts irgendwas einbilden, sondern einfach hart ehrlich arbeiten, irgendwie Verantwortung übernehmen. Also so diese eigentlich total banalen Dinge, die oft so unspannend klingen. Also wenn man jung ist und so, dann wäre man halt irgendwie, glaube ich, auch ganz gerne mal was Besonderes. Und kreativ sein ist schön und all das. Aber irgendwie habe ich da so richtig begriffen, worauf Erfolg eigentlich so wirklich fußt. Und das sind diese kleinen Details, die du jeden Tag richtig machen musst. Also die Einstellung, die du jeden Tag zur Arbeit mitbringst und jedem gegenüber an den Tag legst, dass die eigentlich dafür sorgt, dass du erfolgreich bist. Und das war mir damals in jungen Jahren, trotz der einen oder anderen guten Saison oder so, war mir das eigentlich nicht so bewusst. Und dieses Bewusstsein ist mir wichtiger als diese ganzen Titel oder Auszeichnungen in Australien.
Du hast danach mal gesagt, das fand ich einen sehr schönen Satz oder zwei schöne Sätze, ich war endlich mal Teil von etwas und auch von etwas Erfolgreichem, das hat mir die Welt bedeutet. Ach, es sind drei Sätze. Ich war erleichtert, dass es so etwas überhaupt noch gibt. Der Max kann nicht mal bis 13. Aber das fasst das ja ganz gut zusammen. Wann hat es denn dann so ein bisschen Klick gemacht, was jetzt natürlich eine Verkürzung ist, man macht schon mal im Leben genau Klick. Aber dass du gesagt hast, du hast ja dich mit rüber genommen nach Australien und auch noch viele deiner Verhaltensweisen erstmal ein bisschen introvertierter in der Kabine, noch Zeitung gelesen und so weiter und so fort. Aber das muss sich ja dann schon relativ schnell ja innerhalb dieser Saison oder der langen Vorbereitung so ein bisschen verändert haben. Kannst du da was festmachen, wann das so war?
Also so richtig Klick hat es auch erst wieder viel später gemacht. Das ist irgendwie auch ganz interessant, weil wir haben diese Zeit unter Engie erlebt. Das waren zwei Jahre und das hat wirklich alle transformiert. Also das ist nicht nur meine Geschichte, das sind nicht nur meine Worte. Du kannst mit Bessard Berisha oder Matt Smith oder mit wem auch immer reden. Leute, die noch mal zu Rekordtorjägern wurden, zu Nationalspielern, deren Karriere eigentlich auch vorbei war oder nie begonnen hat im Fall von Matt Smith. Der hat alle einfach auf ein total hohes Level mitgehievt. Und als wir das mitgemacht haben, war mir zumindest das gar nicht so bewusst. Aber Ainsch war dann nach zwei Jahren weg. Und dann hatten wir einen anderen Trainer und hatten dann riesen Probleme in der Saison. Und diesen Kontrast zu sehen und sich dann rückzubezünden und zu sagen, hey Moment mal, was machen wir jetzt auf einmal wieder anders? Oder was ist eigentlich damals passiert, dass wir so krass erfolgreich waren? Also da habe ich eigentlich erst angefangen, mich mit der Zeit noch mal total auseinanderzusetzen und zu analysieren, was ist da eigentlich passiert? Weil drinstecken, da ist man so wenig objektiv und man weiß ja noch nicht, wie die Sache ausgeht und misst dem Ganzen nicht so viel Bedeutung bei. Aber dann im Nachhinein, in der Rückschau, das Analysieren, das war das Wichtigste, was mir bisher passiert ist. Und das ging dann noch einher mit Live-Coaches, die wir in Australien hatten. Also in Australien ist es so, dass die Fußballer, selbst wenn sie zehn Jahre das Glück haben, A-League spielen zu dürfen, am Ende nicht ausgesorgt werden. Das heißt, die haben wirklich diesen existenziellen Druck. Jeder weiß auch, dass die durchschnittliche Verweildauerung der A-League zwei bis drei Jahre ist. Also du musst dich...
Fast kurz eigentlich.
Mega kurz. Also vom ersten bis zum letzten A-League-Spiel vergehen in der Regel 2,7 Jahre oder so was. Das heißt, die Jungs wissen, ich muss mich weiterbilden, ich muss vielleicht studieren, ein Business aufmachen. Und ich muss auch mit dieser Situation klarkommen, irgendwie auf Vereinssuche zu sein, vielleicht keinen Vertrag zu kriegen. Dieser ganze Druck. Und die Spielergewerkschaft, die PFA in Australien, ist da wirklich sensationell. Also die bieten da unheimlich viele Kurse an. Also das kann einfach ein Real-Estate-Kurs sein. Das kann ein Kurs über Meditation sein. Und wir hatten tatsächlich dann auch einen Live-Coach. Und ich finde diese ganze Live-Coach-Nummer mega, mega spannend, wo man sich im Prinzip mit sich selber auseinandersetzt und schaut, wie man sein Leben optimieren kann.
Also war das dann Psychologe? Waren das dann so Gruppenveranstaltungen? Geht man einzeln zudem? Kannst du noch ein bisschen beschreiben, was der macht?
Sowohl als auch. Also wir hatten dann zweimal im Monat feste Tage, wo der Live-Coach halt reinkam und verschiedenste Sachen angeboten hat. Und das haben wir dann als Team verpflichtend auch gemacht, was echt auch eine coole Sache war. Und dann hattest du drüber hinaus die Möglichkeit, mit den Leuten halt eins zu eins auch zu arbeiten. Und dann gab es halt weiter für eine Lektüre und Geschichten. Und ich war mit sowas vorher noch nie in Berührung geraten. Und dann kamen aber erstmal so die Klassiker, so Tony Robbins oder sowas. Und dann kann jeder auch davon halten, was er will.
Was ist Tony Robbins?
Kannst du das kurz sagen? Ein amerikanischer Motivations-Guru. Und im Deutschen haben diese Bücher ja nicht den besten Ruf. Selbsthilferatgeber oder so, wie das so despektierlich bezeichnet wird. Aber das ist es ja gar nicht. Das sind ja irgendwie Leute, die rausgefunden haben, was man eigentlich machen muss, um im Leben erfolgreich zu sein. Und zwar auf jeder Ebene. Dass man beruflich Fortschritte macht, dass man seine Beziehungen hinkriegt und die das dann mehr oder weniger unterhaltsam verpacken. Und da war ich dann irgendwie total auf diesem Trip. Es war super spannend, mich mit mir auseinanderzusetzen oder mit dem erfolgreichen Menschsein oder so. Und dann eben gekoppelt mit den Ereignissen in Australien, erst der Mega-Erfolg und dann wieder die Saison, wo es nicht so lief, da hatte ich auch super Anschauungsmaterial. Da wurde mir einfach sehr viel bewusst zu der Zeit. Und das hat mich als Mensch sehr, sehr verändert. Und um jetzt wirklich den Bogen zu sparen, das war der Moment, wo ich gesagt habe, hey, du hast eigentlich ganz viele Jahre auch nicht verschwendet. Ich glaube, wenn man jung ist und Sachen ausprobiert und Fehler macht, das ist auch okay. Aber ich habe einfach lang nicht begriffen, was es heißt, dein Leben in die eigene Hand zu nehmen und einfach Dinge zu tun, die gut für einen sind.
Es hört sich so einfach an und ist dann doch so schwierig. Würdest du dir denn wünschen, dass man sowas im deutschen Fußball auch mehr hätte? Also wenn wir hier über solche Dinge sprechen, dann geht es ja eher um reine Psychologie. Aber du hast ja schon ganz gut jetzt angedeutet, Live-Coaches, das kann ja auch einfach nur eine inspirierende andere Geschichte sein, von der man sich selbst Dinge mitnimmt. Man muss das ja nicht immer gleich so in Therapierichtung schieben, wie es manchmal getan wird, so in der öffentlichen Darstellung. Würdest du dir sowas im deutschen Fußball auch mehr wünschen?
Ich glaube, das wäre in jedem Lebensbereich total richtig am Platz. Ich bin auch überzeugt davon, dass es nur eine Frage der Zeit ist. Wenn man sieht, was in Amerika jetzt schon abgeht, was in Australien abgeht, das wird nochmal zu uns rüber schwappen. Bei uns, du hast es ja richtig gesagt, hat es noch so ein bisschen diesen Touch von Therapie. Aber es ist ja totaler Quatsch. Das ist einfach nur so ein Ding, wo dir beigebracht wird, wie man anständig lebt. Also es hört sich jetzt so banal an.
Ziemlich wie andere anständig leben. Und dann kann man überlegen, ob man das selbst übernehmen möchte.
Total. Und man wird ziemlich schnell feststellen, dass es da halt auch gewisse Regeln gibt, die relativ allgemein gültig sind. Also wenn du ein totaler Ego-Typ bist, der sich überhaupt nichts schert um seine Mitmenschen, der sich selber auch sehr isoliert, die Chance ist einfach verdammt groß, dass du dann am Ende unglücklich wirst und andere unglücklich machst. Wie wichtig Storytelling ist, Motivation, Visionen aufzubauen, Feedback zu geben. Solche Sachen, wenn man mit Teams zusammenarbeitet, auch eigentlich ein No-Brain. Also da brauchen wir nicht drüber reden. Aber das ist halt so Wissen. Im Prinzip haben wir das alles schon mal gehört und es ist alles da und es macht auch einfach Sinn. Aber wenn man das in geballter, gebündelter Form nochmal vor sich liegen hat, z.B. im Gespräch mit einem Life-Coach oder auch in Buchform oder so, dann kann man irgendwie da nochmal richtig auch die Linse scharf stellen und einfach sagen, hey, ich achte da jetzt viel mehr drauf und ich versuche irgendwie nicht so dieses Blatt im Winde zu sein, sondern meinem Leben selber irgendwie mehr eine Richtung zu geben. Das ist alles. Und wie gesagt, ich glaube, dass das jetzt schon passiert. Also es gibt in Deutschland auch immer mehr Life-Coaches schon.
Im Podcastbereich auch ein großes Thema tatsächlich. Wenn die Podcastbereiche, sie sind ja immer so die Nadel für den Trend, das muss ich natürlich sagen, hier in einem Podcast, dann kommt das definitiv nach Deutschland. Kannst du da irgendwas Konkretes benennen, was du dann verändert hast oder wo sich dein Blick verändert hat in dieser Zeit?
Eine Sache, also ich könnte wirklich jetzt 100 nennen, aber total krass war diese Sache, hör auf mit dem Finger auf andere zu deuten. Also total banale Weisheit, aber beeinflusse das, was du beeinflussen kannst. Und ich glaube bei Tom Brady jetzt um den Superbowl herum ging es auch das, also control the controllable oder so, haben sie es irgendwie genannt, dass er angeblich diese Fähigkeit hat, sich nicht irgendwie links und rechts ablenken zu lassen, sondern auf den Punkt, obwohl er nicht der talentierteste ist, irgendwie seinen Bereich so optimal wie möglich durchzuführen und der Rest, der gibt sich dann schon irgendwie. Und ich war halt so ein Wahnsinnskünstler, ich konnte ja für alles immer eine Ausrede und einen Grund und sonst irgendwas finden und im Grunde war es ja schon so, dass tendenziell es jede andere Schuld war und die Welt sich gegen mich verschworen hat und ich im falschen Beruf war und totaler Quatsch. Also die Richtung von dem Zeigefinger muss in die andere Richtung gehen. Also es hilft dir einfach nichts. Und in dem Moment, wo du anfängst zu sagen, ja Moment mal, eigentlich liegt es ja an mir. Es kann nicht sein, dass jeder Trainer ein Depp ist und alle Mitspieler um mich herum es nie passt oder was auch immer. Guck einfach mal, was machst du eigentlich falsch? Und dann wirst du ziemlich schnell feststellen, dass in meinem Fall auf eine Art überheblich war, dass ich mich auch gerne abgekapselt habe, dass ich auch nicht verlässlich war. Also ich hatte Phasen, wo ich total hart gearbeitet habe und dann wieder solche, wo ich es irgendwie schludern habe lassen und irgendwie so ein bisschen das Nachtleben auch ein bisschen zu sehr genossen habe und solche Sachen. Kannst du halt nicht bringen. Also wieder, das sind keine Weisheiten, wo man sagt, wow, jetzt...
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Genau und das finde ich irgendwie das Spannende daran, dass das so offensichtliche so oft vernachlässigt wird. Also zumindest war es halt bei mir total so. Es gibt hundertprozentig Leute da draußen, die es viel schneller schnallen und einfach viel mehr Verantwortung für sich selber übernehmen, auch schon in jungen Jahren. Bei mir hat es lange, lange gedauert.
Ja gut, aber es kann ja immerhin nicht jeder von sich behaupten und das ist ja auch nicht die angenehmste Erkenntnis, wenn man gerade eben so etwas wie du es jetzt nennst, erkennen muss. Vielleicht liegt es gar nicht so sehr immer in meiner Umgebung, sondern an sich selbst. Das ist ja das Schwierigere von beiden Dingen, die man verändern kann. Dann lassen wir zum Sportlichen zurückkommen. In der nächsten Saison kamen dann eben Besat Berisha aus Bielefeld. Der Beginn eines magischen Duos, möchte ich es fast nennen. Ihr zwei habt sehr, sehr viele Tore gemeinsam erzielt. Der eine vorbereitet, der andere hat sie dann gemacht. Das Eröffnungsspiel der nächsten Saison gleich wieder gegen die Mariners. Die haben wir schon lange nicht mehr gesehen. Drei Monate Vorbereitung noch mal auf diesen Gegner. Und dann die große Frage, wie lange ihr unbesiegt bleibt. Du hast es ja vorhin schon gesagt, 36 Spiele am Stück waren es dann. Und wir beide wissen natürlich, woran es lag. Denn du standest gegen Sydney zum ersten Mal nicht im Kader. Zack, verloren. Warum wurde da nicht der Rauswurf von Posto Ceklo gefordert?
Ich wurde tatsächlich dann ein paar Wochen verletzt. Und wir haben die ersten fünf Spiele nacheinander verloren. Also eigentlich total absurde Nummer.
Wenn man so lange unbesiegt.
Ja, und das hat dann echt dummerweise auch ein bisschen dazu geführt, dass die Leute das halt miteinander in Verbindung gebracht haben. Also natürlich hat es vielleicht auch ein bisschen eine Rolle gespielt, aber auf einmal hieß es dann gar nicht mehr so sehr, ja das war jetzt die Arbeit von Ainge, sondern es kommt quasi auf ein Spiel an. Und das war halt der größte Quatsch ever, aber in dem Moment sah es halt echt so aus.
Und hast du es damals auch ein bisschen geglaubt?
Nee, also weil ich einfach wusste, dass die Art, wie ich da Fußball gespielt habe, dass das ohne Ainge nie möglich gewesen wäre und dass er das auch mit jedem anderen genau so hingebracht hätte. Also der war da auch unheimlich konsequent, auch in der Folge wurde das dann noch total deutlich. Also bei ihm ging es nie ums Personal, was er zur Verfügung hatte. Der hat es einfach hinbekommen, dass egal wer versteht, was er auf dem Platz zu tun hat und dass die Mannschaft einfach funktioniert wie eine richtig geil geölte Maschine.
Und wie muss ich mir da australische Medien im Umfeld von so einer Geschichte dann vorstellen? Ich vermute mal rund um diese ungeschlagen Serie, das war wahrscheinlich so ein totaler Aufmerksamkeit-Pieks. Das hat ja auch eben auch sportabend übergreifend die Leute interessiert. Wie funktionieren da die Medien in Australien?
Also wenn es um Fußball geht, ist da die Resonanz wirklich überschaubar. Also es gab gerade in der Anfangszeit Tage, da gab es gar keinen Bericht in dem Äquivalent der Bild-Zeitung da bei uns. Ist mittlerweile anders, aber du guckst halt auf die Backpage und das ist immer so der große Aufhänger, der große Artikel und das ist eigentlich immer AFL oder Cricket oder Rugby. Also AFL ist Australian Football. Genau, da musst du halt ein bisschen ins Heft reinblättern und dann kommt halt irgendwann Fußball. Als die Sache dann war mit dem Rekord oder so, dann geht es ja irgendwie indirekt auch wieder um andere Sportarten. Das war natürlich schon groß dann auch. Was dann halt auch ist, also diese überspitzte Darstellung, Wortspiele oder so, das kommt dann halt auch, dann war für die Medien irgendwie klar, es liegt halt an einer Person und dann wurde aus Brisbane-Raw oder dann Broich-Ban-Raw. Also überschaubar originell, aber...
Hey, nichts gegen Wortspiele. Ich weiß nicht, was ich hier noch vorbereitet habe. Nein, Spaß. Aber das heißt, es ist alles ein bisschen kleiner von der Aufmerksamkeit her, wenn ich das jetzt richtig mitnehme, aber die Mechanismen sind im Grunde schon sehr ähnlich.
Na, nicht zwingend. Also was mich immer wieder überrascht, wie erfolglos Coaches auch sein dürfen in der A-League, ohne ihren Job zu verlieren. Also auch aktuell wieder. Ich glaube, die Central Coast Mariners sind wirklich stockletzter mit einem Sieg nach 17 Spieltagen. Das geht immer so weiter. Man darf sich da auch immer so ein bisschen schönreden, dass es besser wird und dass die Jungs auf einem super Weg sind und dass man eigentlich kurz davor steht, richtig erfolgreich zu sein und dass es auch seine Zeit braucht. Das ist auch das Lustige, weil Ainsch Postacoglu nicht zu der Saison angefangen hat, wo ich dazukam, sondern irgendwie schon ein halbes Jahr vorher. Da hat er erstmal den Dressing-Room so richtig ausgemistet. Da sind die in der Tabelle total abgestürzt. Die waren, glaube ich, dritter. Also übernommen hat, haben dann die Finances verpasst. Die Vorbereitungen haben wir richtig auf die Mütze bekommen. 0-3 gegen Victory, 4-2 gegen Adelaide verloren und solche Sachen. Und dann hat es in der Saison auch noch gedauert, bis dann der Erfolg kam. Und seitdem berufen sich alle Trainer, die irgendwie so eine Dürreperiode durchlaufen, auf Ainge. Das es einfach eine gewisse Zeit braucht, weil bei ihm das dann bei Melbourne Victory nochmal ähnlich war. Und das scheint in Australien dann irgendwie so eine ganz gängige Argumentation jetzt zu sein.
Aber muss ja auch nicht unbedingt schlecht sein eigentlich, dass man ein bisschen entspannter auch mal auf Misserfolg guckt.
Ich glaube, da geht es nicht um Erfolg oder Misserfolg, sondern um Entwicklung. Und das wird glaube ich manchmal verwechselt. Also wenn ich einfach Wochenende für Wochenende ein Scheiß spiele, auf gut Deutsch gesagt, und nicht wirklich verbessert und sichtbar ist, dann kann ich ja nicht sagen, aber irgendwie in drei Wochen oder drei Monaten wartet man alle ab, wenn der Knoten erst mal platzt. Also bei Ensch war es schon so, dass da erst mal viel echt disruptive war. Also den Laden einmal auseinandergenommen und dann wieder neu zusammengebaut. Aber du konntest halt auch sehen, es wird immer besser. Also wenn du dann 70 Prozent Ballbesitz auf einmal hast und selbst wenn du dann noch nicht so torgefährlich bist, aber du kannst zumindest mal behaupten und für jedermann nachvollziehbar und ersichtlich, hey, wir dominieren Spiele. Und das ist halt bei vielen anderen, die genauso argumentieren, Beileibe nicht der Fall.
Ja, okay, da kann man schwer gegen argumentieren. Das war ja dann auch dein erstes Jahr, in dem du Asiatische Champions League gespielt hast. Also das ist dann alles im Frühjahr. Parallel zu den Playoffs, lustige Taktung, die man da hat, wenn man in der A-League spielt. Im ersten Jahr 2012 ging es da nach Peking, Tokyo und Ulsan, was in Südkorea liegt, 2015, 2017. Hast du da auch nochmal teilgenommen an der Asiatischen Champions League? Du warst unter anderem dann auch in Thailand und in Japan, nicht nur in Tokyo, sondern auch in Urawa und Kashima zum Beispiel. Wie muss ich mir denn die Asiatische Champions League vorstellen?
Also erstmal unfassbar reisen für uns. Also wenn wir dann am Samstag in Perth spielen und dann nach Bangkok müssen, um dann irgendwie drei Tage später wieder in Brisbane zu spielen, also es geht eigentlich gar nicht. Vor allem bei mir dann schon im fortgeschrittenen Alter, ich war so kaputt, also hatte körperlich solche Schmerzen, es hat so lange gedauert, da wieder reinzukommen, also es war erstens wirklich extrem belastend, dann hat es sportlich auch nicht so die Wertigkeit.
Nur in Australien oder generell?
In Australien. Also es sind kaum Zuschauer im Stadion. Es ist ein relativ gutes Niveau, das muss man echt sagen. Gerade in Korea und Japan wird echt ordentlicher Fußball gespielt, muss man wirklich sagen. Und auch im Middle East wird ganz schön aufgeholt. Also Katar ist jetzt Asienmeister. Was da passiert, die haben schon auch coole Truppen. Und die haben halt auch Kohle ohne Ende. Also wenn man sich die Facilities da anschaut, also wenn man nach Peking fährt und sieht, was die für ein Stadion haben oder für Trainingsmöglichkeiten. Genau das gleiche in Shanghai, das ist Wahnsinn. Also die haben dann Spieler rumlaufen wie Thavis und so. Also war nochmal eine coole Erfahrung.
Sandro Wagner.
Auch.
Okay, aber weite Reisen, coole Erfahrungen. Und konntest du das dann aber in dem Zeitpunkt, zu dem Zeitpunkt, in dem es passiert ist, wertschätzen, dass du diese Erfahrung nochmal gemacht hast? Weil es hat sich gerade eher so angehört, als ob es eine Belastung gewesen wäre.
Ja, es war eigentlich schon zu anstrengend. Es war cool, nochmal gegen einen Top-Spieler zu spielen. Grundsätzlich auch nie verkehrt zu reisen und Städte auch nochmal mitzunehmen. Aber im Grunde ist die Nummer ja Flughafen, Hotel, Stadion und dann wieder raus und dann eben wieder über Singapore nach Brisbane fliegen. Und das war dann wieder 14 Stunden Flug, um dann irgendwie den Tag darauf wieder zu spielen. Das ist belastungstechnisch und grenzwertig. Und wenn wir über Fliegen reden, dann reden wir über Holzklasse. Also braucht keiner meinen, dass Brisbane Royal irgendwie Geld hätte, sich da eine Business Class zu leisten.
Okay, das heißt, da konnte man sich nicht die nötige Beinfreiheit holen, die man vielleicht gebraucht hätte, um da die Regeneration richtig laufen zu lassen. Aber es war ja nicht nur Flughafen spielen wie der Flughafen. Zwischendurch ging es ja auch durchaus mal im Taxi zu einer Massagestunde, wie ich deine Freunde-Kolumne entnehmen konnte, die du damals geschrieben hast. Wie kam es denn dazu eigentlich? Warum hattest du Lust darauf, dich auch nochmal so quasi mitzuteilen? Weil für dich auch nochmal eine Aufgabe, so einen Text zu schreiben, das macht man ja nicht einfach so.
Das weiß man manchmal nicht so genau, warum man Sachen im Leben macht. Manchmal ist es echt so, Leute fragen halt an und man denkt sich einfach so, warum eigentlich nicht?
Und das war es eigentlich auch schon und deswegen dann?
Also mit dem Mitteilungsbedürfnis, das hält sich eigentlich in Grenzen. Das ist ja immer schwer glaubhaft zu vermitteln, wenn man doch irgendwie regelmäßig irgendwo auftaucht. Aber es ist halt in erster Linie, weil Leute einfach auch Fragen und Interesse zeigen. Ich war früher jemand, der sehr viel einfach auch abgeblockt hat. Und ich möchte auch da irgendwie nicht mehr so sein. Ich finde es eigentlich total cool, dass jeder so seine kleinen Projekte hat, größeren und kleineren und versuche halt nach Kräften. Also ich bin gerade auch wieder busy, aber wenn es sich halt irgendwie ausgeht, so wie heute, finde ich es einfach auch echt eine coole Sache, mich da hinzusetzen und jemand anderem irgendwie auch zu ermöglichen, sein Ding durchzuziehen.
Das ist schön. Und wie ist das mit dem Schreiben für dich? Also du hast ja immer oder liest ja wahrscheinlich immer noch sehr viel. Das war auch eine der wichtigen, das war Teil dieser Mozart-Schublade, dass du auch, ich sag jetzt mal, nicht John Grisham gelesen hast, sondern da wurde dann eher Camus genannt oder Hemingway Dostoyevsky, also auch gleich schon richtig oberstes Regal, wo man vielleicht gar nicht immer hingreifen möchte. Wie war es denn dann mal selbst zu schreiben?
Schwer. Also ich finde es auch jetzt immer noch schwer. Also ich möchte es eigentlich fast nicht mehr machen. Ich finde es irgendwie viel schöner, einfach drauf loszuquatschen und am schönsten witzigerweise sogar auf Englisch, weil ich da genau weiß, ich werde nicht genau das richtige Wort finden und es erwartet auch keiner von mir. Also das ist ja auch so ein bisschen...
Also kannst du dann ein bisschen einfacher sprechen?
Total. Also ich kann beides dann. Ich kann es irgendwie kompliziert probieren und wenn es schief geht, ist es irgendwie auch okay. Aber ich glaube, wenn es ums Deutsche geht, ums geschriebenes Wort und so, ich habe da irgendwie immer noch so ein etwas, ich weiß gar nicht woher das kommt, das ist eigentlich auch totaler Quatsch, aber so ein gewissen Anspruch. Und ich finde es für mich selber viel angenehmer, wenn ich da mit meinen eigenen Erwartungen auch nicht in Konflikt komme. Und deswegen rede ich echt gerne auf Englisch mittlerweile.
Und wie kommt es, dass man gerade so hochklassige Literatur liest, die ja auch nicht immer leicht zu verstehen ist? Also ich habe Germanistik studiert, ich habe auch mal Camus und Dostoevsky gelesen. Es war aber nicht immer das, wo ich mir gedacht habe, da gönne ich mir jetzt nochmal richtig was, sondern manchmal hat man es auch eher gelesen, weil man halt weiß, die sollen ganz cool sein, die haben das hier, die Pest von Camus, ganz ganz wichtig, wenn man verstehen will, über was er so nachgedacht hat, okay, dann lese ich es halt.
Ja, das glaube ich war auch so eine Mischung. Sicher war Attitüde dabei, zum anderen auch so ein bisschen Sport, also so intellektueller Sport. Ich finde es nach wie vor geil, ab und zu so das Gehirn ein bisschen auf Turen zu bringen, aber das hat sich auch sehr gelegt. Also ich lese mittlerweile unheimlich gern einfach nur populäre wissenschaftliche Bücher.
Also ist das ein bisschen zurückgegangen. Man weiß ja irgendwie auch nicht immer, warum er was gemacht hat im Leben. Das hast du mir ja auch vorhin schon gesagt. Und man kann ja auch sehr, sehr viel mitnehmen. Ihr seid in der Saison dann nochmal Meister geworden, nochmal ins Finale gekommen, rund um die AFC außen rum. Das war jetzt dann auch die letzte erfolgreiche Meisterschaft mit Pastor Coglu. Oder Koglu, sag du eben. Ich hab sie ganz zeit falsch gesagt und nicht darauf reagiert, dass du es anders sagst.
Na, den Namen kriegt keiner so richtig hin.
Du bist halt auch ein höflicher Mensch. Wie war das zweite Finale? Hast du an diese zweite Saison noch besondere Erinnerungen? Oder wie ist das, wenn du jetzt in der Rückse auf diese wahnsinnig lange Zeit von 2010 bis 2017 blickst? Verschwimmt das alles miteinander? Oder waren das für dich konkrete Abfolgen von Ereignissen?
Sehr konkret, eben weil ich irgendwie mit der Lupe drauf geschaut habe. Ich weiß auch noch die ganzen Ansprachen von damals und die Herangehensweise von Einge. Weil nämlich wir im zweiten Jahr nicht die Liga gewonnen haben. Also wir hatten ja diese Misere von fünf Spielen in der Folge, wo wir verloren haben. Als ich dann nach meiner Verletzung zurückkam, war es auch erst noch holprig. Erst zum Ende haben wir dann Fahrt aufgenommen und dann wieder alles irgendwie weggeputzt. Aber wir haben halt dadurch die Liga verloren. Du kannst in Australien Meister werden, weil es ja Playoffs gibt. Aber es gibt halt auch noch eine ganz normale Regular Season. Und da sind wir halt nur Zweiter geworden. Und dann gab es zwei Sachen, die halt wichtig waren zu dem Zeitpunkt. Also Ainge war auf der einen Seite super happy, dass wir Back-to-Back-Championships geholt haben. Also das hat in der A-League damals noch niemand geschafft. Und für ihn war es immer so, dieses Ding Erfolge zu bestätigen. Er sagt irgendwie, einmal Meister werden kann jeder. Und hat aufgezählt, ja, das hat Sydney gemacht, das hat Central Coast gemacht, das hat Adelaide hinbekommen. Das haben sie alle hinbekommen.
VfB Stuttgart, VfB Wolfsburg wird er alle genannt haben.
Lester, es gibt ja immer wieder diese Beispiele. Und sein Hauptmerkmal für gutes Arbeiten war halt reproduzierbare Ergebnisse, war Erfolg über Jahre. Irgendwie mal einen Lauf haben. Das hat nicht gezählt. Deswegen war ihm das wichtig, dass wir da noch mal die Championship geholt haben. Auf der anderen Seite gab es eine Ansage von ihm. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Er hat sich wirklich in die Kabine hingestellt und hat uns mit auf den Weg gegeben. Wenn ihr denkt, dass es gut genug ist, in Australien in dieser Liga zweiter zu werden, dann geht noch mal heim und denkt noch mal drüber nach. If you think that's good enough, think again. Und dieses Think again, das ist so krass hängen wie Blüben bei mir. Wenn man wirklich nicht über diese Dinge nachdenkt und gerade im Erfolgsfall nicht drüber nachdenkt, man ist gerade nochmal Meister geworden und so, aber er hat Recht. Wenn du wirklich als gut gelten möchtest, musst du die Liga jedes Jahr gewinnen. Und das haben wir aus welchen Gründen auch immer einfach nicht hinbekommen.
Und wann war diese Ansprache? War das dann noch vor den Playoffs spielen oder danach?
Nach der Meisterschaft. Wir hatten dann noch mal eine Woche Training und dann kam diese Ansprache kurz vor dem Urlaub. So ein bisschen ein Saison-Fazit. Und ja, dann kam diese Ansage. Aber wichtig sowas, weil man gibt sich so schnell mit irgendwas zufrieden. Und ich finde, dass Einstein so einen Blick für das Big Picture, wie er es einmal genannt hat. Da geht es gar nicht darum, irgendwas kaputt zu reden in dem Moment. Aber wie willst du dich denn als Persönlichkeit entwickeln? Was hast du denn selber für Ansprüche an dich? Also war es das jetzt, quasi einmal diesen Erfolg gehabt zu haben? Oder bringt es dir nicht vielleicht das Mensch, viel, viel mehr die Messlatte höher zu legen? Irgendwie am Ball zu bleiben? Irgendwie auch den Erfolg kritisch zu hinterfragen?
Und jetzt hat es bei dir ja total verfangen. Wie war das bei jüngeren Spielern?
Boah, bei den ganz jungen kann ich es gar nicht so sagen.
Ich versuche mir gerade vorzustellen, was hätte der junge, noch jüngere Thomas Broich eigentlich gesagt in dem Moment oder über ihn gedacht?
Das glaube ich, kann ich mir ganz gut ausmalen. Also ich hätte damals eine Katastrophe gefunden, dass jemand selbst irgendwie in so einem brutal geilen Moment irgendwie was zum Nörgeln findet und so. Also man kann ihm das ja auch irgendwie total schlecht auslegen und irgendwie in so eine Anti-Haltung dann irgendwie sich zurückziehen, was ich wirklich auch in jungen Jahren einfach sehr, sehr konsequent und fälschlicherweise gemacht habe, aber da halt nicht mehr. Also es waren viele Sachen. Also Andrew hatte auch so ein Ding 80-20. Und im Leben, wir beschweren uns sehr unheimlich gern. Also grad Fußballer, ich glaube, Fußballer wissen das auch, jammern gern. Also das ist so, das kommt mit dem Beruf, glaube ich. Man muss sich immer irgendwie tendenziell überfordert fühlen und gestresst und immer so ein bisschen am Jammern. Und für Andrew hat er halt so ein Ding 80-20 bei mir. Im Leben bist du quasi fast am Optimum, wenn 80% der Dinge super laufen. Und die 20%, die wird's immer geben, wo es irgendwie knirscht und knarrt. Egal ob im Sportlichen, im Privaten, wo auch immer. Und das ist eigentlich eher darum geht, sich damit auch abzufinden, dass man das als die Realität des Lebens anerkennt und nicht immer so tut, als wäre da irgendwas im Argen.
Ah, das ist eine interessante Variante der 80-20-Regel. Ich kenne die so, dass man sagt, um 80% des Ergebnisses zu erreichen, reichen 20% des Einsatzes. Und für die letzten 20 braucht man dann nochmal 80% der Energie. Das ist ein etwas anderer Ansatz, aber vielleicht geht das auch eher in Richtung von allen Perfektionisten. Wenn wir aber dann nochmal ganz kurz auf dieses Finale zurück schauen, dann sehe ich, dass ihr wieder zurückgelegen habt. Diesmal gegen Perth Glory durch ein Eigentor in der 52. Minute. Und dann gab es wieder eine Aufholjagd. Berisha hat dann beide Tore gemacht, in der 84. und in der 90. Minute. Also erst die Verlängerung sichergestellt, und dann aber hatte man so ein bisschen den Eindruck, nach allem, was ich mir dann jetzt so anlesen konnte, und ein paar Bilder davon habe ich auch gefunden, dass ihr jetzt das Gefühl hattet, okay, wir machen das jetzt einfach dicht, wir haben keinen Bock auf Verlängerung, und für Perth war es ein bisschen zu viel.
Na ja, das war ein absurdes Spiel. Also Perth hat in diesem ganzen Finale keinen einzigen Torschuss abgegeben. Die haben einmal geflankt und wir haben uns das Ding selber reingegrätscht. Und es war wirklich nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis wir irgendwann ein Tor machen. Und das ist halt dann spät passiert. Und damals wirklich klar, also jetzt brechen alle Dämme. Und wir haben uns halt auf Verlängerung eingestellt. Und haben gedacht, die spielen jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde her. Aber dann ist halt irgendwie in der Nachspielzeit noch der Siegtreffer gefallen.
Und dann bist du wieder so schnell nach Deutschland geflogen oder hattest du da mehr Zeit, das in Australien noch zu genießen? Bis zur Ansprache von Bosse Kogdlu.
Da bin ich dann geblieben, konnte es aber auch nicht genießen, weil ich operiert wurde. Dann wurde ein Weisheitszahn entfernt.
Und das hast du in Australien machen lassen? Das heißt ein Weisheitszahn auf Englisch? Das war einfach. Und warum ist Ainge dann gegangen?
Weil er aus Melbourne stammt und Victory, der größte Verein in Australien ist, und ihm ein Angebot unterbreitet hat. Und dann war er ganz schnell weg.
Und ist das nicht bitter, wenn man sich selbst in so eine, also Schicksalsgemeinschaft ist mir ein zu großes Wort, aber man hat ja gemeinsam was erreicht. Und für dieses gemeinsame Erreichen hat es ja auch dazu gehört, dass jeder seinen Anteil eingebracht hat in eine Gruppe. Und dann sagt einer davon, okay, ich habe jetzt hier ein Angebot aus meiner alten Heimat mit fünf Jahren. Ist ja glaube ich aus Griechenland nach Melbourne gezogen und dann da aufgewachsen. Tschüss, danke, ciao. Und denkt dran, seid nie zufrieden mit dem, was ihr erreicht habt.
Ja, bitter irgendwo, aber irgendwie auch normal. Also eine andere Regel des Lebens ist ja irgendwo, dass nichts so bleibt wie es ist. Also früher oder später war ja klar, dass es entweder nicht mehr so erfolgreich sein würde oder dass vielleicht Spiele abhauen oder der Trainer geht oder so. Also geht ja gar nicht darum, auch David dazu zu sagen, ja, wie kann er nur oder so oder blöd und jetzt stehen wir hier alleine da oder so. Sondern einfach dankbar sein, dass wir diese Zeit miteinander hatten, dass wir auch echt so viel lernen durften, dass irgendwie auch, also für ihn war das auch wichtig zu sehen, dass seine Methoden so aufgegangen sind. Also er war vorher auch nicht immer nur mega erfolgreich. Und es hat ihn in seiner Arbeit auch bestärkt und hat das Gleiche dann mit Melbourne Victory abgezogen und dann mit der australischen Nationalmannschaft, die zum ersten Mal den Asien Cup unter seiner Regie gewonnen haben. Also es war für alle wichtig. Und vor allem, er hat uns ja dann auch mit einer Aufgabe hinterlassen. Also ohne, dass wir es realisiert haben. Aber das witzige Wahrheit, dann kommt ein neuer Trainer und irgendwie denkt man, ja, man hat eine geile Truppe und man wird auf jeden Fall auch wieder erfolgreich sein. War aber nicht so.
Das war dann der Vater von Dario Vidozic, der dann kam. Rado Vidozic.
Auch ein super netter Typ, der sich tag und nacht mit Fußball beschäftigt, der auch echt einen Fußballverstand hat. Also viele von den Rotationen, die wir uns da erarbeitet haben und teilweise eigene, andere von Barcelona. Also der hatte da auch einen gehörigen Anteil dran. Also der hat viel Fußball studiert. War aber so ein bisschen überfordert mit der Teamführung. Und da war wieder das Problem, wenn du dann zwei Mal einander Meister wirst, dann hast du ja plötzlich auch wieder richtige Egos im Team. Also diese Loser, mit denen Ange am Anfang gearbeitet hat, waren dann auf einmal so die Benchmark der A-League. Ich glaube, das war für ihn dann auch sehr, sehr schwierig, da eigene Ideen umzusetzen und überhaupt so als Autoritäter voll zur Entfaltung zu kommen und auch wieder eine eigene Story zu erzählen. Also das hat halt einfach nicht so geklappt. Aber das Geile dann war, also wir Spieler haben nachdem Rado dann zurückgetreten ist, zwar ihm selber auch zu viel dann, haben uns dann einfach irgendwie erinnert, so rückbesonnen im Endeffekt, so ja Moment mal, also wir haben doch was mit auf den Weg gekriegt. Also wir haben doch zwei Jahre zugehört, wir müssen noch irgendwas noch können und wissen, das kann ja nicht alles weg sein. Und haben uns dann als Führungsspieler, das war total krass. Also wir hatten ein paar reifere Semester, Berisha, Shane Steffanout, Mademarkay, Matt Smith. Wir haben uns da nochmal hingehockt und einfach nochmal erarbeitet, was uns damals so erfolgreich gemacht hat. Also das war nochmal ein sehr bewusstes Auseinandersetzen mit den eigenen Idealen und wir haben das wieder hingekriegt, dass wir im Jahr darauf wieder Meister geworden sind und wieder mit 10 Punkten Vorsprung. Das war eine richtig geile Nummer. Und da ging es auch glaube ich für mich los, da hatte ich zum ersten Mal das Gefühl, ich würde echt gerne Trainer machen. Also irgendwie zu sehen, dass die Mannschaft riesen Probleme hat und man hockt sich hin und erarbeitet Lösungen und arbeitet irgendwie an gewissen Rotationen und Amt-Timing. Spricht mit den jungen Spielern, die damals noch nicht dabei waren, erklärt denen die Spielidee, warum wir was machen.
Aber was hat denn dann der Trainer gemacht in der Situation?
Uns vertraut. Also der war nicht außen vor. Wir haben das halt schon zusammen erarbeitet und er musste ja auch logischerweise das Trainingentwerfen gestalten und durchführen und so. Und der war vor allem ein sehr guter Motivator. Aber das taktische Know-how hatten wir er. Also er musste ja nicht reinkommen und hätte es machen können und irgendwie seine völlig eigene Spielidee uns da aufdrücken können. Aber er wusste ja auch, das funktioniert doch, was die Jungs da die letzten Jahre gespielt haben. Und da hat er uns im Prinzip auch so ein bisschen machen lassen und hat sich selber wieder auf, ich komme immer wieder darauf zurück, auf Storytelling fokussiert. Also der war der Typ, der konnte sich hinstellen, so flammende Appelle halten, hatte einfach rhetorisch richtig was drauf, war ein guter Public Speaker. Die Kombination war dann auch noch mal richtig geil.
Also ihr habt dann die Meisterschaft gewonnen. Vorher war es so, dass ihr eben nach der, oder unter Vidozic in dieser kurzen Phase erstand Raw dann sogar am tabellen Ende, seid dann letztendlich aber sogar noch bis ins Halbfinale der Playoffs gekommen. Du hast dann mal darüber gesagt, über diese Phase, in der es nicht so gut lief, es greifen dieselben Mechanismen, aber ganz anders als in Deutschland. Hier geht es wesentlich freundlicher zu.
Ja, du wirst hier nicht an die Wand genagelt. Also du kannst echt krass abstürzen, also vom ersten auf den letzten Platz. Und natürlich sind die Leute kritisch und natürlich pfeifen die Fans auch mal, aber es war nie so, dass ich in der Stadt irgendwie angepöbelt wurde oder dass man auch so völlig runtergeschrieben wurde. Also es gab vielleicht den einen oder anderen Ausrutscher mal in die Richtung, aber das war nie ein Tenor. Und das war für mich auch nochmal super angenehm, weil ich glaube, man kennt das ja selber. Also wenn man so an gewisse Situationen erinnert wird, also das holt einen manchmal unheimlich ein, also auch fast schon körperlich, dass man irgendwie so ein Déjà-vu hat und irgendwie die Gedanken von damals und die Gefühle von damals irgendwie unheimlich präsent sind.
Und an welche Zeit hat dich das erinnert?
Generell an die Bundesliga-Zeit. Und ich hatte da echt so ein bisschen Bedenken, so ein bisschen Bange. Bitte lasst dieses Gefühl oder diese Ängste oder so, die ja irgendwo in einem angelegt sind, die müssen ja quasi nur aufgefrischt werden. Also das ist ja auch das Coole, wenn man sich irgendwie so Neuro-Science irgendwie so ein bisschen anschaut im Moment. Die kommen ja quasi dem menschlichen Gefühlshaushalt und der Art und Weise, wie wir denken, schon auf die Schliche. Da wird vieles klar. Im Endeffekt sind unsere Verhaltensmuster ja neuronale Bahnen. Also alles ist miteinander vernetzt und irgendwie verlinkt. Und gewisse Muster sind in uns angelegt. Und in diese Muster verfallen wir auch immer wieder.
Klar, Gefühle sind ja auch Chemie.
Und die werden nie abgestellt. Also man kann die umarbeiten und überschreiben und so weiter, aber die sind irgendwo noch in einem da. Und das habe ich zu der Zeit nochmal gespürt, dass man irgendwie ganz schnell auch wieder so ein paar Jahre zurück transportiert werden kann.
Aber dann hast du ja festgestellt, es war doch irgendwie anders. Du warst anders und auch die Umgebung war anders. Kannst du mir das erklären, warum man da ein bisschen anders mit umgeht in Australien? Liegt das daran, weil es eben eine weniger große Medienpräsenz gibt, wie du vorhin schon beschrieben hast? Ist der Fußball vielleicht nicht so wichtig im Leben der Leute? Ist es eine generelle Haltung?
Ich glaube von allem ein bisschen. Also Fußball ist einfach nicht Sportart Nummer eins. Das macht es entspannter. Das kriegt man hier wahrscheinlich auch beim Handball oder so mit. Da werden öfter und lieber Feste gefeiert, als dass man irgendwie Handballer kaputt schreibt oder irgendwie anpöbelt oder so.
Das wäre mal was, was der Fußball wirklich vom Handball lernen kann, nicht Klatschpappen.
Nee, aber ist doch irgendwo immer so. Also wenn man sich in einer Nische bewegt, hat man zwar das Problem, dass man nicht die Aufmerksamkeit und Reichweite generiert. Auf der anderen Seite ist die Nische netter. Das sind die Leute, die sich da aufhalten wollen und die sich mit dem Thema irgendwie auch echt auf eine sehr positive Art und Weise beschäftigen und eher so so eine Liebhaber-Attitüde dann auch haben. Und das ist geil. Und je größer es wird, desto polemischer wird es auch. Also du kannst halt das eine ohne das andere nicht haben. Und das ist in Australien halt total der Fall. Wir würden uns alle wünschen, dass es ein bisschen mehr Platz einnehmen würde in den Zeitungen. Aber es ist halt nicht der Fall. Auf der anderen Seite führt es halt dazu, dass die Leute in erster Linie super happy sind, dass es die A-League gibt und dass irgendwie geile Ausländer da spielen. Und wenn die dich auf der Straße treffen, finde ich es immer noch cool, auch wenn du gerade letzter bist und die letzten drei Spiele Grütze gespielt hast.
Ja, vielleicht ist das tatsächlich die Frage der Aufmerksamkeit. Wenn du in der Nische bist, dann kommen ja die Leute zu dir, weil sie dir ihre Aufmerksamkeit widmen wollen, dem Thema. Und wenn du aber so groß bist, dass es eine breite Masse interessiert, dann musst du um die Aufmerksamkeit der Leute bugeln. Dann kommen die nicht mehr immer aus dem eigenen Antrieb und dann muss man vielleicht auch zugespitzter, polemischer und so weiter werden. Weil du jetzt aber gerade die ausländischen Spieler angesprochen hast. Du hast ja in einer Liga gespielt mit Alessandro del Piero, der kam zur Saison 2012, 2013 zum Sydney FC und hat in seiner ersten Saison in allen Spielen gegen Brisbane getroffen. Aber insgesamt hat er nur einmal gewonnen in seiner kompletten Zeit in der A-League. Hatte in 47 Spielen 35 Torbeteiligungen. Ist das für dich was Besonderes gewesen, dass del Piero in diese Liga kam? Ich habe aus der Zeit auch viel mehr Interviews und so weiter gefunden, auch von Brisbane-Spielern über del Piero, als in den anderen Zeiten. Was hat das damals bedeutet für die Liga und vielleicht auch für dich?
Es war ein enormer Boost. Auf einmal stehst du medial wirklich dann auch ein bisschen im Brennpunkt. Dann hast du genau dieses Ding, dass die Zeitungen mehr oder weniger jeden Tag über jeden Schritt von del Piero berichten. Und dieser Glanz fällt auf alle anderen dann auch ab. Also wenn die dann über del Piero schreiben, als wahrscheinlich den krassesten Spieler, der jemals in dieser Liga gespielt hat, dann dauert es halt noch drei Wochen und dann fällt einem ein, naja, aber dann müssen wir den ja auch vergleichen mit den Spielern, die wir hier in der Liga haben. Also das, was bei uns so ist, das Beste gilt. Und dann hast du plötzlich einen Artikel, den es früher niemals gegeben hätte, aber nur wegen del Piero. Und genau das Gleiche mit den Zuschauern zahlen. Also der war allein in der Lage, in manchen Stadien die Zuschauerzahl zu verdoppeln oder zu verdreifachen. Jeder wollte diesen Typen einmal live spielen sehen.
Ja, und dann hat er aber viermal verloren in sechs Spielen gegen Brisbane. War das dann was Besonderes, auch gegen den auf dem Platz zu stehen? Oder sind Fußballer halt dann einfach Fußballer und dann hat der eine eben ein bisschen feineres Füßchen und der andere hat aber mehr die körperliche Präsenz? Er musste sich ja wahrscheinlich auch an die Physis gewöhnen in der Liga.
Ich glaube, das war auch so ein bisschen das Problem. Also er war damals schon 38 und körperlich für dieses Klima und für die Intensität der Liga wahrscheinlich dann auch nicht mehr gebaut. Also es wird einfach extrem viel rauf und runter gerannt und so. Und da kann er halt nur mit Fußballintelligenz und Spielgefühl und so auch nicht alles regeln. Auf der anderen Seite war halt jedes Mal, wenn er am Ball war irgendwie schon klar. Also das ist mit Abstand das Beste, was da in der Liga jemals rumgelaufen ist. Also der musste nicht mehr viel laufen und hat trotzdem irgendwie 35 Scorer-Punkte in 47 Spielen hingelegt. Also das als Arbeitsnachweis sagt gleich alles.
Ist tatsächlich nicht so schlecht. Und trotzdem wurde im September 2014 von Fans zum Spieler des Erzählens gewählt. Nicht Alessandro del Piero, sondern du. Was sagt das aus über dein Standing bei den eigenen Fans und den Fans anderer Vereine?
Also ich glaube, ich war länger da und ich habe halt auch was gewonnen. Also der hat als Einzelspieler durchaus geglänzt und war unfassbar wichtig für die Liga in ihrer Entwicklung. Und vor allem in der Wahrnehmung der Liga. Aber wenn man sich rein aufs Sportliche beschränkt, glaube ich, war halt sein Einfluss dann doch nicht so hoch wie der jetzt beispielsweise von dieser Brisbane-Truppe, die wir damals als Ganzes hatten.
Genau, aber ich wollte es jetzt nicht nur mit der Pierrot vergleichen. Es gibt ja auch noch viele andere Spieler, die auch große Erfolge in der A-League vorzuweisen haben. Und trotzdem wurdest du Spieler des Jahrzehnts. Macht das was mit einem, außer dass man sich drüber freut? Freut man sich da kurz drüber, lang drüber?
Ach, das ist so eine Sache, die ist schon schön. Und vor allem, da kann man sich auch immer wieder mal dran erinnern oder man wird nochmal drauf angesprochen.
Das wird ja immer genannt in jedem Interview mit dir.
Ja, und dann ist es auch wieder schön. Also es ist nicht so, dass ich jetzt jeden Tag dran denke, ja du bist der Fußballer des Jahrzehnts oder so. Aber ich meine, das ist ja schon so immer ein kleines Ego-Bombon. Also es gibt Schlimmeres.
Okay gut, da hast du dich jetzt ganz gut drum herum gewunden. Ihr hattet in der Saison 2013, 2014 habt ihr dann nochmal den Titel gewonnen, wieder nach einer sehr dominanten Saison. Und das war dann die, die du vorhin schon beschrieben hast, wo ihr Führungsspieler euch ein bisschen zurückerinnert habt an das, was ihr unter eurem alten Gandalf, dem Weißen, gelernt habt. Und das habt ihr dann zur Anwendung gebracht und dann den dritten Titel in vier Jahren geholt. Und das eben in einer Liga, die per System darauf ausgelegt ist, dass genau das nicht passiert. Also ihr wart mal ganz kurz die New England Patriots der A-League, könnte man so sagen. War das dann Routine? Hat sich da für dich irgendwas verändert?
Nee, verändert hat sich eigentlich erst mit dem Jahr drauf was. Also wir hatten dann noch mal einen Trainerwechsel später in der darauffolgenden Saison, was da am Anfang auch wieder so überhaupt nicht lief. Und dann kam ein Trainer, der zum ersten Mal wieder komplett eigene Ideen umgesetzt hat. Und das war für mich nochmal eine krasse Zäsur. Und da war dann für mich eigentlich auch ziemlich schnell klar, das war es jetzt. Weil ich in einem anderen System einfach mit meinen Fähigkeiten auch nicht mehr so, also auch theoretisch würde ich sogar sagen, dass es dann tatsächlich auch so war. Aber das hat es irgendwie nicht mehr hergegeben. Also wir haben dann eher so lange Bälle gespielt, wo es um lange Sprints auch ging. Bälle hinter die Abwehr, ganz andere Spielidee. Und da war für mich dann relativ schnell klar, ok, du hast jetzt hier noch einen 2-Jahre-Vertrag. Aber ich glaube, die richtig spaßigen Zeiten, die sind vorbei.
Was würdest du denn so als dein Lieblingssystem und deine Lieblingsspielphilosophie beschreiben?
Ja, also eindeutig das, was Pep spielt. Also egal ob bei Bayern, Man City jetzt oder bei Barcelona. Ich finde diese Art von Fußball schon einfach extrem geil. Zum einen, weil sie so proaktiv, so mutig ist, so schön anzuschauen und dann auch noch so erfolgreich. Also für mich geht da kaum was drüber. Es macht einfach den meisten Spaß. Es gibt andere Systeme, die auch beeindruckend sind. Ich finde es Wahnsinn, Athletiker in Madrid zu studieren. Wie die verschieben, verteidigen, wie das Zentrum dicht machen, wie die alle Mann hinter einem Ball kriegen. Was die einfach für eine Intensität im Spiel haben, wie die ihre Zweikämpfe führen. Mega, mega geil. Aber ich glaube, als Spielertyp fand ich es immer cooler, den Ball selber zu haben. Im Zweifel verliere ich lieber auch mal ein Spiel und habe aber viele Ballaktionen, 70% Ballbesitz. Ich versuche selber kreativ zu sein, als den Gegnern nur daran zu hindern, selber kreativ zu werden und dann die ein, zwei Momente auszunutzen, um ihn zu bestrafen.
Und wo hast du am liebsten gestanden auf dem Feld?
Links außen tatsächlich, in dieser verkappten Zehnerrolle. Ich war nie einer, der nur am Flügel spielt, sondern immer wieder in diesen Sechser-Raum reinkommen. Eigentlich immer zwischen Innenverteidiger, Außenverteidiger und Sechser, sodass eigentlich gar keiner recht wusste, wer es zuständig wäre. Das war eigentlich meine Lieblingsrolle, über die ich unheimlich spät erst entdeckt. Also ich war in der Bundesliga eher Zehner, Achter, auch Sechser. Und wie gesagt, damals habe ich auch nicht so recht verstanden, wie man wirklich Fußball spielt. Also es hört sich so banal an, aber ich wusste einfach lange Zeit nicht, dass man quasi so, na wie kann man das jetzt hier im Radio quasi billig genug beschreiben, das was Barcelona ja immer so cool macht, dass die Spieler aus dem Deckungsschatten rausgehen, dass die diese Diagonalbälle in den Rücken des Mittelfeldspielers spielen. Also diese Dreiecke, diese Aufbauern und so weiter, dass man aber auch nicht zu nah zum eigenen Mitspieler gehen darf, dass man einander Platz geben muss, dann das Timing von gewissen Rotationen, dass wenn ich in der Sekunde zu früh laufe, dass es dann dem anderen irgendwie schwerfällt oder ich den Ball selber gar nicht kriegen kann. Diese ganzen Kleinigkeiten, dieses Bewusstsein, hatte ich leider in meiner Zeit in Deutschland noch nicht so wirklich. Das war eher so, wo kann ich mich anspielen lassen? Ah, ich will den Ball und dann laufe ich im Zweifel sogar noch auf den Ballführenden drauf. Kann mich da natürlich auch nicht drehen oder bringe mich in die Verlegenheit, dass ich quasi immer noch einen extra Gegenspieler auf mich lade. Weil wenn ich natürlich vor den Mann komme, muss ich halt einen mehr ausspielen. Das war halt diese Barcelona-Idee, die er dann den Weltfußball erobert hat, die für mich selber auch mega Sinn gemacht hat. Und da ist die Rechnung bei mir zum ersten Mal richtig aufgegangen.
Ja, spannend. Der linksaußen, bei dem aber keiner so genau wusste, warum er dann ständig im Halbraum und in der Zentrale zu finden war. Und dann ist es auch schwierig, ihn zu decken. Jetzt hast du ja schon so ein bisschen angedeutet, wann du dann entschieden hast, deine Karriere zu beenden. Oder hattest du damals noch mal den Plan zu wechseln? Also du hast gesagt, es kam dann eben die andere Spielidee. Ihr hattet noch eine Reihe von interessanten Spielen. Aber ich will jetzt auch nicht alle 90 Minuten hier durchgehen. Sonst schaffen wir den Rest nicht mehr. War da dann auch der Gedanke schon klar, okay, das war es jetzt dann auch generell mit meiner Profifußballkarriere? Oder wolltest du erst noch vielleicht was anderes ausprobieren?
Ich habe kurz noch mal überlegt, vielleicht nach Asien zu gehen. Mein Freund Smith, unser damaliger Kapitän, der hat uns dann Richtung Bangkok verlassen. Er hat dann da auch besucht und fand das irgendwie auch ganz cool. Die Liga, ganz spannend. Auch viele Ausländer eingekauft. Schweizer, Spanier, Brasilianer, da war einiges auch am Start. Die hatten auch ganz gute Stadien. Da dachte ich mir, ein Jahr Bangkok, das ist auf dem Rückweg vielleicht noch ganz cool. War aber gar nicht so einfach, als 36-Jähriger da auch noch den Verein zu finden. Dazu kam dann auch noch, dass ich zum ersten Mal in meiner Karriere auch echt Probleme mit den Sprunggelenken hatte. Wahrscheinlich auch durch die Champions League und deswegen dann noch mal die viele Reiserei. Ich hatte dann wirklich dieses typische Fußballer-Ding, das du erst mal 20 Minuten brauchst, um die Schmerzen wegzulaufen. Da habe ich dann innerlich schon so gemerkt, es gab so diese zwei Herzen in meiner Brust. Das eine war, dieses Ding auch wieder zu sagen, naja, aber du bist einmal im Leben nur Fußballer. Also sollst du es vielleicht nicht doch nochmal ausreizen. Das andere war irgendwie so echt dieses Gefühl, naja, weißt du was, jetzt ist es auch gut. Also war eine geile Reise, hast mega viel mitgenommen, also viele Höhen und Tiefen, auch einiges gelernt, die Welt gesehen. Jetzt geht es mit dem Körper auch echt bergab. Lass gut sein, jetzt ist es so, wie es sein soll.
In welchem Zustand ist denn so ein Profifußballer-Körper deiner Erfahrung nach am Ende der Karriere?
Meiner noch in einem recht guten. Also wenn man meine Knie oder Hüfte oder so anschaut, ist echt alles top. Bei mir ist der Verschleiß in den Sprungrängen halt krass. Also ich hab's ja angedeutet, in Australien sehr physische Liga. Also viele Tacker sind auch abgekommen. Da fehlen halt Bänder und es gibt Verknöcherungen. Und ich muss dann auch nach der Karriere, wurde dann zwei Mal noch operiert, einfach um drin sauber zu machen. Also da waren dann irgendwie die Knochensplitter im Band verfangen und solche Sachen, ganz normale Atoskopie hat dann auch. Einfach sauber machen.
Das ist krass. Und du hast dann deine Karriere beendet und dich erstmal im Hintern verletzt. Habe ich gehört, glaube ich, in irgendeinem Interview mit dir.
Ja, das war besonders schlau, weil ich dann Wochen, Monate gar nichts gemacht habe. Ich fand irgendwie das geilste direkt nach der Karriere endlich mal keinen Sport mehr machen zu müssen. Wo man normalerweise sagt, abtrainieren und vielleicht hat man auch diesen Drang in sich, sich bewegen zu wollen oder so. Aber irgendwie habe ich das schon gut abgefeiert, dass ich endlich mal nicht diszipliniert sein muss. Also das war ja früher auch so im Urlaub oder so. Du musst es, du wusstest es, wenn du es nicht machst, es wird richtig schwer, die Vorbereitung wird hart, du kriegst es vielleicht gar nicht aufgeholt und es ist einfacher fit zu bleiben, als sich wieder fit zu machen. Also immer so dieses Gefühl jeden zweiten, dritten Tag, ich muss eigentlich joggen gehen, ich muss eigentlich ins Gym. Und dass das auf einmal weg war, das war halt richtig geil. Nur dann hat mich ein Kumpel angerufen und meinte, wir spielen heute in der Halle. Das war nach Monaten, eben hatte er nach der OP auch noch so ein bisschen, naja, also kein Reha und war dann noch so ein bisschen am Struggeln. Und habe er gemeint, ach komm, wir sind in der Halle mit so ein paar Jungs, das wird lustig. War auch ganz lustig. Also ging dann auch irgendwie in der Dreiviertelstunde ganz gut. Bis dann irgendwann, ja, da kam der Stich so in der Po-Gegend.
Gut, so ist es halt. Dann warst du halt zum ersten Mal ein richtiger Freizeitsportler, Thomas. Weil so ist das bei uns allen. Wir gehen auch nur so in die Halle und denken uns ja, was, was, what could possibly go wrong? Und dann, dann genau solche Dinge sind es dann nämlich, die, die wrong gehen, weil man halt einfach nicht austrainiert ist. Herzlich willkommen in unserer Welt. Also sieben Jahre warst du in Australien und wir haben das ja sehr ausführlich aufgearbeitet, was es auch für dich bedeutet hat. Hast du in Australien den Fußball gefunden, den du dir ausgemalt hast? Vielleicht als du Kind, Jugendlicher warst, als das alles noch nicht gar nicht so klar vor dir lag?
Nee, so will ich es auch nicht sagen, weil ich glaube mir nicht klar war, was ich mir überhaupt ausgemalt habe. Also dieses Ding, ich möchte Profifußballer werden, das ist nicht verbunden mit einer Vorstellung davon, wie es tatsächlich sein könnte, Profifußballer zu sein. Also man macht sich ja kein Bild davon, oder man überlegt sich nicht, wie sich das wohl anfühlen mag. Das ist eher so, hey Bundesliga, das ist das Nonplusultra, da spielen deine Idole, da möchte ich auch mal hin. Und was das dann bedeutet von der Belastung, vom Team Spirit, vom Umgang mit Medien oder Fans oder so, da macht man sich positiv wie negativ keine Vorstellung von.
Das heißt, negativ kann ich total gut nachvollziehen, aber positiv, du hattest nicht den Traum, dass du dir einfach vorgestellt hast, als du eben in deiner Kindheit, in deiner Jugend Fußball gespielt hast und es dann so langsam sich abgezeichnet hat, vielleicht könnte das ja tatsächlich irgendwie was werden. Stellt man sich da nicht ständig vor, wie es jetzt wäre, um 15.30 Uhr in irgendeinem vollen Bundesligastadion einzulaufen, das entscheidende Tor zu machen und alle sagen, Megatyp?
Ich glaube nicht, dass es Kindern darum geht, dieses Gefühl, wenn ich jetzt da in Dortmund vor 80.000 in eine Bude mache, wie die mich dann feiern oder so. Vielleicht auf einer total unterbewussten Ebene, dass die sich denken, ja, aber jetzt in Dortmund Tor machen, das wäre doch geil.
Kinder vielleicht nicht, aber als Jugendliche, so mit 15, 16, 17, weil du musstest ja dann auch viel aufgeben für den Fußball. Warum hast du das denn dann eigentlich gemacht?
Auch da glaube ich, dass es oft im Leben gar nicht so viele Gründe gibt, warum man etwas macht. Also ich habe mich irgendwie früh festgelegt, ich wollte Fußballer werden, war halt auch ein guter Fußballer und man macht halt auch gern das, worin man gut ist. Also das ist ja irgendwie bei allen Menschen so und dann geht es halt so Sprosse für Sprosse auf der Leiter nach oben und irgendwie ist auch der Endpunkt klar, wohin das hinführen könnte und soll. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das Leben so ein unfassbarer Plan ist. Und selbst wenn man Ziele hat, weiß man oft gar nicht, warum man eigentlich diese Ziele hat. Das ist einfach eher oft was, was sich fast schon ergibt. Also das hört sich jetzt sehr fatalistisch an, aber ich glaube, dass es oft überhöht wird mit dieser Zielsetzung.
Na gut, im Nachhinein kann man so Biografien halt auch am besten nachher erzählen. Dass man sagt, guck mal, als Sechsjähriger hat er in einem Spiel nach 0 zu 3 Rückstand alleine vier Tore geschossen. Und genauso hat er doch dann 15 Jahre später die Meisterschaft eingetütet. Das ist halt so eine Ex-Post-Betrachtung, die einfach sehr einfach ist. Und die ehrlichere Variante ist aber vielleicht, naja, manchmal ist es halt auch einfach so. Und wenn ich zum Beispiel dann die Frage stelle, habe ich mir auch aufgeschrieben, wie bist du zum Fußball gekommen? Du hast 1987, also im Alter von sechs Jahren, beim AVR Rott am Inn angefangen. Dann wird wahrscheinlich die Antwort sein, naja, so wie jeder in Deutschland zum Fußball kommt, man macht es halt einfach.
Genau, so wie jeder andere auch. Und nicht nur Fußball. Also warum wählt man auf dem GIMI bestimmte Zweige? Warum nimmt der eine naturwissenschaftlich, der andere irgendwie sprachlich? Es ist immer, dass man sich denkt, naja, aber in der heutigen Zeit ist es ja schon wichtig, Englisch und Französisch zu sprechen oder Latein. Oder ist es vielleicht einfach nur, weil dein bester Kumpel in die Richtung geht und dann...
Weil die ganzen Mädchen in der Französischen Zweig sind.
Im Zweifel auch das. Also immer so zu tun, als wüsste man genau, warum man welchen Schritt im Leben gemacht hat. Oh mein Gott, ich glaube, das ist einfach nicht so. Das war bei meinen ganzen Wechseln so auch die Nummer nach Australien. Es ist passiert. Und da kann man im Nachhinein viel reininterpretieren. Und das ist auch nicht misszuverstehen. Also es gibt natürlich diesen Drive. Und es gibt auch diese Ziele. Und die haben diese brutale Magnetwirkung. Also wenn du als Fußballer, als Junge dir in den Kopf setzt, ich will Bundesliga spielen, da gibst du alles dafür. Da gibst du furchtbar viel auf. Und du trainierst Tag und Nacht. Und da ist irgendwie dieser Wille. Aber was du da eigentlich willst, ich glaube, das weißt du dir selber gar nicht.
Ja, vielleicht halt auch einfach nur einem Ziel nacheufern. Das ständige Streben, das eben einfach in jedem drin ist.
Und das ist doch das eigentlich Schöne. Also dieses, ich mach Fortschritte, ich werd besser, ich nähe mich einem Ziel, ich erreiche ein Ziel. Und es ist oft gar nicht so wichtig, was das ist. Ob einer Gitarre spielt oder Computerspiele, ganz egal. Einfach dieses Besserwerden an sich ist irgendwie ein unfassbar lohnenswerter Prozess. Also die Gefühle, die dadurch ausgeschüttet werden. Also sich selber gegenüber einfach, dass man sieht, dass Disziplin und Auseinandersetzung mit etwas zu etwas führt, ist schon mal cool. Und dann je besser du irgendwas meisterst, desto geiler ist das Feedback, was du kriegst, ist auch wieder geil. Also warum nicht einfach weitermachen dabei?
Ja klar, entweder man sagt dazu, der Weg ist das Ziel, oder man sagt, oder man kann es mit Faust kommen. In dem Moment, wo du sagst, Augenblick verweile doch, dann kommt der Mephisto ums Eck und sagt, danke, ich habe meine Wette gewonnen.
Boah, jetzt aber.
Aber bei dir kann man es ja machen im Tribüngespräch. Sonst halte ich mit dem Wenigen, was mir aus dem Germanistikstudium geblieben ist, eher hinter dem Berg. Also, in Rot am Inn hast du gespielt. Dann bist du zum TSV 1860 Rosenheim gewechselt, 1993, im Alter von 12 war das dann, bis 96. Und dann zur Spielvereinigung unter Haching. Und als jemand, der dich eben quasi nur ex post deinen Lebensweg verfolgt, würde ich sagen, das könnte so der Moment gewesen sein, wo sich so angedeutet hat, vielleicht ist da eine, du hattest einen kleinen Fuß in der, in der sich sehr schnell schließenden Tür Profifußball.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich schon positiv formuliert, weil wenn du bei Haching in der Jugend spielst, dann hast du mal mindestens 22 bei Bayern und 60, die besser sind. Das heißt, ernsthaft zu glauben, dass man Profi werden könnte, ist eigentlich dumm. Also man muss eher hoffen und irgendwie fast schon trotzig sein. Und so war es ja dann auch. Also ich bin über die Haching-Amateure dann nicht in den Profikader rein gekommen und musste dann umweg über Burghausen gehen und hatte dann auch irgendwie mehr Glück als verstanden. Wir sind aufgestiegen. Da kam so viel zusammen. Also dass ich nochmal Profi-Fußballer werden durfte, ist auch da wieder voll das Geschenk. Ich glaube, da waren viele andere, die ähnlich talentiert waren, in einer Situation, wo sie dieses nötige Quäntchen-Glück einfach nicht hatten.
Und kannst du das Quäntchen-Glück noch irgendwie spezifizieren? Warst du zur richtigen Zeit fit? Hattest du ein Spielstil, den andere nicht hatten? Es muss ja einen Grund gegeben haben, warum du dann zu Wacker Burghausen gewechselt bist 2001.
Ich glaube, es ist schon immer ein bisschen beides. Es ist nicht total so, dass ich ein Vollblinder war. Man muss schon, glaube ich, auch eine gewisse Eignung mitbringen. Aber was dann passiert, dass Burghausen quasi als Fast-Absteiger in der Vor-Saison plötzlich in die 2. Liga aufsteigt. Und ich dann das Glück hatte mit Rudi Bommer, eben Trainer zu haben, der mich da früh dann auch reingeschmissen hat. Und dann lief das in der 2. Liga echt auch noch ordentlich für uns. Das hätte ja so leicht so anders laufen können. Weil wenn du einfach nur ein Drittliga-Fußballer bist, dann ist es nicht einfach, irgendwie auch nur in die 2. Liga zu kommen, geschweige denn Angebote aus der Bundesliga zu haben. Aber dann kam halt der Aufstieg und die U21-Nationalmannschaft und dann kam da so ein Momentum rein. Und ja, dann war es auf einmal viel einfacher. Also es auch ganz leicht hätte sein können.
Und wie kam es, dass du dann im Alter von 20er schon für einen Fußballer zu Wackerburghausen gewechselt bist von Unterhaching aus?
Was da einfach nicht weiterging. Also bei Haching war es so, die hatten damals glaube ich 30 Spieler im Erstligakader und haben halt auch einen Fußball gespielt, der so aufs Überleben ein bisschen ausgelegt war. Und da gab es für mich überhaupt keine Perspektive. Da hat keiner gesagt, wir setzen auf dich oder geduldig noch, aber du bist dabei oder so. Ich habe da mit der ersten Mannschaft nicht trainieren dürfen. Also ich war de facto zu dem Zeitpunkt, ich weiß gar nicht, war das Landesliga, war Fünfte Liga oder so, ich war ein Fünftligaspieler mit 19. Und dann kamen irgendwie glücklicherweise noch Wackerburghausen, die bei irgendeinem Länderturnier U19-Bayonauswahl, gesagt haben, ja okay, den probieren wir mal aus.
Okay, also so haben die quasi den Kontakt zu dir geknüpft. Hattest du dann zu dem Zeitpunkt schon einen Berater? Heutzutage hätte man da ja schon einen Berater.
Doch, hatte ich damals auch schon.
Und wie lief das ab? Wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Boah, wie war das damals ganz genau? Also ich denke mal, dass die Berater bei diesen Turnieren da dann auch anwesend sind und die Scouts und Trainer und so da auch hinfahren, die sich untereinander ja auch immer ganz gut kennen. Also das ist ja regional so ein bisschen aufgeteilt. Dann weiß genau der, keine Ahnung, der Wacker-Manager kennt dann schon auch ein paar Spielerberater, mit denen er in der Vergangenheit schon ein paar Mal zusammengearbeitet hat und so dieses Ding. Man kennt sich und man hat da einen und irgendwie so kam das und schaute den doch mal an und irgendwie so.
Und so ging es dann zu Wacker Burghausen und du hast schon angesprochen, dein Trainer war da Rudi Bommer. Wie war es denn im Kader? Das war ja dann zum ersten Mal auf einem gewissen Level eine neue Mannschaft, in die du ja auch reinkommen musstest. Und ich kann mir das immer schwer vorstellen, wie das eigentlich funktioniert.
War am Anfang auch hart, weil das zum ersten Mal richtiger Herrenfußball für mich war. Also das waren vielleicht nicht die begnadetsten Fußballer, aber das waren richtige Profis. Also die wussten, wie man Spiele gewinnt. Die wussten vor allem, wie man aus vielleicht auch bescheidenen Mitteln relativ viel rausholt. Also einfach mit Disziplin, mit einer gewissen körperlichen Härte, mit extremer Fitness, einfach mit einer gesunden Mentalität auch. Weil Jugendspieler sind halt irgendwie, naja, Jugendspieler, ein bisschen wild im Kopf, Fantasiegeplagt, würde ich fast schon sagen, mit einer gewissen Überheblichkeit auch gesegnet. Und gerade in Burghausen hatten wir da eine unheimliche Bodenständigkeit in der Truppe und wir sind ja auch nicht aufgestiegen mit Hurra-Fußball, sondern das war extrem defensivlastig, extrem diszipliniert. Wir hatten da einfach sehr, sehr kernige Spieler irgendwie.
Wer waren da für dich die wichtigsten Bezugspersonen im Kader?
Stefan Frühbeis war für mich total wichtig, weil der, obwohl er selber nicht so viel älter war, so ein bisschen seine Fittiche genommen hat. Er hat schnell mitbekommen, dass ich mega ungeduldig war und irgendwie auch impulsiv und er hat mich da immer wieder so eingebremst und immer wieder an meine Geduld appelliert und auch immer wieder gut zugesprochen. Aber gleichzeitig habe ich auch mal gesagt, hey, Moment mal, dir ist schon klar, dass du hier auch noch ein bisschen was lernen musst und dass du noch ein Stück weit von dem entfernt bist, was andere leisten. Als junger Spieler siehst du ja oft nur, aber der Alte, der kann da nicht kicken. Es liegt in der Natur der Sache, dass du als neue Generation, also in den meisten Fällen ist es ja so, es ist ja immer auch eine Evolution, du bist der bessere Fußballer. Aber der bessere Fußballer gewinnt dir keine Spiele. Also diesen Irrglauben, den muss man als junger Spieler irgendwann mal ablegen. Es sind die Jungs, die keine Fehler machen, die sich nicht verstecken in den wichtigen Momenten, die einfach eine gewisse Konstantverlässlichkeit, auch Disziplin irgendwie auf den Platz bringen. Das gewinnt dir Spiele. Und nicht irgendwie, ob du jetzt einen Übersteiger machst oder vielleicht auch mal zwei ausspielen kannst.
Okay, und das hat dir sicherlich dann auch Rudi Bommer beigebracht. Aber du durftest ja dann auch relativ schnell ran. Irgendwann, 6. oder 7. Spieltag war das, glaube ich. Kannst du dich eigentlich an dein erstes Spiel in der Regionalliga Süd noch erinnern?
Ja, weil es schnell vorbei war. Also, da sind einmal die Köpfe aneinander gerumst und dann war nach, glaube ich, 20 Minuten schon Schluss.
Genau, 30 Minuten hast du insgesamt gespielt. Beim 1. FC Kaiserslautern der 2. Mannschaft allerdings. Aber immerhin gewonnen. Also, du hattest sofort einen Effekt aufs Team.
Ja, unheimlich.
Hast du an die Zeit noch besondere Erinnerungen, die so ein bisschen rausstechen, jetzt bevor es dann in die 2. Liga ging? Aber für dich war ja wahrscheinlich auch schon Regionalliga ein Erlebnis.
Ja, war es auf jeden Fall. Also, es war für mich zum ersten Mal Profifußball, also auch unter Profi-Bedingungen, arbeiten. Jeden Morgen, jeden Nachmittag einfach zur Arbeit zu gehen und Fußballer zu sein. Also, das war sensationell. Und dann auch direkt in so einer erfolgreichen Truppe zu spielen. Das war natürlich ein mega Gefühl. Also, wenn du so in Profifußball einsteigst, das ist natürlich herrlich. Und ich habe auch an Rudi Bommer noch eine Erinnerung als Trainer ganz konkret, weil wir vorher auch schon über Taktik ein bisschen gesprochen haben. Der hatte damals mit einer relativ einfachen Idee sehr viel Erfolg mit Burghausen. Also für ihn war diese Idee, vertikal spielen, klatschen lassen. Das stand im Vordergrund seines Spiels. Dadurch hattest du eine gewisse Absicherung immer, weil wenn du vertikal spielen lässt und der Ball verloren geht, hast du ja immer Leute hinterm Ball auch. Das ist ja oft so das Problem, wenn du weit aufgerückt bist und irgendwie den Ball zirkulieren lässt. Wenn er verloren geht, ist mit Unterpolen halt offen. Wir hatten damals eine sehr, sehr massierte Defensive und mussten aber nach vorne auch trotzdem ein Tor kreieren. Da war diese Spielidee, dieses Vertikal klatschen lassen, eine der frühesten taktischen Ideen, die bei mir so hängen geblieben sind.
Und du warst wahrscheinlich einer von denjenigen, der klatschen lassen musste?
Nein, der Ball ging meistens zum Stürmer. Und meine Aufgabe war, nachzurücken.
Kannst du dich an dein erstes Tor noch erinnern?
Ich glaube, es könnte gewesen sein, dass das innen allen war, so ein Linkschuss aus 20 Metern.
Exakt.
Ich habe nicht so viele gemacht.
Ja, da wollte ich auch noch mit dir drüber sprechen. Woran würdest du denn sagen, müsste man einen Spieler wie dich, also dessen Erfolg bemessen? Denn in der Retrospektive hat man immer dieses klassische Ding, dass man erst mal guckt, wie viele Tore hat er gemacht, wie viele Vorlagen hat er gemacht. Aber jetzt gibt es ja ganz viele Positionen im Fußball, die gar nicht genuin Tore und Vorlagen machen müssen. Aber vielleicht deine, zumindest die Vorlagen. Wo würdest du dich denn da so einsortieren? Was war deine Aufgabe bei deinem Verein?
Ja, schon das.
Also ist es bei dir in Ordnung, wenn ich die Tore ziehe?
Ja, natürlich geht es darum. Und da habe ich ja auch krass andere Performen. Das muss man einfach so sagen. Ich war nie einer, der viele aufgelegt hat, nie einer, der viele geschossen hat. Und das ist halt unterm Strich auch zu wenig. Und das ist auch der Grund, warum es da nicht reicht. Ich meine, drüber hinaus gibt es diese anderen Elemente. Also Beizirkulation ist heute wichtiger denn je. Und es gibt krasse Spieler. Xavi Iniesta, glaube ich, stechen da wahnsinnig raus, die auch ohne wahnsinnig viele Scorer-Punkte, glaube ich, krasse Einfluss auf das Spiel einer Mannschaft haben. Aber im Grunde soll es schon auch darum gehen, gerade für einen Achter, für ein Flügelspieler oder so, dass er immer wieder auch... Es sind nicht immer diese Werte, die erwartet werden. Leute wollen ja am liebsten immer 10 Tore, 8 Vorlagen oder so. Ich finde, das ist für die meisten einfach unrealistisch. Und da tut man den Spielern keinen Gefallen. Aber wenn es möglich wäre, so 5, 5 oder so, wenn man pro Saison einstreuen könnte, wäre es schon ideal.
Und würdest du dir wünschen, dass da auch in der breiteren Öffentlichkeit noch genauer hingeguckt würde? Weil man kann sich ja zum Beispiel auch die kreierten Chancen angucken. Man ist ja zum Beispiel als Vorlagengeber auch immer davon abhängig, wie die Vorlage dann verwertet wird.
Ich habe eh das Gefühl, dass es passiert ist. Gerade mit der Statistik der Packingwerte, dass das irgendwie so populär wurde, wurde irgendwie klar, um was es eigentlich geht. Es geht nicht darum, 120 Ballkontakte im Spiel zu haben. Es geht vor allem darum, irgendwie Linien zu überspielen. Und jetzt wird ja auch schon geguckt, wenn die Linie überspielt wird, wie ist die Anschlussaktion? Diese Geschichten, Assists, werden irgendwie rückgerechnet. Hast du den vorvorletzten Pass gespielt? Ich glaube, dass das Spiel immer ganzheitlich auch erfasst wird. Ich glaube, dass wir da insgesamt auf einem ganz guten Weg sind.
Ihr seid dann aufgestiegen im Spiel gegen Borussia Fulda mit einem 2-0 am 32. Spieltag. Wie wird ein Aufstieg in die 2. Liga in einer Mannschaft wie Wackerburghausen gefeiert?
Boah, ich habe da jetzt nicht so die mega Erinnerungen dran.
Ist das schon ein Hinweis auf die Feier?
Nein, nicht unbedingt. Ich glaube, dass das mir damals echt die Welt bedeutet hat und vor allem die Perspektive zur 2. Liga. Das war Granate damals. Ich wäre total happy. Das weiß ich schon noch. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wo und wie wir gefeiert haben. Ich kann mich erinnern, auf diesem Vorplatz vom Stadion gibt es ein paar Fotos mit meinem Bruder auch. Es ist ja klar, dass meine ganze Family da war. Wir sehen mega happy aus auf den Fotos, aber an die Nacht habe ich jetzt eigentlich kaum Erinnerung.
Und wie warst du damals so drauf? Du hast schon gesagt, man kommt am Anfang in die Mannschaft rein und hat so ein bisschen die natürliche Arroganz der jüngeren Generation. Das hast du ja vorhin ganz gut beschrieben, dass man sich fußbollerisch den alten Recken überlegen fühlt, aber dann irgendwie verstehen muss, da gibt es noch andere Aspekte. Was warst du damals dann für einen Spieler am Ende dieser ersten Saison im Profifußball?
Dieses unfertige Produkt, was ich dann irgendwie die nächsten Jahre auch immer noch war. Wie gesagt, ich habe damals, glaube ich, nicht so wirklich verstanden, wie man eigentlich Fußball spielt. Ich habe damals viel improvisiert, viel intuitiv gemacht und es ist auch vieles gut gegangen. Ich habe da ordentliche Spiele gemacht. Es war nicht so, dass ich jetzt total planlos auf dem Platz rumgelaufen bin. Aber auf der anderen Seite hatte ich auch kein Bewusstsein dafür, wie ich eigentlich spielen will.
Ja, vielleicht aber auch gar nicht so untypisch für einen jungen Spieler, oder?
Kann ich mir eigentlich schwer vorstellen, dass heute jemand aus der Jugend kommt und mit diesen Fragen noch nicht konfrontiert wurde.
Aber das ist ja dann eher eine Frage der Umgebung, die sich verändert hat für Jugendspieler.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube, dass der Fußball viel systematischer geworden ist. Seit Guardiola ist wirklich alles anders. Denk mal, dass Jugendspieler mit... Ja, ich glaube, dass wir mit sehr vielen Systemen groß werden, mit taktischen Optionen, Verhaltensweisen, Prinzipien. Es wird ja oft kritisiert, dass so ein bisschen verloren geht, dieses intuitive, dieses Straßenfußballer Ding. Wir brauchen auch nicht darüber diskutieren, dass auf dem allerhöchsten Niveau die Topspieler, die Zocker irgendwie auch immer noch den Unterschied ausmachen. Also so ein Messi, das sind Sachen, klar brauchst du die und bei aller Taktik oder so über diese Qualität geht nichts drüber hinaus, aber das Fundament, das warum eine Mannschaft eigentlich gut oder schlecht spielt, bin ich felsenfest davon überzeugt, dass das immer an der Taktik, immer am System liegt.
Und dass man da nicht immer dann den Mbappé oder den Messi oder den Neymar oder den Ronaldo braucht, wenn man den noch hat, dann noch besser. Wie war es denn dann in der zweiten Liga zu spielen? 2002, 2003 war das, du hast 32 Spiele gemacht. Was war deine Rolle bei Wacker in der Phase?
Ja, so eine Achterrolle eigentlich. Manchmal auch als Zehner.
Und in der Mannschaft?
Ja, eindeutig noch junger Spieler. Also da gab es wichtigere Spieler, sowohl sportlich als auch vom Einfluss in der Mannschaft. Also ich war damals totaler Mitläufer eigentlich.
Und ihr habt unter anderem euren ersten Sieg auswärts bei Eintracht Frankfurt geholt, die damals in der zweiten Liga gespielt haben. Insgesamt war das eine Liga mit Freiburg, Köln, Frankfurt, Mainz, Aachen, Duisburg, Union. Also da sehe ich eine ganze Reihe an interessanten Auswärtsspielen, die es da gab und auch Heimspielen. Und ihr wart nie so richtig in Abstiegsgefahr.
Ja, das lief mega gut. Und also die Spiele waren absolute Highlights. Also dann kam St. Pauli irgendwie nach Burghausen. Also allein die ganzen Fans, die da angereist sind, das war fast schon exotisch. Und dann auch das Auswärtsspiel in Köln. Das war damals noch das alte Müngersdorfer Stadion. Ich glaube, das wird gerade umgebaut. Das war schon irgendwie so diese Hausnummer, dass man irgendwie zum ersten Mal auch spürt, wow, also das ist jetzt Profifußball. Also in der Regionalliga durfte ich ja dann zum ersten Mal Profi sein unter Profibedingungen arbeiten. Aber mit diesen Stadien kommt irgendwie eine ganz andere Dimension da rein. Und ich habe das auch in der Folge immer wieder so empfunden. Also ich meine, das ist auch gar nicht respektierlich, aber es macht einen brutalen Unterschied, ob du in Jena spielst, einfach von der ganzen Atmosphäre oder in Köln. Und ich glaube auch, dass die Art und Weise, wie Spiele in so großen Stadien inszeniert werden, dass das irgendwie dem ganzen Produkt auch so gut tut. Also es wirkt dadurch viel edler und schneller und hochwertiger.
Was meinst du mit der Inszenierung? Vermutlich ja nicht, dass die Eggball-Statistik präsentiert wird von Oropax.
Nein, das nicht, einfach dieses immense Stadion, die vollen Ränge und das ganze Flair, was drum herum herrscht. Also wenn man sich manchmal Vorbereitungsspiele von Bundesligisten anschaut, so ein Trainingslager in Marbella, wo man Szenen sieht, ich finde das sieht immer so krass nach Amateurfußballer aus. Und das sind dieselben Fußballer, die zwei Wochen später zum Rückrunden auftakt, wie die krassesten Zocker aussehen.
Ja, das ist ein interessanter Punkt, das stimmt tatsächlich. Also es reicht ja auch schon, wenn diese Freundschaftsspiele sogar in den Stadien stattfinden, aber da sind dann nur 10.000 Leute, denen das Ergebnis relativ egal ist. Das hat irgendwie einen anderen Einfluss. Und das hast du dann als Spieler auch so wahrgenommen. Wie war das mit der Aufmerksamkeit der Medien? Da ist der zweite Liga wahrscheinlich noch mal ein deutlicher Unterschied zur Regionalliga.
Nicht in Bezug auf Burghausen. Also die Burghausener Medien haben sich für uns auch in der Regionalliga schon interessiert. Und das Gleiche war dann in der zweiten Liga der Fall. Die Stories wurden dann ein bisschen glamouröser. Dann redest du halt nicht mehr über Fulda, sondern dann reist du halt nach Köln und so was. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass überregionale Medien da irgendwie ankamen und plötzlich irgendwie wissen wollten, was geht eigentlich bei euch in Burghausen ab?
Okay, das kam dann erst später in deiner Karriere. Du hast dann noch 2003, 2004 bei Wacker gespielt, bis du dann irgendwann zu Borussia Mönchengladbach gewechselt bist. Und in dieser Phase ist auch der Mozart-Inzident passiert mit Stefan Reisinger, den wir vorhin schon gefühlt vor drei Stunden, es waren aber tatsächlich nur anderthalb, thematisiert haben. Und ich habe den Eindruck, so jetzt auch wieder in der Retrospective, dass sich da auch so ein bisschen die breitere Wahrnehmung deiner Person verändert hat. Auch die Aufmerksamkeit.
Also in Burghausen war ich noch irgendwie so ein Mitläufer. Und glaube ich, im Kopf auch noch relativ klar. Also ungeduldig schon, so die typischen Anzeichen der Jugend. Aber da hatte ich noch nicht so diese Flausen, die dann durch diese ganze Mozart-Nummer kamen. Dann kam der Wechsel in die Bundesliga und dann lief es ja erst so überragend. Und das war gekoppelt mit diesem Mozart-Image. Also das war ja dann am Anfang sogar mega geil. Also die Jungs in der Mannschaft, so Jan Schlaudraff, für den war ich dann der Mozart, der Holger Fach, der Trainer damals. Ich hab mich immer Mozi genannt und so. Das erste Jahr war halt echt super. Irgendwie sofort relativ viel gespielt, Tore gemacht, Tore vorgelegt und irgendwie so ein bisschen als Hoffnungsträger auch gegolten. Also da lief dann alles wie im Schnürchen und da wurde dann auch dieses Image auch ein bisschen zementiert, weil mich hat auch mit meinen Büchern durch die Gegend gelaufen und hab das schon auch sehr demonstriert auch und war alles kein Problem, solange der Erfolg da war und das sollte sich ja dann später als brutaler Boomerang erweisen.
Du hast in der Phase sowohl bei Wacker als auch dann bei Gladbach auch viel mehr Tore vorbereitet. Da gibt es auch unter anderem in der Doku ist der Ausschnitt rausgekramt, wo ein bekannter Sport1-Kommentator, damals wahrscheinlich sogar noch TSF, glaube ich, gesagt hat, Herr Hoeneß, Herr Rummenigge, Herr Assauer, glaube ich, sagte noch, schauen sie her, dieser Thomas Broich, das wäre doch einer, weil du ein besonders schönes Tor erzielt hast. Wie kam es denn dann, dass du von Burghausen zu Gladbach gewechselt bist, die im Abstiegskampf steckten?
Ja, aber die waren damals halt auf der Suche nach Talenten. Die ganze Bundesliga, das war damals so ein bisschen der Umbruch auch. Es ging so los mit Kevin Corani und dann später kam Pauli und Schweini und so. Aber das waren schon so diese Anfänge, wo plötzlich irgendwie so nach jungen Spielern gegiert wurde auch so ein bisschen. Und da wurde dann die U21 auch wichtiger. Es gab ja noch diese Zeiten, wo quasi U21-Nationalspieler keine Bundesliga-Stammspieler waren. Also wir hatten damals in der U21 viele Spieler, die bei einer zweiten Mannschaft waren, die irgendwie bei einem Regionalligisten waren. Aber dass tatsächlich jemand, so wie Kourani bei Stuttgart, Bundesliga-Stammspieler war, das war eigentlich die Ausnahme. Aber trotzdem ging es halt los, dieser Trend vermehrt auf jüngere Spieler aufzusetzen. Und dann war es tatsächlich so, dass damals auch ein paar Bundesligisten interessiert waren. Und Gladbach als Traditionsverein war natürlich der Wahnsinn. Und dann Christian Hochstetter und Holger Fach haben sich da auch echt bemüht und mich da eingeladen und das ist super beeindruckend, dass als junger Spieler und das war natürlich schon ein Traum, dass der Wechsel zustande kam.
Und nach welchen Kriterien entscheidet man das dann? Also klar, auf dem Bauch wirst du auch gehört haben in den Gesprächen mit Hochstetter und Fach. Aber wenn du sagst, es waren noch andere Bundesligisten interessiert, du könntest ja jetzt sogar auch sagen, welche, jetzt ist es ja egal. Wie entscheidet man sich da, stelle ich mir schwierig vor.
Also es war damals echt die Strahlkraft des Vereins auch. Also Gladbach ist halt eine Nummer, einfach so ein richtiger Traditionsverein. Das war ja schon mal was besonderes.
Und warum bist du im Winter gewechselt? Eigentlich ungewöhnlicher Zeitpunkt.
Ich denke mal, dass ich damals einfach so schnell wie möglich in die Bundesliga wollte.
Und Gladbach hatte ich halt auch gebraucht, weil es ging eben um den Kampf gegen den Abstieg. Wie war es denn dann mit Holger Fach und in diese Erstligamannschaft reinzukommen? Das ist ja, so wie es bei vielen Spielern ist, am Anfang wirkt das wie eine ganz, ganz schnelle Karussellfahrt. Und man hat den Eindruck, wir schnipsen einmal, du bist im Profifußball, wir schnipsen nochmal, du bist in der zweiten Liga, wir schnipsen nochmal und du bist in der ersten Bundesliga. Und so wird sich ja auch ein bisschen angefühlt haben.
Ja, und du merkst dann direkt nochmal den Unterschied. Also Training in Gladbach war um so viel schneller wieder. Also das war so heftig wie handlungsschnell die Spieler damals waren. Man musste da in der Kürze der Zeit echt viel lernen auch und da war Holger Fach auch extrem wichtig und der stand da wirklich auch mit der Peitsche und hat sich sehr auch auf mich konzentriert und unheimlich viel mit mir gearbeitet. Und ich weiß noch, das war teilweise auch gefühlt die Hölle, also ich musste dann oft bei so Trainingsspielchen, wo wir ohne Tore gespielt haben, war ich dann der Joker und musste immer anspiegelbar sein und der stand da wirklich und hat gefühlt nur auf mich geguckt und immer wieder, ey nicht einschlafen, anbieten, ey immer dieses wirklich permanente Antreiben und das war ein harter Prozess, so dass ich oft irgendwie heim ging, also auch viele Bälle dann verloren habe oder irgendwie das Gefühl hatte, ich machs einfach nicht gut genug und so. Ich war dann echt ein bisschen down und auch da wieder die Sache, du bist dann wieder zum ersten Mal eigentlich von zu Hause weg und irgendwie so allein in der großen Welt und dann Bundesliganiveau und dann hockst du da in Gladbach und das war dann teilweise auch ein bisschen einsam und ein bisschen frustrierend, aber das hat es halt auch total beschleunigt. Also da muss ich dem Fahri echt ein Kompliment sagen, das hat er damals überragend gemacht, dass er mich in der Kürze der Zeit an die Mannschaft angeführt hat.
Ja, genau. Du hast ja dann auch sehr schnell gespielt und das in einem Kader mit Jörg Stiel, Uwe Kamps, das sind so geile Namen, Klaus Reitmeier, Steffen Kurel, Jeff Strasser, Joris van Hout, Marcel Jansen, damals 17 Jahre alt, Max Eberl, 29 Jahre alt, Per Kluge, Jan Schlaudraff, Ari van Lent, ich könnte noch viel, viel mehr aufzeichnen. Aber das war ein schöner Mix, hat man ja schon an den Namen gemerkt, aus wirklich Vereinslegenden zum Teil ja sogar bis hin zu ganz jungen Spieler, wie zum Beispiel Marcel Jansen oder eben dich kann man da auch mit dazu rechnen. Wie fügt man sich denn dann in so eine Mannschaft ein? Läuft das genauso wie in Burghausen, dass man irgendwie so vielleicht einen findet, mit dem man ganz gut kann oder verändert sich da noch mal was zur ersten Liga, dass jeder eigentlich so sein eigenes Ding macht und man gegen die Etablierten bloß nicht aufmuckt?
Na, es gibt schon eine steile Hierarchie, also man weiß schon, wo man steht so am Anfang, aber irgendwie ist das auch okay. Sucht sich halt dann so ein paar andere junge Spieler, so Oli Kirch, Jan Schlautraff, Enrico Gelde damals, wir waren dann relativ schnell Buddies. Und das war schon alles gut. Was mir total leid tut, ist irgendwie, dass ich damals ja, und das ist jetzt ja so offensichtlich, so geile Mitspieler hatte. Also es war auch damals schon klar, dass so ein Steffenkorel, Max Eberl, dass sie das Herz am rechten Fleck haben, dass denen das Wohl des Vereins, also dass es bei denen an vorderster Stelle steht, dass es denen darum geht, auch Mentor zu sein für junge Spieler. Und die haben mit mir geredet und die haben mich gewarnt vor gewissen Entwicklungen und Aussagen, Interviews und so weiter und wollten mich wirklich drauf einstellen, was da kommen mag. Und ich war damals leider so ein bisschen ignorant. Also schade eigentlich, dass man so ein perfektes Umfeld vorgefunden hat und als junger Spieler einfach nicht in der Lage war, irgendwie das Beste draus zu machen.
Ja, das ist so, wenn man zurückblickt ins Leben, dass man auch einfach Dinge an sich selbst sieht, die haben dann vielleicht nicht so gefallen. Was hast du denn damals für Verhaltensmuster mitgebracht aus Burghausen? Also man kann ja die tollsten Geschichten über dich lesen. Michael Oening hat mir gesagt, du hättest sogar im Entmüdungsbecken dann Bücher gelesen. Du wolltest deine Gitarre mitnehmen auf Auswärtsfahrten. Du hast halt generell einen anderen Lebensstil geführt, als ich würde mal sagen, die Mehrheit an Menschen um dich außen rum. War das damals in Gladbach auch schon so? Für mich ist das so weit weg, dass ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, wie es ist in jungen Jahren auf einmal in einem so hoch professionellen Gebilde zu sein, was aber vielleicht dann auch beim näheren Hinsicht gar nicht so professionell ist.
Na, eigentlich hat sich das erst in Gladbach entwickelt. Also ich kam noch als relativ normaler Bursche nach Gladbach und dieser Fluch, der Anfang, der Segen der Anfangszeit, dieser sportliche Erfolg, der wirklich geil war, den mal mitzunehmen, der wurde halt ziemlich schnell zum Fluch, weil meine Reaktion darauf irgendwie leider recht überheblich war. Und dann habe ich angefangen, diese ganzen Verhaltensmuster zu entwickeln. Und als es dann nicht lief, bin ich dann sogar noch ein bisschen. Ja, dann wurde ich so bockig, trotzig irgendwie. Dann wurde ich es erst recht und irgendwie so mein eigenes Ding machen. Und wenn du dann sportlich auch dann keine Rolle spielst oder andere dir vorgezogen werden oder du dann plötzlich wieder nach Bocholt musst, nochmal Amateure spielen auf so einem gefühlten Acker und so. Und dann glaube ich, dann brauche ich das irgendwie für mich selber, irgendwie zu sagen, so nach dem Motto, naja, aber das ganze Bundesliga-Gedöns, wer braucht das schon? Ich habe keine Ahnung, meine Bücher oder sonst irgendwas. Total unreif und bockig, aber ich konnte es halt damals anders nicht einfach sehen. Also ich kam aus, ich kann mit dieser heftigen Kritik, mit diesen Rückschlägen, mit dem Gegenwind, den man logischerweise irgendwie erfährt, an dem man normalerweise wächst, mit dem kam ich so irgendwie gar nicht klar und ich habe mich da in eine sehr schlechte Richtung entwickelt. Ich wurde dann immer rebellischer, immer mehr Anti-Haltung.
Um das zu verstehen, wie das dann war, auf einmal wieder in der Oberlinge spielen zu müssen, dann unter Dick Advokat, müssen wir glaube ich noch kurz den Hörern und Hörern erzählen, was du meinst, wenn du sagst, es lief ja am Anfang sehr erfolgreich. Also im ersten Spiel im Derby, das war ein Auftakt der Rückrunde, da warst im Kader, aber wurde es noch nicht eingewechselt, aber dann gleich gegen den damaligen Tabellen ersten Werder Bremen 90 Minuten gespielt, dann beim Tabellen dritten Stuttgart gespielt, da auch die erste Vorlage gegeben. Also es ging sehr, sehr schnell, dass du auch auf dem Spielfeld standst, nicht nur in der Mannschaft warst.
Ey, das war echt gefühlt, einmal schnippen, so wie du es vorher erzählt hast. Ich war gerade noch in Gladbach mit diesen Anfangsschwierigkeiten, so oh mein Gott, ist das ja alles schnell im Training und dann einmal noch 90 Minuten auf der Bank und plötzlich war ich mitten drin im Geschehen.
Und war es denn dann auch im Training schon besser oder?
Viel besser. Das Ding war dann auch, dann kam das Selbstvertrauen dazu und zu der Zeit war ich halt auch ein Spieler, der total von diesem Selbstvertrauen abhängig war. Ich habe dir erzählt, was für mich früher Gefühl, für Faktoren waren, warum ich gut oder schlecht war oder so. Das war viel mit Spritzigkeit zusammen, mit Selbstvertrauen, diesen ganz weichen, kaum greifbaren und kaum planbaren Faktoren. Und in der Phase war das halt maximal gegeben. Da habe ich dann intuitiv einfach gute Entscheidungen getroffen und dann fällt da noch ein Tor und da noch ein Assist und dann wird das ja immer noch mehr und noch besser. Also sportlich war das eine relativ einfache Phase. Da musste ich gar nicht viel drüber nachdenken, was eigentlich gerade passiert.
Was waren dann da so die schönsten Momente in der Phase? Erstes Tor gegen den HSV, erste Minute, die du dann da in der Startelf standst gegen Werder oder besondere Auswärtsspiele wie eben bei den Bayern. Was ist dir da so hängen geblieben aus der Phase?
Also genau die Sachen. Das erste Tor, was ja eigentlich auch ein Zufallsprodukt war, so eine Freistoßflanke, wie der Wind hinten reinträgt, okay, aber dann hast du den ersten Bundesligator.
Und das war der Dosenöffner, das war irgendwie zweiter Halbzeit beim Stand von 0 zu 0, das 1-0 gegen den HSV und dann habt ihr das 3-0 gewonnen.
Ja, mega geil dieses Gefühl dann auf dem alten Bökelberg noch. Also ich bin total ausgerastet. Und dann der erste Assist war schon auch cool. Das war so ein kleiner, schicker Durchsteckpass. Immer schön, wenn so einer gelingt. Und dann kam echt das Spiel bei den Bayern, haben wir 5-2 verloren, glaube ich sogar. Spielte aber keine Rolle. Ich kam, komme aus München und bin mit Raimond Aumann, Giorgini und Co. groß geworden. Und dann noch mal im Olympiadienst zu spielen. Das war auch noch mal richtig, richtig krass. Da hat es fast keine Rolle gespielt, dass wir verloren haben. Also das waren tolle Momente, tolle Erlebnisse.
Und wie hast du dann deine öffentliche Wahrnehmung in Gladbach dann erlebt in dieser Phase? Denn in dich wurden ja auch viele Hoffnungen gesetzt, die du ja auch erfüllt hast. Also die Rückrunde verlief dann so, dass am Ende dann Gladbach gesichert rausgekommen ist. Es ging dann eben nicht in die Abstiegsregionen. Ihr standet, glaube ich, nur einmal, ganz kurz mal auf einem Abstiegsplatz. Gab es da noch Leute, die auch Dinge an dir kritisiert haben? Oder war das so, dass du da durch die Stadt gelaufen bist und jeder hat gesagt, cool, dass du da bist, mega Typ, nächste Saison Europa?
Also innerhalb der Truppe ja und auch Holger Fach als Trainer. Also es war schon so deutlich der Tenor, hey, Kirche im Dorf lassen, du spielst gut, aber nicht so gut, wie dich die Leute gerade machen. Aber wollte ich halt in dem Moment nicht hören, weil warum mich irgendwie runterziehen lassen. Und man vermutet ja dann auch so, grad bei Älteren vielleicht auch so ein bisschen, wenn ich neid oder so, aber dass sie einen halt auch ein bisschen einbremsen wollen in dem eigenen Erfolg, das ist ja auch immer so ein bisschen Konkurrenzkampf. In der Stadt war es ganz krass, in den Medien war wirklich diese Hoffnungsträgernummer und gefühlt war ich da echt dann so on track auch für die Nationalmannschaft. Dachte mir so, ja krass, jetzt Poldi und Schweinigen so, haben das, naja, wohl, haben sie es damals schon geschafft. Ich glaube, das kam in dem Jahr erst. Aber es ging halt so los, dass immer mehr junge Spieler dann auch den Weg gefunden haben. Und so gefühlt war ich da auch einer, der da ganz kurz davor stand. Also es wurde auch immer schon wieder drüber geredet. Rudi Völler hat sich dann auch zu dem Thema mal geäußert und die kamen zu spielen. Und ich dachte einfach nur, hey, einfach so weitermachen.
Das ist das, was wir im Intro gehört haben, wo du gesagt hast, na im Grunde ist es so, wenn ich jetzt einfach so weiter spiele, dann wird Rudi Völler nicht an mir vorbeikommen.
Sehr selbstbewusste Aussage, aber damals habe ich es echt so gefühlt.
Ja gut, man kann es ja auch nachvollziehen. Und meine Güte, du warst 23 zu dem Zeitpunkt, da ist man halt auch 23. Also gute Güte, muss man ja auch nicht mal alles, also es ehrt dich ja, dass du da sehr kritisch zurückblickst und das wird ja auch in der Doku sehr genau aufgedröselt. Es hängt natürlich auch mit den Dingen zusammen, über die wir jetzt dann gleich noch sprechen werden, die dann auch noch gekommen sind. Aber es ist ja auch alles nachvollziehbar und wahrscheinlich wäre es zwei von drei Leuten so ergangen.
Das Ding war bei mir vor allem, und das verstehe ich eigentlich nicht, also ich halte mich jetzt nicht für total doof, aber dass ich mir damals nicht vorstellen konnte, dass die Reise noch mal in eine andere Richtung gehen könnte. Also ich dachte irgendwie, okay, ich habe ein gewisses Niveau. Und also welch Grund sollte es geben, dass ich das nicht jetzt irgendwie die nächsten Jahre abrufen kann? Das war für mich eigentlich unerklärlich, dass ich dann so schlecht Fußball spielen konnte in der Folgezeit. Ich dachte immer so, ja, wenn man eine Sache einmal kann, dann muss man es doch auch wieder können. Ich habe damals halt nicht begriffen, was alles dazugehört, um es zu reproduzieren. Und das ist nicht nur irgendwie deine Fitness oder dein Selbstvertrauen oder die taktische Reife oder was auch immer, dass da dann auch irgendwie die Fähigkeit dazu gehört, ein Teamplayer zu sein. So banale Dinge, die helfen, diesen Level irgendwie zu halten. Und das finde ich bis heute echt schade. Also nicht so, dass ich da jetzt total rumheule oder so, weil das war eine wichtige Lektion in meinem Leben. Also als ich das dann auch begriffen habe, hat mir das unheimlich weitergeholfen. Es hilft mir heute noch weiter. Aber man hat ja immer dieses Ding, naja, ist schon irgendwie schade, weil Talent war ja da. Und was wäre ja vielleicht möglich gewesen, wenn ich damals ein bisschen reifer, ein bisschen schlauer gewesen wäre.
Also ging es ja so ein bisschen um das, was dann Posto Giochlo euch in Brisbane gelehrt hat, dass die Kunst nicht ist, an die Spitze zu kommen. Und für dich hat sich das ja erst mal angefühlt wie eine vorläufige Spitze, sondern eben dran zu bleiben. Du hast irgendwo geschrieben oder gesagt, es fühlt sich gerade an in dieser Zeit in Gladbach, als würde man eine Ernte einfahren. Und das fand ich eben dahingehend bemerkenswert, weil sich Ernte einfahren so anhört, wie jetzt müsste man auch nicht mehr säen. Also fast schon wie so ein Karriereabschluss.
Und ich glaube, ohne es jetzt im Detail zu wissen, was ich damals day to day gemacht habe, aber genau diese Einstellung meine ich zu dieser Zeit gehabt zu haben. So nach dem Motto, ja jetzt habe ich meine ganze Jugend so hart gearbeitet, auch so abstinent gelebt und so und dann bist du plötzlich Profi und jetzt ist das ein Selbstläufer. Jetzt, die nächsten zehn Jahre, das werde ich einfach nur genießen, weil kicken kann ich ja irgendwie, die Vereine stehen gerade auf mich, das wird laufen und am besten noch Nationalspieler werden. Überhaupt da nicht zu erkennen, dass es mindestens noch mal genauso viel Disziplin und Aufwand braucht, um dieses Level zu halten. Das ist eigentlich unfassbar dumm, aber wie du sagst, mit 23 oder so, da ist das auch okay.
Ja und in dem entsprechenden Umfeld eben auch. Du hast dich dann zum ersten Mal schwerer verletzt und deswegen auch im Mai 2004 die U21-WM verpasst. War das so ein bisschen der Einschnitt, der dann auch den unglückseligen Grundstein für die drauf kommende Saison gelegt hat?
Ich denke schon, weil ich damals echt mega in Form war und gerade bei der U21 mit den Mitspielern und so, das lief einfach super. Ich hatte das Gefühl, ich muss nur das Nationaltrikot überstreifen und das wird schon irgendwie laufen.
Also du hast eben damals mit Thomas Hitzesberger, Sebastian Schweinsteiger, Lukas Podolski, Philipp Lahm hat dann auch in der U21 glaube ich gespielt. Da standst du in einer Reihe mit denen.
Ja, wir hatten eine sensationelle Truppe, haben geilen Fußball gespielt und ich hab da dann gegen Ende sogar als Zehner gespielt. Also hatten die Heim-EM vor der Brust und so. Da hab ich mir echt viel erhofft und ausgemalt und dachte halt, okay, wenn du da geil spielst, dann gibt's vielleicht sogar noch eine Chance auf Portugal, glaube ich war das damals. Oder spätestens dann irgendwie Richtung Heim-WM. Also da war die Fantasie echt groß in die Richtung.
Und dann eben diese Verletzung. Kannst du mir das mal erklären, was passiert, wenn man sich verletzt? Weil man ist ja nicht nur, dass man eben das hat, der eigene Körper hat einen Stich gelassen oder sein Tribut gefordert. Man hatte Pech, dass man eben jetzt rausgerissen wird aus seinem Alltag, aber man ist ja auch aus der Gruppe der Mannschaft rausgerissen. Weil auf einmal bist du ja noch viel mehr Einzelkämpfer als sonst. Bist alleine in der Reha, hast deinen eigenen Terminplan, guckst den anderen aus der Ferne wahrscheinlich immer mal wieder zu und winkst drüber. Wie war das?
Also eigentlich easy.
Ehrlich?
Also ich bin gerne allein, immer noch, also damit habe ich echt kein Problem, aber für mich war das okay. Auch die Verletzung fand ich nicht weiter schlimm, das war halt so, okay, passiert im Fußball. Wird danach halt genauso weitergehen wie davor, wird ein bisschen dauern, bis man wieder irgendwie in Form kommt, aber eben dieses Ding, ich meine, ich kann ja kicken so, es muss ja dann irgendwann wieder kommen. Wenn es drei Wochen dauert, dauert es halt drei Wochen, aber es kam halt nicht wieder. Es war halt tatsächlich so, dass ich dann immer mehr Einsatzzeit wieder bekommen habe, auch von Anfang an gespielt habe, aber die Leistungen waren halt einfach nicht mehr vergleichbar mit den Vorderverletzungen. Und ich würde auch nicht sagen, dass es an der Verletzung lag. Also das war keine Sache von, ah, jetzt kommt er wieder und kann irgendwie sein Sprunggelenk nicht bewegen oder so. Es war eine langwierige Geschichte, drei Monate gedauert oder so, bis das völlig auskuriert war, aber es war eine Sehnenreizung, also nichts, wo du sagst, da ist im Knie was kaputt gegangen, also nichts mechanisches oder so. Und es war irgendwie komisch, dass trotzdem irgendwie so der Stecker gezogen war.
Hat das dann vielleicht auch damit zu tun gehabt, dass du Teile der Saisonvorbereitung verpasst hast? Wie wichtig ist die für so ein Bundesliga-Jahr?
Ich würde schon sagen extrem wichtig. Also ich habe immer meine besten Jahre gespielt, wenn ich echt auch eine richtig harte Vorbereitung hatte, die ich voll durchgezogen habe.
Kannst du mir erklären, warum das eigentlich so ist? Mir erscheint das immer so irre, dass man sagt, wir trainieren jetzt im Juni, Juli richtig hart, machen da auch so richtige Schweineschichten, wo alle in ihren sauren Bereich reingehen und dann soll das noch im nächsten Frühling eine Auswirkung haben?
Das ist die Grundlage, das Fundament, auf dem alles weitere Training fußt und du kannst dich auch in der Folge in der Saison nur gut belasten, wenn du eine gute Grundlage hast. Du würdest Spieler total kaputt machen, wenn du mitten in der Saison dann einfach mal noch mal drei Wochen Koalitionstraining einstreust, wenn die nicht schon eine gute Grundlage haben. Das ist ein totaler Balanceakt und es geht ja im Fußball viel drum um diese Leichtigkeit, um diese Spritzigkeit und wenn du die nicht hast, fällt vieles schwerer und die Grundlagen dafür werden halt definitiv in der Vorbereitung gelegt.
Da muss ich noch mal eine eigene Saison machen. Das finde ich wirklich einfach spannend. Aber wir wollen ja jetzt über deine Gladbacher Zeit sprechen. Jetzt geht die neue Saison los. Du hast dich dann eben peu a peu wieder rangearbeitet an die Mannschaft, aber die Gladbach selber als Verein steckte hinten drin in der Tabelle und nach einem 0 zu 3 gegen den VfL Bochum wurde dann Holger Fach entlassen. Wie hast du das damals erlebt? Ist so ein bevorstehender Trainerwechsel, hat sich ja angedeutet. Ist es auch Thema innerhalb der Mannschaft?
Da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, da kann ich mich im Einzelnen nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Und hat das für dich eine große Rolle gespielt, dass mit Holger Fach ja derjenige, den du vorhin ja, das hast du ja ganz gut beschrieben, wie er dich unter seine Fittiche genommen hat und es scheint ja auch ein gutes Verhältnis gegeben zu haben. War das für dich dann wichtig oder bedeutsam, dass da ein Wechsel vorherrscht oder hattest du damals auch schon diese Haltung, dass du dir gedacht hast, na egal, wer kommt, ich habe meine Fähigkeiten, es kann ja nur weiter hochgehen für mich?
Ich glaube, ich hatte es schon ein bisschen unterschätzt, weil der Fach, der mich damals halt geholt hat, viel mit mir gearbeitet hat und auch echt was in mir gesehen hat. Und irgendwie dachte ich, glaube ich, ohne es jetzt wirklich total genau zu erinnern, aber irgendwie denke ich schon, dass ich so eher das Gefühl hatte, naja, also es ist ja das Normalste der Welt, Trainer kommen und gehen und ja, also das Leben geht weiter, man setzt sich durch und vielleicht tut es einer Mannschaft auch gut, kommen neue Ideen rein. Irgendwie, wenn es nicht läuft, gibt es ja auch viel, es brodelt ja innerhalb der Truppe, also ohne dass ich jetzt genau auf die Situation interpretiert wissen möchte. Aber es ist ja schon so, dass es immer so einen gewissen Konflikt gibt. Also unzufriedene Spieler wird es immer da geben, wo gerade Misserfolg ist. Es heißt Reservisten oder Leute, die mit der Taktik unzufrieden sind. Und irgendwie verspricht man sich ja auch ein bisschen was von dem neuen Typen, der reinkommt. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es bei mir damals auch ähnlich war. Was ich halt nicht gecheckt habe, war, dass ich halt mit dem Fachi einfach ein Freund da in der Truppe hatte. Also ein Freund als Fußballer, der hat einfach was in mir gesehen, der hat mit mir schon gearbeitet, in mich investiert. Und dann kommt ein neuer Typ, der...
Dick Advokat.
Ja, der einfach aus Holland kommt, irgendwie andere Ideen hat, der mich dann in so einer schlechten Form auch kennenlernt und im Prinzip in seinem Kopf wahrscheinlich erstmal so eine kurze, knappe, erste Einschätzung macht und sagt so, ja, also ob das jetzt derjenige ist, auf den ich in der Situation setzen sollte, naja. Also der hat glaube ich ganz schnell in eine andere Richtung geguckt und hat sich da andere Spieler rausgesucht und dachte, die Jungs, die kriegen es für mich hin.
Du musstest dann eben, also du hast hier mal sechs Minuten gespielt, da mal sieben Minuten, dann musstest du in der Oberliga für die zweite Mannschaft spielen, auch das wird in der Doku ja sehr nachhaltig noch mal begleitet. Kommst aber auch wieder zurück und darfst dich in zwei Spielen über 90 Minuten beweisen, 0-6 gegen Hertha und 1-1 gegen Leverkusen und dann bist du wieder draußen. Hat dir Dick Advokat damals eigentlich vermittelt, warum du keine feste Rolle bei ihm hattest? Also wusstest du, woran du bist?
Also ganz spät dann und das war eigentlich ein ganz lustiges Gespräch und irgendwie auch ganz cool von ihm. Also hab ich dann irgendwann in die Trainerkabine gerufen und andersrum, ich hab's um das Gespräch gebeten und wollte einfach mal wissen, so wohin geht die Reise und so, planen sie mit mir und dann guckt er mich so an und macht einfach so Thomas, machst du Tor? Also er hat, also wir sind beide, also ist gerade überschaubar. Thomas, machst du Assists? Stand halt einfach nicht viel zu buchen, also ne, läuft grad irgendwie auch nicht so. Warum soll ich dich aufstellen? Da war irgendwie relativ schnell klar, dass es eher mal nichts mehr werden würde, aber er hatte natürlich auch recht. Also gerade in diesem holländischen System, da hatten gewisse Positionen einfach ohne Rolle. Die hatten da tatsächlich noch viel mehr irgendwie ganz bestimmt was beizutragen. Also wenn du da als links außen gespielt hast oder so, da musstest du halt deine Positionen recht diszipliniert halten, aber du warst auch derjenige, der immer wieder hinter die Abwehr kommen musste, der einfach immer wieder in Torschluß-Situationen kommen musste, führt halt einfach keinen Weg daran vorbei. Ich habe oft das Gefühl, dass in diesem modernen System, wo es ein bisschen weniger rigide ist, dass man oft auch gar nicht weiß, woher genau die Tore kommen, da streut so jeder so ein bisschen was auch mit ein. Aber damals war wirklich ganz klar die Anforderung, dass die Mittelfeldspieler und auch die Flügelspieler mindestens zehn Assists, fünf Tore oder so, sollte da kommen und alles drunter war einfach nicht gut genug.
Also deine Zahlen haben halt einfach in der Phase nicht gestimmt. Und trotzdem stelle ich mir das als eine sehr diffuse Zeit vor, denn gleichzeitig, also wir haben so zwei Pole in dieser Phase. Das eine ist, für die zweite Mannschaft in der Oberliga spielen zu müssen. Und der andere Pole ist, im Team 2006, was es ja damals noch gab, ran zu dürfen. Und da hast du unter anderem gegen Schottland ein richtig gutes Spiel gemacht. Wie geht man denn damit um? Das ist ja völlig schizophren.
Ja, so hat es sich auch angefühlt. Es war wirklich diese Nummer, Reise zur Nationalelf, Trikot überziehen und irgendwie ein anderer Spieler sein. Dann kam ich wieder heim und dann war irgendwie alles so, darf ich überhaupt spielen? Kriege ich fünf Minuten, kriege ich eine halbe Stunde, spiele ich von Anfang an. Also einfach diese ganzen Fragen, diese ganze Ballast, dieses irgendwie total blockiert sein oder so. Das kam damals schon und da hatte ich zum ersten Mal, war das Problem, dass ich so einen, in Englisch so sagen, die so Confidence-Player bin und auch lange Jahre war. Also ich konnte das wirklich erst im Späthelbst meiner Karriere so ein bisschen abstellen, aber es war absolut absurd irgendwie, also diese Spaltung, dass der gleiche Spieler in einer Woche in der Nationalmannschaft irgendwie geil spielen kann und dann im Verein irgendwie tatsächlich auch wieder schlecht spielt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich total missverstanden wurde oder so. Das konnte auch jeder sehen. Aber ich meine, wie erklärst du das dann? Und es hilft ja auch dem Vereins-Trainer nichts, wenn ich in der anderen Truppe gut spiele. Bringt ihm ja nichts.
Na gut, aber interessanterweise macht es ja dann doch was mit dem öffentlichen Druck. Also das würde ich ja noch so ein bisschen durch deine Karriere begleiten, dass es immer wieder von außen die Stimmen gab. Lass doch mal Thomas Broich spielen. Der bringt dem Spiel noch mal eine andere Note als ganz viele andere Spieler, weil du eben auch für damalige Verhältnisse noch mal ein besonderer Spielertyp warst. Ich meine, wir reden über 2004. Das war noch mal ein anderer Fußball als 2014 zum Beispiel. Und das kommt er dann schon mit rein. Also ich glaube, das kommt auch in der Doku vor, dass Dick Advokat immer wieder danach gefragt wird, wann lassen sie eigentlich mal Thomas Broich spielen? Und da hat er dann nicht gesagt, gucken sie mal her, wie viele Tore, wie viele Vorlagen hat er gemacht, sondern da hat er dann eher so ein bisschen säuerlich geantwortet. Sie fragen mich immer nach Broich. Warum eigentlich? Und das hat sich ja dann schon verändert. Also weißt du, für dich hat sich das, war es eine schizophrene Situation, aber es hatte ja dennoch auch eine Auswirkung auf deine Wahrnehmung.
Ja, es ist definitiv so, dass der Trainer dann halt eher piste reagiert, ist ja klar. Also der wusste nicht, was ich vorgelesst habe, sieht dann den Spieler, der irgendwie nicht wirklich funktioniert. Und die Journalisten wollen mich aber permanent irgendwie reinreden. Also es ist ja klar, dass er dann so ein bisschen auch dicht macht und glaube ich mit mir dann auch kein gutes Gefühl verbindet. Also das ist ja irgendwie so wie so ein Päckchen, was ihm aufgeschnürt wird. Mir selber hat es auch nicht geholfen, weil irgendwie konnte ich dadurch auch immer so mit dem Finger auf den Trainer zeigen. So nach dem Motto, naja, also dass ich eigentlich kicken kann und so, kann man ja auch ganz gut Woche für Woche, aber in regelmäßigen Abständen auch mal bestaunen. Also ich war gar nicht gezwungen, mich selber so zu hinterfragen, sondern konnte eigentlich sagen, naja, also der Trainer mag mich halt nicht irgendwie. Und das ist ja auch für jedermann offensichtlich. Und man hat ja auch mitbekommen, wie er auf der PK reagiert hat und diese Geschichte. Also das war echt eine komplizierte Situation damals.
Das glaube ich. Das war die Saison 2004, 2005. Im Sommer kamen Marek Heinz, Oliver Neuwille und Christian Ziegel, damals noch von den Spurs. Und im Winter, das war echt eine geile Zeit bei Gladbach, kommen Wesley Song, Jörg Böhme, Giovane Elber, Casey Keller und noch ein paar andere. Das waren jetzt mal nur ein paar Namen, die ich nennen wollte. Wie sah denn da das Mannschaftsgefüge aus?
Ja, permanenter Umbruch eigentlich. Also hier hat sich ja dann auch permanent verändert. Also gerade die Winter-Einkäufe, das waren ja wirklich dann fünf auf einen Schlag. Ich glaube, Philipp Darmes und so war auch noch dabei. Und dann ist ja auf einmal die erste Elf eine ganz andere. Und dann hast du wirklich diese Spieler, die der Trainer gebracht hat und die vorher da waren. Also da gibt es dann eine totale Spaltung. Und dann macht man, glaube ich, als Spieler auch den Fehler, dass man das noch verstärkt, dass man sich auch irgendwie so verhält oder dem Trainer das auch so krass vorwirft, also unterschwellig. So nach dem Motto, du stehst ja nicht auf mich. Und das macht es nicht besser. Also selbst wenn es stimmen würde, was ich echt nicht glaube. Also ich glaube, dass Trainer in erster Linie das machen, was für den Mannschaftserfolg das Beste ist. Also sie wären total Banane, wenn sie es nicht machen würden. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass irgendein Trainer aus persönlicher Vorliebe jemanden aufstellt oder nicht. Also es muss irgendeine Art von Überzeugung dahinter stecken. Und anstatt irgendwie seine Überzeugung, seine Sicht der Dinge irgendwie ändern zu wollen, kann man sich halt total leicht dahinter verschanzen, dass man sagt, naja, es hat er verpflichtet und die spielen jetzt.
Natürlich spielen die jetzt, ja. Und gab es da aber nie den Gedanken, dass du dir gedacht hast, geil jetzt noch mal mit Giovane Elber und Wesley Sonk hier im Training ein bisschen aufzubolzen und von Jörg Böhme mir die Schusstechnik am Freistoß abzugucken?
Na, es war schon auch eine geile Zeit. Also, so einen Elber dann noch mal in der Truppe zu haben, auch Christian Ziege war Wahnsinn. Also, der hat auch eine ganz andere Art Fußball gespielt. Der war auf so einem hohen Level, was da an Übersicht und One-Touch-Football, da waren so geil. Wesley Sonk, ein richtig geiler Kicker. Das war, fußballerisch war das eigentlich eine coole Zeit, aber ich war halt da eher so unsortiert eben. Also, ich glaube, dass ich in der ganzen Gladbacher Zeit, und leider muss ich das Gleiche dann noch mal sagen über die Kölner und Nürnberg Jahre und so, ich war einfach irgendwie durch vom Kopf. Also, ich konnte das Positive gar nicht so mitnehmen und so schätzen, wie das war, weil ich einfach so fokussiert war auf meinen eigenen kleinen Kram, irgendwie die Welt hat sich einfach nur um mich gedreht. Und hab mich halt nicht wirklich auch diesen Problem aus, mit dem Problem auseinandergesetzt oder die Lösungen finden wollen, die wirklich mich aus diesem Schlamassel wieder hätten ziehen können. Also, ich hab da oft auch einfach so den Rückzug gewählt und naja, also mich so ein bisschen abgekapselt mit dem Finger auf andere gedeutet. Und das war für mich irgendwie dann eine Rechtfertigung genug oder Erklärung genug.
Dick Advokat hat dann nicht mal eine Saison ausgehalten, wurde nach dem 29. Spieltag schon wieder entlassen. Letztendlich wurde der Klassenerhalt aber geschafft. Wie hat sich das für dich angefühlt? Ist man da mit dem Schicksal des Vereins noch wirklich verwoben? Weil wenn du jetzt die ganze Zeit betont, dass du ja damals sehr viel auf dich geguckt hast, war es für dich ja keine besonders gute Zeit und der Klassenerhalt ja dann irgendwie auch wurscht?
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Also das war dann echt eine Erleichterung, als dann Hausköppe kam und die letzten vier Spiele, habe ich ja dann glaube ich nochmal auch spielen dürfen und auch nochmal ein richtig großes Spiel daheim gemacht, irgendwie 2-0 gegen Stuttgart, glaube ich. Das waren die Spiele, die uns nochmal die Klasserin gesichert haben.
Von fünf Spielen, vier Unentschieden, ein Sieg, eine Niederlage, das waren die letzten fünf.
Also das war bemerkenswert damals in der Situation und da ging für mich persönlich auch nochmal was und da habe ich echt nochmal richtig dran geglaubt. Da war dieses geile Gefühl in Ansätzen auch wieder da. Also ich mochte auch wirklich Gladbach super gerne. Also ich fand diesen Verein, das ist ja nichts Greifbares, aber dieses Ding Traditionsverein, das gibt es ja nicht von ungefähr. Also du weißt einfach, wenn du in einem drin steckst. Und das hatte ich bei Gladbach halt immer. Es war irgendwie immer geil, diese Farben zu tragen. Und wenn du dann da wieder irgendwie auch eine entscheidende Rolle einnimmst, irgendwie auch mit den Fans wieder diesen Energieaustausch hast oder so, das war schon nochmal eine coole Normal. Die letzten Spiele gegen Ende der Saison kann ich mich echt gut erinnern.
Und wie hast du die Drucksituation erlebt, immer gegen den Abstieg kämpfen zu müssen? Also nicht immer, das war jetzt natürlich falsch, aber du hast ja immer mal wieder auch gegen den Abstieg gespielt.
Fand ich irgendwie nie tragisch. Ich glaube, weil ich es nie erlebt hab, wie es ist abzusteigen. Also ich hatte so einen Grundoptimismus, also so ein Ding, dass man es gar nicht vermöglich hält, bis es passiert. Und ich hatte das Glück, dass es einfach nie passiert ist.
Ja, das ist eigentlich eine sehr gute Beschreibung. Ja, spannend. Das würden sich so manch andere Fußballer tatsächlich wünschen. Dann kam die Saison 2005, 2006 und Untertrainer Horst Köppel, der eben übernommen hatte, nach Dick Advokaten. Es lief deutlich besser. Zwischenzeitlich war Gladbach sogar mal auf Rang 5. Aber du kamst fast gar nicht mehr über 90 Minuten zum Einsatz, hast zwei Tore geschossen, drei aufgelegt. Was war in der Zeit passiert? Warum warst du da nicht mehr für 90 Minuten die feste Stütze?
Ach, einfach nicht gut genug gespielt. Muss man echt sagen. Es waren immer wieder mal Momente da, aber in der Gesamtheit einfach nicht genug End-Product, also Tore Assists und auch von der körperlichen Präsenz, von der Beisicherheit oder so. Es war halt einfach im besten Fall durchwachsen und meistens einfach auch eher schlecht. Also es war nicht so, dass Köppel was gegen mich hatte. Ganz im Gegenteil. Er hat eigentlich anfangs mit, also gerade bei Per Kluge und bei mir echt versucht, uns total zu pushen. Aber ich hab das einfach leistungsmäßig nicht zurückzahlen können.
Das ist ja die Phase, wo auch viel drüber berichtet wurde, sicher auch, weil es erste Liga war, was du alles so neben dem Platz machst. Also es gibt sensationelle Bilder von dir in einem Töpferkurs, wo du einen griechischen Tempel mit dorischen Säulen, was, glaube ich, getöpfert hast. Du hast ein Philosophiestudium angefangen. Es gab eben diese Fotoshootings, wo du dich in Denkaprose mit einem Buch präsentiert hast. Wie war denn da so dein Leben als Fußballer und dein Leben als privater Mensch aufgeteilt? Wie wichtig war denn das, was du da neben dem Platz gemacht hast für dich?
Also bei mir war es immer so, die Sachen neben Platz wurden. Umso wichtiger, je schlechter es lief. Also hat mich irgendwie auf eine ungesunde Art immer noch gesund gehalten. Also ich habe mich mit den Problemen, die ich hatte, gar nicht wirklich auseinandersetzen müssen, weil ich immer tausend andere Dinge hatte, die irgendwie auch noch funktioniert haben. Und trotz allem muss man halt auch sagen, viel davon war halt echt Attitüde und auch dieses Darstellen in gewissen Medien oder so. Ich glaube, da hat auch diesen Aktivitäten die nötige Ernsthaftigkeit gefällt. Das war ja auch sporadisch. Also ich habe nicht irgendwie fünf Jahre Philosophie studiert und das zu Ende gebracht. Das war irgendwie mehr oder weniger eine Schnapsidee, einfach nur eine Laune, das mal zu machen. Ich glaube, ich wollte mich damals halt auch so sehen als der Typ, der halt auch andere Sachen macht und so. Aber da hat auch die letzte Überzeugung gefehlt. Und dann kommt er noch dazu, wenn du all diese anderen Sachen machst. Du hast ja gar nicht den Fokus auf deinem Kerngeschäft. Also wie sollst du dann im Beruf besser werden, wenn du dich mit deinem Beruf irgendwie als Allerletztes auseinandersetzt?
Na gut, wenn es deinen Kopf frei hält, dass du dann fokussierter trainieren und spielen kannst, dann kann das ja schon funktionieren. Also das ist eine Diskussion, die führt man aktuell rund um Jerome Boateng sehr gerne mit Bayern-Fans, wo einfach das Pauschale, der Pauschale-Vorwurf kommt, der macht so viel neben dem Platz. Und deswegen stimmt dann die Leistung auf dem Platz, nicht? Und ich finde, die Kausalkette, die kann man nicht immer so machen. Da müsste man mit jedem Spieler einzeln sprechen, ob es wirklich so ist.
Also da gebe ich dir total recht. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass ich später in guten Jahren irgendwie mich nur auf Fußball konzentriert habe. Also diese Elemente, die sind unfassbar geil. Also man kann ja auch abseits des Fußballs noch irgendwas erlernen wollen oder irgendwie coole Aktivitäten noch am Start haben. Aber man muss sich zu gleichen Teilen quasi damit auseinandersetzen.
Bei dir hat dieses Verhältnis nicht mehr gestimmt.
Sich überhaupt mit Fußball auseinandersetzen. Also wenn mich eigentlich der Fußball schon nicht mehr interessiert, sobald ich ins Auto einsteige oder so, dann haben wir ein Problem. Dann kann das ganze andere Leben noch so reichhaltig und cool und turbulent sein. Dann passt alles. Ich hatte auch in Köln eine Riesenzeit mit meiner WG und so weiter. Dann war alles halb so schlimm. Dadurch konnte ich auch so den ein oder anderen sportlichen Rückschlag viel, viel besser verkraften. Nur du gibst dir selber halt gar nicht die Chance, diese sportliche Situation auch zu ändern.
Ja, ja faszinierend. Und dann hat ja 2006 auch die WM stattgefunden im eigenen Land. Und in deinem allerersten aktuellen Sportstudio-Ausschnitt hatte ich damals noch Johannes B. Kerner gefragt, was so deine Ziele wären. Da hast du gesagt, da gibt es ja ein Turnier im eigenen Land. Das wäre schon so ein Ziel. Ich glaube, das war 2004. Und jetzt 2006 erlebst du diese WM im eigenen Land als Zuschauer. Hat das wehgetan? Hat dir das das was bedeutet?
Komischerweise nicht. Also ich war da schon an dem Punkt, da waren mir andere Sachen fast wichtiger als Fußball-Bundesliga oder Bundesligaspieler zu sein. Ich habe bei mir selber so ein bisschen Erfahrung gemacht, ich weiß nicht, ob man das so auf andere übertragen kann, aber wenn ich in irgendwas echt schlecht bin, dann versuche ich dem auch so ein bisschen die Wichtigkeit zu nehmen. Und nachdem diese ganze Bundesliganummer da so ein bisschen eine Krise war, also bei diversen Trainer nicht mehr wirklich gespielt und war einfach sehr kontroverse als Spieler, als Persönlichkeit und so, wollte ich eigentlich mit dem ganzen Business schon langsam nichts mehr zu tun haben und hab das so ein bisschen in die Ecke gestellt und auch für mich so ein bisschen negativ gebrandet. Das ist so von mir geschoben einfach. Und dadurch habe ich, glaube ich, auch diese anderen Sachen gar nicht so an mich angelassen. So, ja, okay, das hat Wm im eigenen Land. Cool, schau ich mir ein paar Spiele an, Fieber ein bisschen mit, aber ich hatte da emotional jetzt keinen so riesen Bezug dazu. Also es war für mich auch kein Beinbruch, da nicht dabei zu sein.
Krass, und wie hast du die Spiele dann verfolgt? Warst du in Deutschland, hast du Urlaub gemacht, wo warst du?
Ja, ich kann mich sogar erinnern, ein Spiel in Köln auf der Fan-Meile. Aber irgendwie so, na ja, also schon mitgefiebert, aber jetzt auch nicht mit so krassem Patriotismus.
2006 im Sommer, das war dann auch die Zeit, in der du zum ersten FC Köln gewechselt bist. Da solltest du dann drei Jahre spielen. Warum eigentlich der FC? Lokal-Rivale von Gladbach, zumindest Rivale, und die waren gerade abgestiegen in die zweite Liga.
Zwei Gründe, also zum einen kannte ich damals extrem viele Leute aus Köln. Cooler Studenten-WG, das könnte spaßig werden. Und das andere war, es war halt auch ein absoluter Traditionsverein. Das war mir echt wichtig. Also ich mochte dieses Gefühl bei Gladbach, in solchen Farben zu spielen und dachte mir...
Wobei schwarz und weiß ja eigentlich keine Farben sind, aber...
Aber das Lustige ist ja, für mich ist Gladbach trotzdem irgendwie grün. Also wenn sich ein Bild in meinem Kopf einstellt, sind es diese grünen Trikots und diese... Also wenn man sich im Verein irgendwie bewegt, kommt man auch nicht drum rum. Und ich wollte halt unbedingt so was Ähnliches haben. Also diese Tradition, diese Verrücktheit, diese geilen Stadien, diese coolen Fans und so. Und das habe ich mir halt von Köln auch versprochen.
Und in Gladbach ging es aber für dich nicht weiter?
Nee, da gab es in der Sommerpause einen Anruf von Jupp Heynckes, der irgendwie sich total korrekt halt gemeldet hat. Und meinte so, ich wollte mich mal kurz vorstellen und gleichzeitig aber auch dir mitteilen, dass es halt mit dir hier nicht weitergeht.
Und wie hast du das aufgenommen?
Relativ stoisch. Also ich habe mich irgendwie darauf eingestellt, der neue Trainer kommt, okay, beweist man sich neu, aber ist ja irgendwie legitim und fand das irgendwie auch cool, dass er das persönlich gemacht hat. Ja, damit war das durch.
Und war das für dich was Besonderes, halt zu einem Verein zu wechseln, wo jetzt nicht jeder Gladbacher gleich hurra geschrien hat?
Ja, also mir war die Brisanz schon bewusst, aber auf der anderen Seite, glaube ich, hast du als Profi, oder halt ich zumindest, zwar eine Bindung zu dem Verein. Also ich kann wirklich sagen, ich fand es geil, für Gladbach gespielt zu haben und finde den Verein nach wie vor auch extrem spannend, aber diese ganzen Rivalitäten, die Vereine so haben, irgendwie das habe ich so nie empfunden. Also das ist ja so ein Sakrileg irgendwie, also von Schalke nach Dortmund, von vielleicht auch Gladbach nach Köln ist ja nicht irgendwie so ein cooler Move oder so, aber da hat es bei mir irgendwie aufgehört, oder ich finde irgendwie, dass Vereine absolut geil sein können und sich aber nicht ausschließen müssen.
Ja, warum soll man auch diese lokalen Rivalitäten mitnehmen, wenn man ja eigentlich aus einer ganz anderen Region kommt? Das ist ja irgendwie auch nachvollziehbar. Es ging sehr, sehr gut für dich los. Hans-Peter Latour war damals dein Trainer. Im Kader waren Leute wie Stefan Wessels, Marvin Martib, Mille Voje Novakovic, Patrick Helmes, natürlich der ewige Matthias Scherz. Und du hast in den ersten fünf Spielen sechs Tore aufgelegt. Also das, was Dick Advokat gerne gesehen hätte, hast du dann bei Köln gemacht, unter anderem ja auch gegen Wacker. Am zweiten Spieltag war das in der Saison 2006, 2007. Dein Einstand in Köln lief also, dem äußeren Anschein nach, sehr gut.
Ja, es lief echt super und wir hatten damals auch eine coole Truppe, also talentiert und auch super Leute drin. Also alles, was du gerade aufgezählt hast, muss ich sagen, also denke ich unheimlich gern daran zurück. Charakterlich echt feine Burschen, lustige Kerle. Und es ist eigentlich total komisch, dass wir so geil losgelegt haben und dann kam diese allererste Niederlage irgendwie und dann gab es schon so ein kräftiges Rauschen im Blätterwald. Und damals war die Presse in Köln wirklich extrem und die Erwartungshaltung war so unfassbar brutal, dass es einfach nur kleine Rückschläge bedarf hat, sodass das Ding wirklich zum Kochen kam. Und da kam da so schnell so eine Unruhe, so ein Druck rein. Und das haben wir irgendwie als Truppe echt nicht verarbeitet gekriegt.
Wie geht denn dann der Trainer mit so was um? Also man kann es ja auch nutzen, um dann so einen Burgfrieden zu schließen. Das ist eine ganz berühmte Geschichte, die man sich hier über Felix Maggert in München erzählt. Also wenn man sich berühmte Geschichten über Felix Maggert hier erzählt. Aber dann ist es diese, dass er damals ein Vorkommnis, was in der Presse nach außen getragen wurde, was im Training passiert sei, damals als anders genommen hat, zu den Leuten zu sagen, guck mal, wir alle wissen, dass das genauso nicht passiert ist. Und wir gegen die, das ist der Grund, die schießen, die wollen, dass wir schlecht spielen, die wollen Unruhe reinbringen. Und er hat das dann verwendet. Das hat dann in der Saison auch gut funktioniert, um so ein Mannschaftsgefüge zusammenzuschweißen. Wie war das in der Phase? Und das war ja extrem. Ihr habt als Tabellenerster gegen Paderborn 2 zu 0 verloren. Dann erst mal 3 unentschieden, noch 2 niederlagen. Das war, als hätte man einen Stecker gezogen. Und man kann das sehr leicht nachrecherchieren, wie die Überschriften quasi, die Schriftgröße wurde immer größer und mehr Ausrufezeichen standen dahinter.
Ja, das ist echt brutal. Ich kann mich an eine Geschichte erinnern. Da war ein Foto von einem Spiel in der Zeitung, ich glaube, Salvatore Gambino. Also komplette Seite, mehr oder weniger. Und dann stand da irgendwie so zintgemäß, ja, so sieht ein Verlierer aus. Also es kann auch sein, manchmal erinnert man sich ja auch an Sachen und bläst die dann irgendwie total auf.
Okay, vielleicht was eine halbe Seite.
Ja, kann alles sein. Also das liegt so lange zurück, auch ein bisschen schwammig. Aber ich glaube, da hast du als Spieler auch so ein bisschen Schiss. Also du wirst nicht derjenige sein, der beim nächsten Mal so öffentlich gekreuzigt wird. Und wenn du halt dann eben nicht so ein Mentalitätsmonster bist, sondern durchaus auf Zuspruch und ein bisschen Liebe angewiesen bist, dann ist so ein rauses Umfeld natürlich Gift. Und ja, anscheinend war ich nicht der Einzige. Also wir haben da als Team verlegt den Faden verloren.
Hat ja dann auch nicht geklappt mit dem sofortigen Wiederaufstieg. Es gab allerdings ein Highlight, auch genau in dieser Phase, wo es auf einmal auf miraculöse Art und Weise auf einmal nicht mehr so gut lief. Nämlich das Zweitrundenspiel gegen den FC Schalke 04 habe ich vorhin schon angesprochen. Mit 2 zu 2 ging es da in die Verlängerung. Schalke hat sich da noch in die Verlängerung geschossen. Und dann hast du das 3 zu 2 in der 98. Minute selbst gemacht und das 4 zu 2 in der 111. Minute aufgelegt. Jetzt wissen wir ja alle, was danach noch so alles kam. War das das beste Spiel deiner Karriere?
Ja, ich glaube schon. Das lief irgendwie von der ersten Minute an echt super. Wir haben insgesamt auch geil gespielt. Auch wieder bezeichnet, die Schalke waren ja oben dran in der Bundesliga. Das war so dieses eine Spiel, wo wir keinen Druck hatten. Da gehen in Köln die Lichter an, Abendspiel, Pokal, irgendwie total besondere Atmosphäre. Als nichts zu verlieren. Und auf einmal fängst du wieder an, vernünftig Fußball zu spielen. Das ist schon absurd. Das ist irgendwie meiner Erinnerung in Deutschland auch das Spiel, das am allermeisten raussticht mit Abstand.
Und welche Rolle spielen bei solchen Spielen die Fans? Also bei diesen Spielern im Positiven und vielleicht bei anderen Spielen im Negativen?
Also ich finde, dass Fans tatsächlich eine Riesenrolle spielen. Und das die wirklich sehr oft ihrer Mannschaften einen Bärendienst erweisen. Also es gibt eigentlich nichts Schlimmeres als auch nur so ein Raunen, wenn Spieler eh schon verunsichert sind. Also du siehst es ja bei diversen Vereinen diese Saison wieder. Es ist unfassbar, was die für eine Energie erzeugen können im Positiven Sinne. Also wenn so ein Stadion abgeht, das ist eine Wucht, das ist ein Gefühl, das kannst du mit nichts vergleichen eigentlich. Also es ist schwer so ein Gefühl herzustellen im Alltagsleben. Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn du eh grad so psychisch so leicht labil bist und dann kommt so ein relativ tricky Ball auf dich zu. Einer, der so ein bisschen holprig daherkommt, vielleicht noch auf schlechten Rasen. Und du denkst dir irgendwie schon so bitte, bitte lass mich den Ball einfach nur vernünftig annehmen. Und dann geht das Ding schief und dann wird geraunt und beim nächsten Mal rauen sie schon während der Ball unterwegs ist. Also das hat definitiv einen brutalen Einfluss aufs Spiel. Und witzigerweise nicht so sehr die gegnerischen Fans. Also dass die dich beschimpfen, ist ja normal. Das ist ja im Zweifel irgendwie noch gut. Also das machen die ja vor allem eigentlich, wenn es bei dir gut läuft. Aber die eigenen Fans, die Unruhe, die da entstehen kann oder teilweise auch der Hass ist hoch gegriffen oder so. Aber da entgleisen ja manchmal auch die Emotionen stark. Das finde ich viel schlimmer. Also ein Auswärtsspiel per se, ich meine, Auswärtsspielen ist immer schwer, aber die Emotionen, die Stimmung empfinde ich nie als negativ oder nie als Problem. Ein Heimspiel, wo sich die eigenen Fans gegen dich wenden, das ist ein Riesenproblem.
Dahingehend war es ja dann vielleicht gar nicht schlecht, dass dann Christoph Daum kam, der ja eine ganz andere Aufbruchsstimmung transportiert hat, aber schon mit fast absurden Ausmaßen. Also das erste Training hat dann im Stadion stattgefunden vor ich weiß nicht wie vielen zigtausend Kölnern. Er sollte auf einmal dieses Baby da in der Hand halten und hat es wieder zurückgereicht in die Menge. Wie war das damals?
Absurd. Da tut sich, glaube ich, auch kein Verein mit gefallen damit. Das nimmt ja Züge einer Karikatur an. Man möchte wirklich als Verein total solide arbeiten. Aufs wirklich absolut Wesentliche beschränkt. Das was der FC ja dann später mal unter Schmatke und Stöger hingekriegt hat. Aber zu der Zeit waren wir ja irgendwie... Also Karnevalsverein trifft es ja da sogar noch. Was da und in der Folge, es ging mit der Vorstellung los, aber dann mit den ganzen Eskapaden und den Charakteren, die wir da irgendwie im Kader hatten oder so. Das ging ja so drunter und drüber. Da hat den FC in Deutschland keiner mehr ernst genommen.
Und hast du das damals auch schon so kritisch gesehen?
Ja, also das war ja klar, das war irgendwie... Das war so eine halbe Zirkusnummer. Also das sind keine guten Vorzeichen.
Und ist deine Meinung da auch so ein bisschen stellvertretend für die Mehrheit in der Mannschaft?
Boah, da möchte ich jetzt niemanden irgendwie was in den Mund legen.
Na aber wie seid ihr Christoph Daum begegnet? Es gibt ja auch wahrscheinlich, oder sehr wahrscheinlich, gibt es ja zwei Christoph Daums oder Daumlinge. Das eine ist der öffentliche, den auch ich wahrnehmen kann. Das andere ist derjenige, der in der Kabine steht.
Ich muss noch da ganz ehrlich sagen, ich finde es ist auch nicht allein die Schuld von Christoph Daum. Das wollte ich jetzt auch nicht sagen. Das ist so ein Kölner Phänomen, dass er da so vorgestellt wird und so ein Messias und Halsbringer ist. Dass er als Trainer da rumgeht, irgendwie auch normal. Und dann werden ihm da Babys entgegengehalten. Das ist einfach krass. Das musst du als Trainer, als Verein erst mal moderiert kriegen. Ich glaube, das ist uns einfach nicht gelungen. Und ich glaube schon, dass uns das als Spielern auch sehr, sehr bewusst war. Also wir hatten, glaube ich jetzt nicht unbedingt den Eindruck, dass wir irgendwie da als der seriöseste Club Deutschlands da standen in dem Moment. Und was Christoph Daum, die verschiedenen Seiten angeht, muss ich wirklich auch ganz klar sagen. Also gerade in der Doku gibt es ja diese eine Szene, wo wir irgendwie so gegeneinander reden. Und das ist irgendwie ganz clever gegengeschnitten. Und da kann man auch den Eindruck gewinnen, dass wir uns auch gar nicht so gut verstanden haben. Ich fand, dass Daum zum einen ein brutal akribischer Arbeiter war. Also der war unfassbar vorbereitet. Er hatte Aktenberge mit Datentrainingsübungen, Auswertungen über Jahre angesammelt. Also er war unheimlich gut vorbereitet. Fand ich mega beeindruckend. Und zum anderen hat er auch oft auch schützend seine Hand über mich gehalten. Also das ein oder andere Mal habe ich mir irgendwie was zur Schulden kommen lassen oder war durchaus angreifbar. Und der hat sich auf jeden Fall hinter seine Spiele gestellt. Also man pickt sich da manchmal so gewisse Sachen raus oder so ein gewisses Image. Und dann wird das, glaube ich, so ein bisschen einseitig. Und das gibt es auch. Aber es gab halt diese andere Seite, wo ich sage, ich komme echt auch gut mit dem aus und schätze ihn auch. Und das wird dann manchmal so ein bisschen verkürzt dargestellt. Eben auf diesen kleinen Dialog dann verkürzt und so. Da entsteht halt manchmal ein anderes Bild.
Du hast es gerade schon gesagt, wenn du dir mal was zu Schulden kommen lassen hast, dann hat er seine schützende Hand über dich gehalten. Du hast mal gesagt, Köln ist fatal in dem Sinne. Da hängen die Trauben sehr tief. Du kannst dir die Vergnügungen einfach runterpflücken. Und in der Doku sieht man dich in dieser Zeit auch zum Beispiel mit Kippe in der Hand. Waren das so die Dinge, die du dir zu Schulden hast, kommen lassen oder worum ging es da?
Ganz konkret fällt mir ein ganz lustiges Beispiel ein. Ich habe irgendwann mal Training verplant. Man hat angenommen, als die Mehrheit musste damals auch annehmen. Zu Recht, dass ich die Nacht durchgefallen habe und morgens es einmal nicht zum Training geschafft habe. Fakt war, ich habe einfach gedacht, es wäre Nachmittagstraining. Ich saß bei mir in der Wohnung, ganz normal Frühstück, Zeitung gelesen und so. Die Jungs waren am Trainieren. FC hat verzweifelt probiert, mich zu erreichen. Wann warst du nicht zu erreichen? Handy aus, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich saß ganz normal beim Frühstückstisch. Irgendwann klingelt es bei mir und ich mache die Tür auf. Mein Vereinsmitarbeiter stand da total aufgelöst. Wo bist du? Wir haben ein Training. In so einem Moment rutscht mein Herz in die Hose. Da denkst du dir so, oh nein. Jetzt geht es ab. Ich wusste ja, es war kein Geheimnis, dass ich damals auch öfter mal raus war. Mir war klar, dass das in Zusammenhang gebracht werden würde. Was machst du jetzt? Das Auto fährst du da hin, eine Viertelstunde muss ich fahren. Was mir da alles durch den Kopf gegangen ist. Dann komme ich zum Training, da stehen die Journalisten. Ich denke mir, was mache ich? Wie komme ich aus der Nummer raus? Dann bin ich so hinten rum, habe mich reingeschlichen und bin über einen Zaun gesprungen. Ich springe aus einem kleinen Ast, wie in einem schlechten Film. Und dann knackst das.
Alle drehen sich um?
Alle, wirklich mit ihren Objektiven und so. Die ganzen Journalisten alle. In dem Moment gibt es dieses Fight, Flight or Freeze Phänomen. Bei mir war es halt Freeze in dem Moment. Ich konnte mich für einen Bruchteil einer Sekunde nicht bewegen. Ich stand da einfach so auf frischer Tat ertappt. Dann hab ich es irgendwie versucht wegzulachen. Bin irgendwie in die Kabine rein. Und dann wurde halt Christoph Daum auf der PK dann drauf angesprochen. Und das war einfach sensationell. Der hat mich da so krass verteidigt. Der meinte dann im Grunde, das ist ganz allein, meine Entscheidung wäre, wie ich zum Training komme. Also der Grund, warum ich nicht beim Training war. Es waren medizinische Gründe. Und wie ich das Trainingsgelände betrete, das sei mir völlig freigestellt. Und jeder wusste halt in dem Moment...
Ja klar, welcher von den medizinischen Gründen springt dann über den Zaun?
Kann ja krippig gewesen sein, ist ja egal. Aber es geht halt darum, es wäre ein Einfaches gewesen, irgendwie dazu zu sagen, ja guck mal, hier mal ein Paradebeispiel, der hat Training verplant. Aber war halt schon cool und das war auch bezeichnend. Das war typisch für Christoph Daum. Also der hat seine Spieler nicht ans Messer geliefert. Selbst in der Situation, wo er sich ja irgendwo kompromittiert. Also das ist ja auch nicht einfach, da sowas rauszuhauen.
Klar, die Journalisten sagen, ey was willst du uns denn da erzählen?
Genau, aber einfach die Schützen eine Hand drüber gehalten. Und das sind Sachen, da bin ich ihm echt auch heute noch dankbar.
Das hat man der Geschichte und wie du sie erzählt hast auch angemerkt. Dann gab es ja in der Saison 2007, 2008 den Aufstieg mit Christoph Daum. Was war das für eine Zeit? Zu welchen Spielern hattest du einen besonders guten Draht? Welche Rolle hast du damals gespielt?
Einen guten Draht vor allem zu Patty Helmes, Schätzi, auch ein cooler Typ. Meine Rolle war dann sogar noch ganz positiv. Ich habe in der Rückrunde vor allem extrem viel gespielt. Ich glaube, wir hatten dann auch einen richtig guten Lauf. Wir haben das erste Rückrundenspiel noch verloren. Und dann, wenn mich alles täuscht, 15 in Folge nicht. Und dann erst wieder das bedeutungslose Spiel in Kaiserslautern. Da eben extrem viel gespielt. Und dann auch wieder dieses Gefühl. Das waren bei mir immer nur so kurze Momente. Jetzt bin ich in einem Verein auch angekommen. Jetzt bin ich wichtig für eine Mannschaft, für einen Verein. Und trage auch was zum Gelingen bei. Da dann aufgestiegen zu sein, war echt ein überragendes Gefühl.
Mit einem entscheidenden, voren entscheidenden Spiel zu Hause gegen Hoffenheim, da hattest du dir kurz vorher die Rippe gebrochen. Und jetzt gibt es so zwei Geschichten zu dieser Nummer. Die eine Geschichte war die, die man damals mitbekommen hat, dass du trotz dieser Rippenverletzung oder Rippenfellverletzung dann gegen Hoffenheim gespielt hast, 3 zu 1 gewonnen, Vorentscheidung im Kampf um den Aufstieg, ganz große Nummer. Und dann die zweite Geschichte, die man dann in der Doku erfahren hat, dann ein paar Jahre später, wo du in der Doku dann beschreibst, naja, du bist damals auch am Samstag vor diesem Spiel aus dem Krankenhaus ausgebüxt. Und als du wieder zurückkamst, haben die Ärzte festgestellt, das Rippenfell ist nicht so doll angewachsen, wie es hätte eigentlich anwachsen sollen. Was haben sie eigentlich gemacht?
Ja, das war eine dieser extrem dummen, unreifen Aktionen. Einfach, okay, die Rippe war angepiekt, musste halt ins Krankenhaus und das ist ja auch nicht weiter ein Ding. Wird halt wieder aufgepumpt und dann waren die Ärzte schon, ist alles okay, wir behalten dich über Nacht da und entlassen dich am Morgen. Und ich weiß echt nicht, was mich damals geritten hat, aber es war irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, es war so ein Programm von mir, dass ich unbedingt irgendwie, glaube ich, irgendwo anecken musste oder irgendwo über die Strengen geschlagen musste oder so. Da dachte ich halt, weißt du was, wenn doch eher alles gut ist, geh doch mal kurz in eine Bar. Ein Kumpel angerufen, raus aus dem Krankenhaus, am nächsten Morgen diese Untersuchung und dann sagen die, die Lunge ist wieder ein bisschen zusammengefallen. Es gab sogar jemanden, der ein Foto gemacht hat in dieser Bar, das dem FC geschickt hat. Und der FC das halt einfach als nicht glaubwürdig abgetan hat. Also total krass. Und dann kurze Zeit später kam ich halt raus, konnte dann auch schnell wieder trainieren. Und dann war eben dieses wichtige Spiel. Und es war noch ein geiles Spiel. Es war eine überragende Kulisse zu Hause. Und ich habe, glaube ich, leistungsmäßig da auch nochmal gut einen rausgehauen. Also es lief echt super. Und dann entstand da so eine kleine, ja so in Anführungszeichen, Heldengeschichte da drum. Und naja, also eigentlich habe ich mich bei der Sache auch wieder nicht mit Drogen bekleckert.
Und wie war es dann mit Köln aufzusteigen? Ist das nochmal eine andere Nummer als mit Burghausen, logisch?
An die Nacht kann ich mich erinnern. Das war gefühlt auch eine Woche Ausnahmezustand und gut mit den Jungs um die Häuser gezogen. Das war schon krass, egal wo du hinkommst, wie die Leute da feiern und abgehen und was das denen bedeutet. Das war eine Gefühlserexplosion, die auch echt eine Woche angehalten hat. Das war sensationell.
Und kann man da auch vergessen, dass zum Teil dieselben Leute noch ein Jahr vorher viel kritischer mit einem umgegangen sind, als der direkte Wiederaufstieg nicht geschafft wurde?
Ach, das war in dem Moment total egal. Es ist ein Druck von einem Abfeld. Und dass man es irgendwann auch mal genießen will, dass man nicht immer alles hinterfragen will. Sondern einfach, komm, jetzt haben wir es geschafft. Egal wie, es war ja auch irgendwie so ein bisschen mit Hängen und Wirken. Wir sind, glaube ich, als dritte aufgestiegen. Das ist ja jetzt auch nicht gerade ein Ruhmesblatt für einen FC, aber egal, wir sind halt wieder in der Bundesliga. Und danach lächst diese Stadt halt einfach.
Und wie war dann diese Erstligasaison für dich? 2008, 2009 war das dann. Du hast genau zwei Spiele über 90 Minuten gemacht, noch zwei weitere über 80 und 86. Warum warst du dann in der ersten Mannschaft nicht mehr präsent?
Ja, auch wieder Leistungsgründe. Also das war so, ich war in der Vorbereitung eingeplant, durfte dann auch spielen. Wurde dann aber auch immer wieder rausrotiert. Und aus der Zeit gibt es irgendwie eine ganz lustige Geschichte. Da waren Studenten beim Training. Und irgendeinen von diesen Studenten habe ich da mal getroffen, Jahre später, und der meinte dann zu mir, du ganz ehrlich, ich habe Training geguckt bei euch. Und die Art und Weise, wie du trainiert hast, und du warst noch in der A-Mannschaft irgendwie, das hat eigentlich so gewirkt, als würdest du gar nicht spielen wollen. Und das fand ich auch total krass von jemandem, der von außen so unbeteiligt guckt. Und es war ziemlich gegen Anfang der Saison noch. Also ich war eigentlich drin in der Mannschaft. Und ja, also der fand so in Sachen Einsatz, Körpersprache oder so, er meinte, du ganz ehrlich, also ich war eigentlich Fan von dir, ich wollte, dass du spielst, aber ich habe Training geguckt und mir war eigentlich klar, der wird dich rausnehmen.
Und hatte er denn Recht? Wolltest du nicht spielen?
Nein, das würde ich niemals so sagen. Also manchmal frage ich mich echt, wie weit habe ich mich denn selber auch sabotiert? Also es kann doch nicht sein, dass der Trainer das so wahrnimmt, dass ein Student, der einfach mal Training gucken kommt, das so wahrnimmt und dass ich mir gar nicht im Klaren bin, dass ich genau das mache.
Wer hat denn in der Zeit so dann noch einen Zugang zu dir gefunden? Weil es wird ja klar, du hast jetzt diesen einen Studenten, der dir das gesagt hat, aber dir wird ja Christoph Daum auch hin und wieder mal sportlich gesagt haben, was da noch fehlt zur ersten Mannschaft und ja auch viele andere aus deiner direkten Umgebung auch.
Nee, zu der Zeit gar nicht. Also da muss ich echt nur meine Mom zitieren. Das kam erst Jahre später, dass ich auch bereit war, diese Zeit aufzuarbeiten und das auch selbstkritisch zu sehen. Meine Mom meinte eigentlich, in den Jahren hatte die kompletten Zugang zu mir verloren. Also die konnten mir gut zureden, wie sie wollte. Keine Chance. Und ich glaube, das war nicht nur meine Mom, sondern das waren wahrscheinlich alle. Also Berater, Freunde. Ich glaube, es war einfach zu der Zeit nahezu unmöglich wirklich zu mir durchzudringen.
Und deine Position war dann die des Trotzigen, dass du gesagt hättest, hey, ich hätte eigentlich jedes Recht jetzt hier in dieser Erstligasaison eine Rolle zu spielen und mir wird das verwehrt.
Ja, irgendwie so ein bisschen, okay, jetzt mit gefühlt Lungenschuss irgendwie aufgestiegen mit dem FC. Und dann, ja, komme ich halt einfach nicht zum Zug. Irgendwie eine gefühlte Ungerechtigkeit, irgendwie auch so ein bisschen Story of my life. Es klappt schon wieder nicht. Und irgendwie so ein ganz ungesunder Fatalismus. Also ich glaube einfach, dass ich nicht wirklich dagegen aufbegehrt habe. Oder es ist ja noch nicht mal ein Aufbegehren. Also ich war einfach total verantwortungslos mir selber gegenüber. Ich glaube, ich hätte viele Chancen gehabt, das in der Bundesliga auch immer wieder und nochmal zu schaffen. Und Trainer waren mehr als gewillt, mir eigentlich die Chance zu geben. Aber das ist die einzige Sache, die ich nicht wirklich festmachen kann an irgendwas. Ich scheine irgendwie sowas Destruktives eher in mir getragen zu haben, also auf meine eigene Karriere, auf meine eigene Person bezogen.
Hast dann auch immer weniger eine Rolle gespielt, dann zuletzt dann gar nicht mehr so häufig überhaupt noch im Kader gestanden. Und dann kam dein letzter Wechsel innerhalb der Bundesliga zum ersten FC Nürnberg im Jahr 2009. Und du hattest aber gar nicht so wirklich den Plan, noch mal in der Bundesliga zu bleiben. Ich habe da was gelesen von den San Jose Earthquakes, zu denen du wechseln wolltest.
Ich habe es damals probiert, auch Australien schon, witzigerweise Adelaide, und die haben einfach gesagt, nein danke.
Die haben sich später nochmal bedankt. Das ist lustig, ne?
Dann wurde Michael Oening Trainer in Nürnberg und er hat sich einfach ganz weit zurück geändert und dachte, der war doch mal ein junger Kerl, der konnte auch eigentlich kicken.
Der war Co-Trainer unter Holger Fach und dann auch später unter Dick Advokat, daher kanntest du ihn aus Gladbach.
Genau, also der hat diese gute Anfangszeit mitbekommen, mit dem habe ich mich auch menschlich super verstanden. Ist ja auch einer der breit gestreute Interessen, der hat mir auch damals ab und an mal Bücher zum Lesen gegeben. Das war irgendwie so diese Art von Mensch.
Der kennt das auch mit den Schubladen, der saß einmal am Klavier irgendwann und eine Kamera hat es abgefilmt und fortan war er immer der Pianist in den journalistischen Darstellungen.
Ganz genau. Hat für mich einfach Sinn gemacht, da nochmal hinzugehen, das da nochmal zu probieren, weil wenn es der nicht hinkriegt, wie er kriegt es dann hin. Und nachdem es auch da nicht geklappt hat, da war mir dann auch spätestens klar, dass es nicht an den anderen liegen kann. Mehr an Trainer geht ja nicht. Wenn der mich holt, wenn der mich kennt aus früheren Zeiten, wenn der mich mag als Person, also wir haben heute noch ein Riesendraht, wenn der mich nicht aufstellt, dann muss ich schlecht sein. Aber dann reicht es an irgendeiner Ecke einfach nicht. Egal, was das sein mag, Potenzial, Bereitschaft, Einstellung, Teamfähigkeit, aber es reicht einfach nicht. Dann kam dieses, ich muss aber auch raus. Ich möchte auch nicht mit Erwartungen konfrontiert sein. Egal, wo man dann wieder hingeht. Wenn ich in die 2. Liga gewechselt wäre, hätten da Leute auch wieder was erwartet.
Jeder kennt deine Geschichte.
Ich wollte einfach bei Null anfangen und weit weg. Das war wirklich diese Flucht. Das war mein einziger Reflex. Da ging es nicht darum, fußballerisch noch mal irgendwas zu reisen. Einfach raus aus der Nummer. Und dann auch in der Folge tief ins Spiegel schauen. Sich selber mal ein bisschen verstehen. Vielleicht auch als Mensch einen Schritt voranzukommen.
Du hattest zu Saisonbeginn gleich eine Verletzung. Das war natürlich auch denkbar schlecht. Führte auch zu einer Auseinandersetzung mit Önning. Und Konkurrent auf deiner Position war EK. Gündogan. Jetzt warst du zu dem Zeitpunkt 28 Jahre alt. Gündogan war dann quasi dein Spiegel. So wie es früher war, als du bei Wacker angefangen hast, als du zu Gladbach gekommen bist. Auf einmal war da ein anderer, der gesagt hat, fußballerisch habe ich es aber doch mehr drauf und der dich verdrängen konnte. Wie bist du mit diesem Konkurrenzkampf umgegangen? Kanntest du das überhaupt aus der Position?
Nicht wirklich. Ich glaube, ich habe mich damals auch noch nicht so alt gefühlt, aber bei Ili war es halt auch klar, es kommt dafür ein Fußballer um die Ecke.
Das konntest du damals auch schon so sehen?
Nicht immer. Also in guten Momenten ja, in schlechten nicht, wie es immer so ist. Aber vom Tempo, von der andere Schnelligkeit, auch vom Spielverständnis, wie Ili damals schon mit dem ersten Kontakt immer aufgedreht hat, also ich hab das ja vorher versucht mal zu beschreiben, was ja so schwierig ist hier, nur über Audio, aber dass man quasi nicht immer wieder um den Gegner rumgeht, um ihn dann ausspielen zu müssen. Ili konnte quasi mit dem ersten Ballkontakt schon Leute ausspielen. Das waren einfach so Sachen, die hatte ich nicht drauf. Auch Torgefahr, Schusstechnik oder so. Das war einfach ein anderes Level.
Du hast nur neun Spiele gemacht für den Club, warst viel verletzt und in der Doku sprichst du davon auch in sehr eindrücklichen Worten, dass du eine Art Fußballdepression hattest. Das sind jetzt deine Worte. Du sprichst auch davon in Interviews, dass du fast schon psychosomatische Schmerzen hattest. Da war keine Grundmotivation mehr her, da überhaupt noch zum Training zu gehen.
Da muss man total vorsichtig sein. Das Wort Depression ist ein großes. Ich würde Leuten zur nahe treten, die es wirklich am eigenen Leib erfahren haben. Das komische Wort Fußball-Depression und auch beim psychosomatischen, das waren keine Schmerzen. Das Ding war einfach, das war so, dass ich in dem Moment, wo ich wusste, ich muss irgendwie zum Training, dass sich in mir was zusammengezogen hat, dass ich irgendwie überall anders lieber sein wollte, als jetzt da hinzufahren. Dann stand ich auf dem Platz und hatte Blei in den Adern. Das meine ich mit psychosomatisch. Diese Leichtigkeit, diese Spritzigkeit. Das, was du im Idealfall hast, hat sich so krass ins Gegenteil verkehrt. Ich hab das Gefühl, als wäre alles ungelenk an mir und steif und schwer. In dem Zustand Fußball zu spielen, ist ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit. Da ist sehr klar, dass du jeden Sprint verlierst, dass deine Reaktion langsam ist, dass dein erster Ballkontakt in den meisten Fällen schlecht ist. Das war eine richtig, richtig fiese Zeit. Ich hatte Gott sei Dank das Glück. Ich glaube, das ist die Kehrseite des Ganzen. Dieses ganze Gedöns, was ich immer abseits des Platzes hatte, das hat mich da auch ein Stück weit über Wasser gehalten. Ich konnte trotzdem Musik machen und Bücher lesen und mit meinen Leuten cool sein.
Und hast du das auch noch gemacht in der Zeit?
Na klar, hier war Training und das war natürlich superoptimal, aber ich konnte einfach dann das auch abkapseln, wegstecken und dann gab es noch was anderes in meinem Leben. Deswegen würde ich auch ganz eindeutig sagen, ich hatte kein Problem grundsätzlich mit meiner Psyche im weitesten Sinne. Ich denke mal, dass jemand, der Depressionen hat, dass sich das ein ganzes Leben ausweitet, ich hätte das Glück, dass das wirklich auf den Fußball in ein paar Monaten beschränkt war.
Das heißt, jetzt auch eine Rückschau würdest du sagen, du hättest damals nicht unbedingt einen Psychologen besuchen müssen oder es wäre vielleicht auch von Vereinsseite aus, wenn man das irgendwie bemerkt hätte, gut gewesen, dir da zu helfen?
Ich würde sagen, dass es mega viel gebracht hätte. Also, egal ob Psychologe oder nur Life Coach. Also, ich denke mal, wenn mir einer irgendwie damals meine Muster hätte spiegeln können und wirklich zu mir durchdringen hätte können und mir anschaulich machen können, was ich eigentlich durch mein Verhalten für mich selber verursache, wenn ich diese Kausalitäten irgendwie aufgezeigt bekommen hätte und verstanden hätte, also zu jedem Zeitpunkt, nicht nur in Nürnberg, sondern auch in Köln oder Gladbach oder so, da hätte so vieles anders laufen können. Also, ich wusste einfach nicht um die Prozesse im Menschen, um Ängste, Motivation, Umgang mit Druck, irgendwie diese ganze rebellische Haltung. Das lässt sich ja erklären. Und das lässt sich auch irgendwie kanalisieren und uminterpretieren. Und ich glaube, dass man aus Menschen produktive, kreative Sachen rausholen kann, selbst wenn der eine oder andere gerade mal in einer Lebenskrise ist. Also, ich bin ein riesen Befürworter von psychologischem Arbeiten. Man muss halt immer aufpassen. Also, in dem Moment, wo du die Frage stellst, dann denke ich mir schon, na okay, wenn ich jetzt im Zusammenhang mit Psychologe zitiert werden sollte, und ich sage, ich hätte damals einen Psychologen gebraucht, das würde ich auch jetzt immer noch nicht gern in der Zeitung lesen. Aber grundsätzlich bejahe ich das total.
Bei der Begriff, dass Psychologen stigmatisiert ist, oder weil man selbst stigmatisiert ist, wenn man zum Psychologen geht, weil man diese Schwäche, die ja eigentlich keine Schwäche ist, nicht zeigen will. Warum eigentlich?
Es hat immer noch sowas von Krankheit. Und ich glaube das eigentlich.
Aber eine Krankheit ist ja auch heilbar.
Ja, und das Ding ist ja auch heilbar. Das meine ich ja eben. Das sind ein paar Schaltkreise, die neu justiert werden müssen. Und du bist wieder on track. Es ist ja keiner irgendwie ein lost case, of course. Man muss ein gewisses Bewusstsein entwickeln. Methoden auch, wie man sich selber umprogrammiert. Weil wenn gewisse Programme über fünf Jahre ablaufen, kriegst du ja auch nicht über Nacht einfach nur den Schalter geswitcht und jetzt verhalte ich mich anders. Also erstmal verstehen, was falsch läuft, dann so ein bisschen umprogrammieren und dir selber jede Chance geben, um im Leben wieder erfolgreich zu sein. Und mit erfolgreich mache ich nicht irgendwie 100 Bundesligaspiele machen, sondern einfach nur wieder kritikfähig zu sein, irgendwie sich nicht abzukapseln, irgendwie als soziales Wesen wieder aufzugehen. Also so ganz banale Dinge, die dann auch automatisch wieder in Erfolg münden.
Darüber haben wir am Anfang gesprochen. Das war dann das, was du quasi in Australien erleben durftest. Du hast später mal gesagt, du hast in deinem Kopf da ein bisschen aufgeräumt. Das hast du jetzt ja wieder so ein bisschen angedeutet. In der Rückschau hattest du ja eine sehr interessante Karriere mit so vielen Geschichten. Und wir haben ja sogar jetzt noch manche Dinge hier weggelassen. Wie würdest du denn selbst deine Zeit als Profifußballer einordnen? Bist du froh, dass du sie hattest?
Auf jeden Fall. Also mega geile Zeit. Hat sich nicht immer so angefühlt, als ich mittendrin gesteckt bin. Aber das muss es auch nicht immer. Also auch Fehler machen, auch mal leiden oder so. Ich glaube, wenn man irgendwie die Chance hat, daraus zu lernen, dass es eigentlich was Geiles ist. Also klingt total nach Platitüde, aber es ist ja schon oft so, dass man sich selber mehr hinterfragen muss oder mehr aus Situationen lernt, wenn man den Kahn irgendwie an die Wand fährt oder wenn was nicht so läuft. Also in der Volkssituation.
Da hinterfragt man sich ja.
Die ersten Jahre in Burghausen oder Gladbach oder so habe ich ja nicht drüber nachgedacht, was ich falsch oder richtig mache. Es lief einfach. Und diese lange Periode des Misserfolgs, die hätte ich gerne abgekürzt. Also verstehe ich nicht falsch. Ich brauche das nicht. Und das ist auch echt eine harte Zeit gewesen. Und da fällt man dann schon durchaus auch vom Glauben ab. Aber auf der anderen Seite, es führt dazu, dass man empathiefähiger wird, dass man irgendwie viel, viel selbstkritischer wird. Und ich glaube, dass das Lektionen sind, die für das weitere Leben halt unbezahlbar sind. Und jetzt bin ich 38, das heißt, ich habe noch 40 Jahre vor mir. Und ich glaube, vieles von dem hätte ich niemals gelernt, wenn ich nicht als Profi sein dürfen. Und dazu kommt ja noch, also dieses Profi-Ding an sich, irgendwie, dass man viel reist, irgendwie vor 80.000 Leuten Fußball spielen darf, auch viel Freizeit hat und so. Man nimmt es nicht immer so wahr als Profi, aber es ist ja ein absolutes Geschenk.
Ja, das hast du ja vorhin schon angesprochen, mit dem Jammern, was man auch gerne macht als Profi. Wenn du die Möglichkeit hättest, in jedes Nachwuchsleistungszentrum und in jedem DFB-Stützpunkt einen Satz an die Wand zu schreiben, sodass in jeder oder die meisten der deutschen Nachwuchskicker sehen, was würdest du diesen jungen Spielern, diesen jungen Menschen mit auf den Weg geben wollen?
Ich glaube, es ist ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit, das in einem Satz zu sein.
Du darfst auch mehr verwenden.
Ich glaube, ich würde in die Richtung gehen, es muss nichts Zitatreifes sein, aber diese jungen Menschen können von den älteren brutal viel lernen, ohne dass sie es in dem Moment checken. Wenn man da ein Bewusstsein für schaffen würde, das wäre schon brutal. Wenn du es schaffst, als junger Mensch zuzuhören und zu reflektieren, was du gerade machst und was das für Konsequenzen für dich hat, damit wär unfassbar viel geworden.
Halte deine Ohren offen oder hört auf die Alten. Schreib mir doch einfach hört auf die Alten an alle Wände. Hier in Bayern kommst du damit sehr gut an in einem CSU-regierten Land. Da hören das die Eliten sehr gerne, wenn auf die Alten gehört wird. Thomas, ich könnte noch über ganz viele Dinge mit dir sprechen. Wir lassen jetzt den ganzen Teil, was du jetzt aktuell eigentlich machst, weg. Und vielleicht holen wir das einfach nochmal an anderer Stelle nach. Ich danke dir sehr, dass du dir so viel Zeit genommen hast für den Rasenfunk. Mir auch, mir auch. Ich hoffe euch auch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern. Das war Tribünengespräch Nummer 29 mit Thomas Broich. Ich werde noch ein paar interessante Artikel und Videoschnipse, die man so finden kann, auf YouTube in den Show notes verlinken. Wenn ihr immer noch nicht genügt habt von Thomas Broich, dann könnt ihr euch da noch ein bisschen weiterbilden. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit und danke für eure Unterstützung. Wir hören uns wieder in der nächsten Folge des Rasenfunks. Macht's gut, ciao! Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.